make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so following extremists I was I was
in kind of a weird spot honestly I'm
really just kind of experimenting on you
guys I'm experimenting in so far that I
am curious how you guys respond to
covering older videos instead of all
nude all-new all-different marvel until
like August or September so when like
Marvel Legacy drops versus how you guys
respond to covering all-new
all-different marvel stuff I mean
there'll be a few things here and there
that we cover like old man Logan and
Ultimates and stuff like that but
because it takes six months to finish a
story you know I was like well we can
kind of cover some older stuff in
between so I'm just kind of curious to
how you guys respond to that whole thing
but as I was thinking about that there
were two different routes that we could
have taken with Iron Man we could have
covered Iron Man vol 4 or we could have
covered Iron Man vol 5 4 is longer than
5 in 5 of course you know being newer is
more modern and really kind of ties into
a lot of what people are talking about
in terms of what's going on with fireman
right now and so I figured we kind of do
5 since we could probably get about 6 or
7 videos out of it and then call it a
day and that'll really give me a good
litmus test and how you guys respond to
things so if all the time this is all
said and done you guys make it clear the
eatest don't care about older stuff and
you want all-new all-different marvel
then we'll switch back to that we may be
able to find a happy balance with both
but with regards to this when one of the
other reasons that I chose that is
because with extremists fresh on our
minds this one deals directly with the
fallout of that but there are a couple
of things to run over specifically with
volume 4 nothing super complicated
nothing really difficult or convoluted
with the character of Maya Hansen for
example she was basically arrested at
the end of the extremis storyline in
volume 4 released on parole and then she
went to go work for shield and Tony
Stark because at the time Tony Stark was
director of shield following the events
of civil war and so because of that it
was really just kind of her approving
the fact that she was more or less
reformed the whole idea with extremis
was just kind of part of her past and
she was ready to let that go
and that was really yet I mean it was
just kind of a way to you know build her
character a bit the other half of this
is that in the post-civil war landscape
Iron Man vol 4 stretched through a lot
of things and went all the way up till
like siege and so on and so forth
what ended up happening is going into
season really even after the events of
Civil War when Tony Stark's moral
compass was called into question the
idea that maybe he had been fighting on
the wrong side for all the wrong reasons
he more or less kind of suffered this
crisis of conscience so after being
ousted as director of shield he
basically formed a company called stark
resilient
which basically served the purpose of
being like a more economic friendly arm
where Sark International was more of
like a weapons manufacturing arm of
stark resilient was gonna focus more on
the everyday thing so just improving
technology overall for the betterment of
society itself the issue with this is
that it made him a target for a multiple
you know multitude of different people
you know injure those that he cared
about Pepper Potts and so on and so
forth and so Tony Stark actually left
resilient and made Pepper Potts the CEO
so those are guys who were who were
reading like superior Ironman that's
where that came from
volume four has some cool things here
and there but I think the volume five is
more pertinent to just cool Ironman
stuff now this particular story arc is
called believe and what this does is
deal with the fallout of extremis and it
tells us that extremists did not go away
that's extremis is very much there now
what we do here is we actually pick up
in buoyance Aires Argentina with Maya
Hansen now the crazy thing about this is
that she's being pursued by aim advanced
idea mechanics now here's the thing
advanced idea mechanics originally
started out as like the science
technology arm of Hydra with the goal of
world domination
eventually aim broke away from Hydra
following the death of Baron von
Strucker and became their own
organization but they still have the
same goal of like dominating the world
but for example advanced idea mechanics
were the first ones to create a cosmic
cube and so again they they have all
kinds of different you know studies and
so on but extremis is just another
instance of them trying to launch a plot
that will see them you know trying to
secure world domination and so the
result of this is that by Hansen inner
panic sends out an automated message
Tony Stark gets it and basically it's
her saying look you know this is an
automated message informing you that if
you get this I'm likely dead and
extremists is on the loose again now
this is kind of cool because the first
place we go to is basically one group
this managed to take hold of extremists
and this is basically just an
organization that's more or less
advanced idea mechanics of themselves
now of course the cool thing about this
is that a lot of what we end up seeing
here you know in this conflict between
Tony Stark the fact that he basically
has armor that's in a liquid state this
all really kind of lays the groundwork
for like into sim armor for example that
he has if superior Iron Man different
things like that and that's why I said
volume 5 is a little more pertinent in
terms of Iron Man and as far as you guys
think of him because of the fact that
there's so many interesting things in
here that lay the groundwork for what
comes later of course really all
stuff you know Indus in the whole nine
yards that whole predecessor was
extremists the fact remains here that
Tony Stark basically locating finding am
getting a hold of their head guys was
really quick and it was really simple I
mean aim was purporting that extremists
would be like the next stage and
technology or set along those lines and
the idea was to basically use it for
their own ends and of course the
question that Tony Stark has is where is
the rest of extremis what's going on
here now eventually he manages to find
himself mixed up with some of the guise
of advanced idea mechanics who have
reached beyond and actually have a place
called new Avalon now Tony Stark himself
as Iron Man has intrigued
quite a few people in this particular
instance is really more like a battle
it's more of like a conflict what these
guys have done is they have taken an
extremist they've made it into actual
armor sand them brought in basically
people who specialize in a multitude of
different things whether it's
hand-to-hand combat being a pilot
whatever the case may be and the idea
here is to run a gauntlet can may be as
good as tony stark because keep in mind
in the realm of marvel comics when it
comes to like mechanized suits or
technology or something like that Tony
Stark is the number one guy in terms of
weaponizing technology now in terms of
overall intelligence it's kind of a
toss-up I mean an all-new all-different
marvel they established that moon girls
like the smartest girl on the planet but
prior to that it was like Reed Richards
valaria Richards and Doctor Doom who
held the number one spot and now who it
was it was actually number one would
changed based on the story where those
three were generally the smartest people
on planet in terms of weaponizing
technology Tony Stark is the number one
guy and the Iron Man suit is the title
to beat if these guys these pilots and
these extremist suits can beat Ironman
that it means that this weapon is a
success that you know extremists as has
been used by this organization will
effectively work they can in turn build
more suits hand those over and be can't
you know gain new contracts with the US
government to really replace what it is
that Tony Stark does now the cool thing
about all this is that it basically
creates a scenario whereby time and
himself is basically able to function at
peak capacity and what I mean by this is
Tony Stark's armors are usually modular
whenever it comes to like you know the
different equipment and stuff that he
uses and what that means is that
different aspects of this suit can be
detached and something else can be put
in its place and that's really the
nature of it here is an invitation to
use all the tools at his disposal and
see if they can face off against each
one of these individual guys and
most part he's successful he manages to
stave off the attacks of almost every
single one of these guys the goal is
that if he wins he ultimately gets to
take the extremists with him and so the
cool thing about this is that some of
these guys specialize in hand-to-hand
combat and the suits reflect that
accordingly in the sense of they're
really more kind of in Tony Stark's face
punching kicking so on and so forth
others are better at flight a diverting
attack playing more defensively as it
was really kind of cool to see how these
armors relate to what it is that Iron
Man has but at the end of the day they
are not Tony Stark they do not have the
ability to capitalize on their own
skills in the same capacity that Tony
Stark has the ability to capitalize on
his and so of course finding these guys
really serves as a distraction and what
he basically does it's just kind of
snatch up the extremis kit and then just
take off I mean really the most
dishonorable way to in the conflict to
just kind of grab the thing and then
just bolt and that's really yet I mean
it's kind of it's kind of a crappy thing
to do but what this is designed to do is
basically give us a tour of how
extremists can be used in different ways
this next guy actually uses it for
medical purposes and it's really kind of
cool again because of the fact that Maya
hits sent Tony Stark a notification
saying hey look here are the versions of
extremists that have managed to get out
here are their you know unique identity
signatures it's basically just tracking
down these different locations traveling
to those locations and facing off
against people the other half of this is
we actually get to see a little bit of
expansion on the various suits that Tony
Stark uses for example one of these
suits is one where he basically has the
ability of camouflage where he can bend
light around himself now if you're
interested in the different suits that
Tony Stark uses I have like four or five
videos that I did where we basically run
over each one of his suits and what it
is that they're capable of doing again
this one in particular is one that we
had referenced previously where he's
able to basically bend light around
himself to either make him invisible or
to camouflage himself and create
Holograms but once he ends up getting
into this particular building where this
extremist kid is being located at and he
gets down to the basement he actually
finds a girl in bed but then also comes
across some members of his rogues
gallery now this is also kind of cool
because it shows us some of the other
ways that extremists can be used not in
the sense of creating suits of armor but
in the sense of enhancing people's
already existing abilities the living
laser firebrand fibro these are guys
that have their own intrinsic
capabilities and powers for example
firebrand manipulates fire under normal
circumstances she's
real threat to Tony Stark but with
extremist enhancements her powers are
pushed that much further not only that
because designed to enhance the human
body her physical agility her strength
so on and so forth all these things are
increased now again Tony Stark is coming
out of all of this having dealt with
extremists before and so it's not like
he's taken by surprise the same way he
was with Malin instead all of his suits
were upgraded to be able to with span
virtually any scenario when it comes to
the extremist tech go sit down and he'll
encounter a situation that he's never
met before
he'll overcome his situation and then
he'll sit down and say okay under what
circumstances could I can I encounter
this scenario again what million ways
could this scenario play out and then
every last one of his suits will be
upgraded to meet that particular
scenario in this instance because of the
fact that this is rogues gallery he's
fought all these different guys time and
time again his suits are already
equipped for the most part to be able to
handle that and truth you know these
guys are taken out pretty easily I mean
their defeat it pretty readily but of
course for the living laser having
charged through a wall what this does is
it tells Tony Stark
that he probably charged through
multiple walls meaning that just
following the holes in the wall is
basically what it is but the fact
remains that once he gets inside this
room this is an instance where not
everybody who captures extremists uses
it for nefarious ends and this
particular guy that has a daughter
that's basically dying of cancer and the
idea was to use extremis for the purpose
of trying to find a way to cure her the
issue here is that this guy does not
know the ins and out of extremists he's
smart but he doesn't quite know how to
use it or how to modify it in a way that
will benefit his daughter and so what he
did is he actually kidnapped several
people are you several people and
injected them with extremists hoping
that he'd be able to find a way to
basically cure his daughter the issue is
that you know for the first person
it didn't matter they effectively ended
up dying for the second person they were
cured but his daughter is extremely sick
in the same capacity as the first person
and so really you know what seems to be
the case that there's no way for his
daughter to be rescued in comes Tony
Stark with an inoculation that's
basically going to cure this guy's
daughter but the problem with this is
that this guy broke the law despite his
desperation despite the fact that he
wanted to keep his daughter safe at the
end of the day he still broke the law
and so the result of this is that he's
basically going to be arrested and taken
to jail but his daughter's gonna live so
again it's kind of a cool scenario to
see how Tony Stark deals with these
different versions of the extra
this virus snuffer here we switch over
to the catacombs in Paris if you guys
have read a chance you should definitely
look it up there are people who will
like party like they'll go and they'll
have parties and stuff like that and
they'll go into the catacombs especially
like if they're not from France they'll
get lost and they'll die they'll starve
to death because it is a labyrinth down
there it's absolutely insane with
regards to this whole thing in Paris
Tony Stark of course realizes that one
of the signals is coming from the
catacombs now the catacombs themselves
are a small tight space which means
there's no real room for maneuverability
and so Tony Stark plans accordingly and
basically adopts one of the newest
versions of the Hulkbuster armor now
this is a Hulkbuster slash a general
tank all-purpose suit in the sense that
it's not designed explicitly for the
Hulk but it certainly can help so once
he gets down there what he finds is a
veritable bloodbath I mean it's
absolutely insane there's just body
parts just pieces of scientists all over
the place well of course this leads him
to coming across something like twelve
or thirteen women who have these
different edgings carved on their faces
now this is when things get kind of
weird and in truth it's played pretty
fast and loose I mean the idea from one
of the scientists seems to be that they
were trying to resurrect the great black
infinite we're not told what that is
honestly it doesn't matter it's really
just kind of curing Gillen saying these
are crazy religious fanatics you know
and as a result they ended up just
creating monsters with no understanding
of what it was that they were doing but
this tells us that basically when
extremists went up Maya Hansen was
forced to recreate it by aim and it was
sold by aim it was pay man whoever wants
to buy it can have it we don't care what
you do with it and so again it's really
kind of wild here just because of the
fact that one of the scientists has left
tries to take out Tony Stark of course
he fails but in doing so where this
scientists had all these different you
know edgings and stuff around the door
in order to keep himself protected with
the door destroyed the protections no
longer there and this guy's basically
just kind of torn to pieces now this is
when we get into one of the darker sides
of Tony Stark and the reason why is
because of the fact that of course he
has his new AI essentially replicate the
symbols that were previously on the door
to create a kind of you know protective
aura around himself after which you know
all these different young linen does
kind of enter a pacified state but
because of the fact that extremists if
allowed to manifest for too long
basically corrupts and destroys the
minds of the people who have ingested it
but what it basically means is that
there's no saving these girls they're
too far gone in truth
all Tony Stark can relieve you is just
issue a mercy killing and that's exactly
what he does eBay
this begins using a high-intensity laser
to incinerate these girls heads now this
is dark but it's also as humane as 20
star can possibly be they don't feel a
thing I mean one minute there's a bright
light the next that's it that's all she
wrote and so it takes 20 seconds for it
to charge which means that if he's
issuing out 11 or 12 shots he's got to
wait a little over 2 minutes in order to
basically take out all these different
folks and so because of that it's pretty
intense and it takes a toll because for
him he's basically killing people and if
at all possible Tony Stark always tries
to keep people alive unless there's
absolutely no choice and in this
instance there was really no choice and
so what is up happening is this last
little extremist kid actually takes us
into space and it's really kind of cool
the way that this happens just because
of the fact that one of the people or at
least really one of the guys you know
that is taking this is a guy named Eli
now of course Eli in 20 start go back
quite a bit in the sense that they've
been both you know comrades and they've
you know been sodas at arms so to speak
on the frontline of the technological
arms race and different things like that
but Eli is actually using extremists for
a pretty interesting concept
historically speaking extremis has
always been weaponized ever since the
virus was created and released people
have always weaponized it now I mean in
this instance we see a people who are
trying to use it for medical means but
nine times out of ten is being used in
some form of weaponry what this guy Li
wants to do is actually use it for the
purpose of exploration in his mind
humanity's limited on the planet Earth
we talked about this when Ironman joined
the guardians of the galaxy and actually
the way the story ends will go directly
into guardians of the galaxy so I might
put it in that playlist just for the
sake of it but and the fact remains here
that with regards to Humanity on earth
Humanity is very primitive relatively
speaking to like all the other species I
mean you got to think the Kree Empire
stretches systems solar systems the
Skrull Empire is the exact same way the
Shiar Empire is an amalgamation of
different races and here you have
humanity stuck on a singular planet this
guy using extremis is to basically say
why be limited by such a basic thing why
would you want to weaponize extremis I
mean use it for exploration and so the
goal is to reprogram extremists to that
it can be modified in the human genome
to allow people to walk on Mars without
suits and basically begin the process of
colonizing other planets
looking to the future now under no
circumstances Tony Stark would agree
with this and in fact he says that he
says look I would agree with you I'd be
might be behind you 100 percent of the
way under any normal circumstance if
this was sanctioned by the federal
government if like Reed Richards had a
hand in it or something like that but if
I can come in here then that means dr.
doom can come in here it means that like
magneto could come in here it means any
number of villains could just walk in
and take it and then suddenly they've
just got a ridiculous amount of power
what this does is it leaves to the most
logical outcome a conflict between Tony
Stark and you know Eli and his various
forces now forced again this is Tony
Stark playing it smart is him sitting
down and saying look we're in a space
station out in the middle of nowhere
they're not going to shoot bullets just
because of the fact that if they did all
the way take is a pinprick of a hole in
a wall and then suddenly it's just
explosive decompression oxygen just goes
violently escaping out of the hole next
thing you know the whole little station
blows up and it takes all of us with
them and so in his mind he knew that
they were simply gonna go for
incapacitating him well because of the
fact that he's wearing a mechanized suit
they would use electronics and so as a
result he basically reconfigures a suit
to cope with any kind of electromagnetic
interference which allows him to
maintain the suits functionality and
then in turn take all these different
guys out after which he grabs the
extremis kit and takes off and so what
is up happening here is Tony Stark goes
back and has a conversation with Pepper
Potts and it's really kind of cool to
see this because he says look after
Civil War you know after Secret Invasion
after being director of shield being
forced out of shield after starting
resilient than having to leave resilient
after thinking my death after all these
things that have happened I'm ready to
take a break like I'm ready to clear my
head I'm tired of being on earth I'm
ready to go out I'm ready to do
something else I'm ready to go
experience something else do any number
of things and so what he does is he
basically dons a suit specialized for
interstellar travel for traveling the
spaceways and he essentially just leaves
the planet earth he basically just takes
off and as a result this is when he
joins the guardians of the galaxy
okay so continuing our trend covering
some older Ironman stuff we actually
pick up with a story called the secret
origin of Tony Stark now technically
speaking this was something like 12
issues long and it's actually split into
like three or four different storylines
in the first part it's like three issues
and then three issues and those are two
story arcs and then in the second part
it's like four issues and two issues on
the other two story arcs but we're not
gonna worry about all that we're just
gonna kind of finish the first two and
then go to the second two and then call
it a day so it'll make sense as we go
through it and in fact you really won't
even notice the transition from one
storyline to another but the cool thing
about this one is that remember this is
when Tony Stark had basically taken off
from Earth and join the guardians of the
galaxy for time and then he actually
ended up defecting from the guardians of
the galaxy so what this does is this
actually picks up in the aftermath of
the Avengers vs. x-men storyline now
basically that story just dealt with the
idea of the return of the Phoenix force
now that whole Avengers vs. x-men
storyline branched out into a litany of
different things but dr. Mane's
that with Tony Stark after the events of
Avengers vs. x-men he had basically just
kind of bailed out and so what this does
is show us that there are galaxies
sweeping ramifications for the things
that go on with regards to planet Earth
and the things that various heroes do
and so of course but Tony Stark kind of
you know being really chatty talking up
a you know a woman from a different
world what's kind of cool about this is
that this is a group called the Baldy
and they are really kind of like the the
harbingers of a lot of different races
that have existed over the years in
Marvel Comics and in fact that's really
kind of what Karen Gillan's throwing in
here it's a little bit of a red con in
terms of the different races in Marvel
whether it's like the Shiar or the Kree
or the scroll whatever the case they may
be we always kind of assumed they just
evolved in their own section of the
universe in a lot of ways they did but
what this story about the vol D does is
it tells us that some worl on the line
they came into contact with the Shiar
which is why the Shiar looked like the
baldy they dressed like the vol d the
fashion aspect imprinted on them there
were other elements of their own society
that imprinted on the Kree and on the
the Skrulls and so on and so forth and
so it's one of these things where well I
wouldn't say the vol d were like proj
inators for all beings in existence
their role within the universe certainly
helped to influence other races around
the universe in terms of their evolution
and how they progressed the funny thing
about this is that this chicks like one
of those crazy religious girls but for
Tony is really just kind of like one
one of those one offs you know where
like you get whether than you bail and
you never have to deal with her
craziness the problem with this is that
when she sees what he looks like under
his mask she freaks out and she just
starts reading him the riot act she's
just like you're hideous under your mask
which really kind of sucks it really
gonna blows because he was expecting you
know to have a happy ending to the night
when she doesn't really get but
ultimately he's basically attacked by
the baldy directly at least by some of
their cops and brought before their High
Priestess and what we end up finding out
is that the voldy like so many other
races across the Marvel Universe
especially that she are basically
worshipped the Phoenix force and so the
idea here is that because Tony Stark and
the earth-based superheroes effectively
destroyed the Phoenix force he is going
to be held accountable for that crime in
particular now what this does is this
actually brings in a character called
recorder four or five one
now the recorders are created by a by a
race called the Reg elion and in fact
they actually date all the way back to
1966 with for number 129 which is when
they were first introduced and what's
funny about that because we're really
just kind of coming out of it their
introduction actually centers around ego
the Living Planet which is really kind
of interesting it's really kind of funny
how it all ties together but back when
ego first popped up in Marvel Comics he
was just like a sentient planet that
just existed in this place called the
black galaxy and they called it that way
because everything that came into
contact came into that galaxy was
basically absorbed and ingested by ego
the Living Planet to both provide him
with the energy he needs as well as
absorb their knowledge and expand his
own intelligence now of course this
eventually dead ended into a story worth
Thor and Galactus fought ego and then
Galactus just like strapped a rocket to
his back end and said I'm just hurling
across the universe it was weird but the
fact remains that the Rogell ian's were
really more of like explorers and
colonizers and so the idea was that if
the black galaxy is there and ego the
Living Planet threatens their existence
their goal was to essentially go out and
explore the rest of the cosmos in order
to find other worlds to settle on and to
do this they created recorders and the
recorders are basically these robots
that would just go out they're more or
less probes that would go out they would
explore some predetermined destination
in space they would report back their
memories would be wiped and they would
repeat the process that's all that they
would do well this particular guy for 51
for reasons that are not initially given
to us and in fact reasons I don't even
think are given to us at all for
whatever reason he did
go back and instead he just kept
exploring the cosmos and so he's been
around for millennia and basically just
seen everything there is to see and so
we're actually gonna find out that he
plays a major role in the whole secret
origin of Tony Stark but 4:51 just kind
of showing up and talking to Tony Stark
is done for the purpose of actually
breaking him out of jail or at least
trying to find a way to get him out of
there and so what happens is once he's
brought before this Tribunal more or
less he basically demands trial by
combat and in doing so he's paired up
against you know a handful of different
people now all the different trials he
goes through all different battles he
goes through are done for the charges
he's facing and he's facing dozens and
dozens of charges you know destroying a
deity heresy against the baldy and you
know just being a dick I mean there's
all different kinds of charges that he's
like that he's facing here and so
because of that he actually ends up
going against a multitude of different
foes and beating every last one of them
now the reason why is because of the
fact that while Tony Stark himself has
no real combat abilities the voldie race
as a whole doesn't fight they're not a
conflicting Society they're very much
like Norrin Radd race before he became a
Silver Surfer II those individuals who
basically sought out so just kind of
engage in peace and study you know
really more of like arts and so on and
so forth as opposed to conflict there's
a bunch of hippies so because of that
Tony Stark's able to take out almost
every last one of these guys just
because of the fact that in his own
escapades as an Avenger he's able to
hold his own but because of the fact
that he's able to defeat all of these
guys one is up happening is the vol D
call in someone called death's head now
deaths head was created by a guy named
Simon Furman and this is actually a
really cool story Simon Furman was
working for Marvel's UK imprint back in
the 1960s or 70s and that was basically
Marvel's attempt to branch out into the
United Kingdom into England and create
stories that people would care about
that's where like Captain Britain came
from and the Excalibur team and all that
kind of good stuff but the fact remains
here that deaths head was created as a
transformers character and Simon Furman
actually threw him in the transformers
comics the problem was that at the time
comic books were becoming more and more
popular and the Transformers were
growing into their own by quite a huge
margin I mean it looks like issue number
100 and something by the time that by
the time the 1960s were all around and
so because of that the fear was that if
deaths had stayed in the transformers
comics exclusively then he would
basically become a transformers property
and so because of that mom
would essentially lose the rights to him
because back then it was kind of like
creator-owned content so if a guy made
something and threw it into a comic so
long as it stays in that line of comics
it becomes the property of that line of
comics and so what model did is they
actually cranked out this super quick
like one-shot that basically had
death's-head inside a Marvel comic which
in turn MIT Marvel could say now he's
the exclusive property of us they in
turn filed a copyright claim on a
death's-head and then made death's-head
a Marvel character and so it was really
kind of cool the way they pulled that
off it was like she hooked right like
they wanted to do she-hulk in the TV
show so Marvel cleaned out a comic to
make she-hulk a Marvel character and so
then they had to go and just get
permission from Marvel in order to
include her in and Marvel got all the
money from the she-hulk appearances that
ever showed up outside of the comic
books but the fact remains a
death's-head is basically just a giant
robot and he's really a bounty hunter
but standing some 30 feet tall he's a
lot more powerful than Tony Stark is so
again it's actually kind of crazy now
something else to point out here is that
Tony Stark is forced to fight without
his armor and even those individuals
that he's going against are forced to
fight without weapons so it's actually
kind of a cool little little tidbit here
but the fact remains that with him more
or less being saved this comes by way of
his new AI called pepper which is
basically just a way to maintain his
connection to Pepper Potts when he's out
in space it's a totally Savio as an
autonomous AI it's not really Pepper
Potts it's just kind of modeled after
her but the way the recorder 451 breaks
Tony Stark out is by capturing something
called the heart of the vol D and
basically this is a massive energy
source the vaulty used to keep their
society going and to keep their energies
going and does so by basically feeding
on the excess energy of the Celestials
and various other cosmic entities in the
Marvel Universe
well the Celestials are none too happy
about that and apparently they've been
searching around for the MALDI forever
with the heart of the voldie they were
able to keep themselves basically hidden
and protected with the heart of the vol
D gone the Celestials obliterate the
entire place it is kind of show up out
of nowhere and destroy everything so
it's actually pretty wild and it's
pretty messed up but ultimately Tony saw
it just kind of has to leave its gonna
has to let him go and fly off and so
what this does is it leads to him coming
into direct contact with death's head
himself now of course deaths head it
basically was kind of bailed out when
everything was going upon when it all
was kind of going to pieces but recorder
451 basically kind of took off and then
kind of poked fun at Tony Stark a little
bit like hey you know catch me if you
can that kind of a thing well the
universe is a massive place and so
because of that Tony Sarg a line
self alongside death's-head will give
him resources to like the kind of things
that bounty hunters only have and he's
eventually able to track down recorder
four or five one what we end up finding
out here though is that record of four
five one basically set all this up four
five one essentially as soon as Tony
Stark and death's-head show up recorder
four five one packs and two Tony starts
suit takes control of his AI and then it
also turns out that he had basically
paid death's-head to lead Tony Stark
here in the first place and so the
reason why is because of the fact that
recorder had to create a circumstance
where Tony Stark would come to him and
the reason for that is because record a
4-5-1 has a very important piece of
information
this piece of information being a
message directly from Tony Stark's
father and so the crazy thing about this
is that Tony Stark's just kind of made
to watch just because of the fact that
recorder has control of his armor and
that kind of thing and Stark really
can't leave but initially we're not told
exactly what it is that his father said
instead we're just kind of like given
this jump over where it's just like okay
and that's what he said and then of
course Tony Stark's kind of reacting to
it and freaking out but what we end up
finding out here is that the parents of
Tony Stark had a very hard time
conceiving Howard a Maria just could not
conceive a child and so much like dr.
strange trying to find a way to heal his
hands Howard is are traveling around to
various people and this is kind of cool
because it's a lot of the most
intelligent scientific people in the
realm of Marvel Comics but they deal
mostly with biology more so than
anything else the Eternal City you know
where all the Eternals live you know
these basically angelic like beings in
the Marvel Universe don't really have a
way to save it the High Evolutionary a
guy that basically deals with growing
human beings cannot do anything to help
them now the fact remains that we
actually end up picking up with Howard
Stark kind of falling to the bottom of
the barrel where a guy's like hey man I
know a guy who knows a guy who knows a
guy and this leads him to Las Vegas
Nevada where he comes into contact with
this guy who's basically a gray now as
far as I'm aware this is the first
appearance of their race inside Marvel
Comics and they're not significant here
but the gray is actually operate out of
a casino called area 52 area 50 yeah
area 52 in Las Vegas now the funny thing
about this is that it's like that rule
you know what happens in Vegas stays in
Vegas and if you've ever been to Las
Vegas before there's crazy people
everywhere and so like someone walking
around as an alien no one's gonna bat an
eye they just kind of blend in perfectly
what the gray basically says is that
is a robot of course we know that now to
be recorder 451 stuck inside this
particular casino thing that looks like
a UFO and the idea is to basically break
in and steal this recorder now of course
the cool thing about this is that the
recorder is not established to be the
guaranteed way for howard and maria
start to have a kid instead what happens
is the gray says hey look this robot
supposedly is like travel around the
universe and seen everything and so if
there is a way for you to achieve
whatever goal it is that you want to
achieve because you know howard doesn't
tell the greys and he wants to advocate
or anything he basically says look this
recorder would be the way for you to be
able to pull it off and so ultimately
what ends up happening is Howard Stark
assembles his own team it's kind of cool
because it's like this 1960s kind of
situation with all these different
things unfolding now keep in mind
because the fact that this is the 1960s
the Marvel Universe is still relatively
new at this point I mean in terms of
superhero immersion so like mutants are
just now showing up so things are still
relatively new in terms of how it's all
unfolding but this is kind of fun
because it turns into this sort of like
tyst mission right it's kind of like
Ocean's eleven meets Marvel Comics which
I love Ocean's eleven and some I love
this kind of scenario this guy the gray
goes in and distracts the various
members of his race who are here and are
running this casino and essentially says
hey look this guy stole our robot and he
took off over to this one location and
said we have to go find him now what had
happened here is one of the guys of Tony
Stark's team used an image inducer and
basically made recorder 451 invisible as
well as him and Howard Stark and so what
this meant was that when the greys
showed up inside the room where the
robot was supposed to be to their eyes
it was invisible and it was it was gone
and so again this is cool because it
shows us that like some of the thievery
and stuff and like some of the schemes
are like pretty cool in terms of in
terms of the kind of stuff that they
were pulling off and so ultimately they
break it out and we actually end up
finding out that like Maria Stark Howard
Starks wife is basically like part of
the whole thieves game like she's very
much involved in this whole blackops
esque you know scenario she's a pilot
and all that stuff and so it's really
kind of cool but um again we're only
given one half of this story and the
reason is because after Tony Stark is
given all this information the recorder
says there's a lot of other things that
we did a lot of other things that we
ended up getting involved in and we're
Tony Stark initially asked okay you know
what
happen next what's the next stage how
does all this lead into presumably the
birth of me the recorders also a little
kind of cloak-and-dagger here you know
where he basically says yeah this all
does kind of lead into you but we have a
destination that you're going to and so
for right now you got to go to sleep man
so we basically knocks him out and they
end up taking off to their destination
which of course turns out to be the
final battleground of the War Between
the Celestials and the aspirants and
this is actually really really really
really cool it's one of the coolest
elements with regards to to this whole
thing of course we'll find out more
about that in the next video in the
meantime what we actually end up doing
is jumping back to to Howard and Maria's
start and we get the last little tidbit
of this story at least in terms of what
led into Tony's talk and what we end up
finding out here is that with them
basically kind of rescuing the recorder
the answer he gives is yes I will
definitely help you guys create a trial
now the cool thing about this is that
the recorders not doing it for
altruistic reasons there's actually a
motivation behind it and it stems
directly from the nature of the planet
Earth the recorder having traveled
around you know the cosmos for so long
and having seen so many different things
recognizes the placement of earth and
that's really the kind of case when it
comes to Marvel Comics for whatever
reason the earth is just strategically
placed in like the best possible
position when it comes to wars and
conflicts and so the recorder being here
is done for the purpose of not creating
a super-powered being but creating a
person that can basically have the
intelligence to make the earth a
futurist place to look to the horizon
and find ways to basically speed up the
Earth's development in terms of weapons
technology defense systems laying the
stage for everything that would make
Tony Stark who he is and so because of
this what recorder basically says is I'm
going to essentially give you a child
and then modify it on the genetic level
to be predisposed to a higher level of
intelligence now for any parent who's
being told we are going to make
modifications to your child before it's
born that is a terrifying concept
regardless of whether or not is going to
benefit your child or is going to cause
harm to your child it's a terrifying
idea and so because of that to have
genetic modifications to their kid
really just kind of freaks them out and
it really kind of bothers them a little
bit but ultimately they end up going
through with it now what we're gonna
find out is there's a little more that
was going on behind the scenes and the
way the cure and Gillan doesn't it's
absolutely genius but the fact remains
here that we end up having Maria stark
goin through the insemination process
when the child is
basically the stowed inside of her and
you know six months later she gives
birth to a kid herself now this kind of
wraps up by the fact that the Grays
eventually catch up to the to the Starks
themselves and the reason why this is so
important is because the recorder sits
down and says no one can know that this
baby is here no one can know that this
child has basically been modified by me
anybody who knows about it is going to
have to be killed as far as they're
concerned they need to believe that you
have a happy and healthy normal baby and
so if the Grays have stumbled across
this and if the Grays have realized that
I is a recorder and involved in the
birth of your child then they're going
to put two and two together and even if
they don't come to the absolute truth
they're gonna become information brokers
they're gonna say a recorder from a
super-advanced race is on earth and
helping a human couple give birth to a
child it probably did something to that
kid that made it super advanced and so
again it's actually gonna speed up the
timeline of the various races that would
see the earth as a threat and try to
destroy it and so in response Howard
Stark and this Recorder travel to this
location of where the greys are at and
essentially kill them all now Tony
Stark's reaction to this it's a lot of
doubt and so because of that is kind of
a funny situation because in this whole
scenario the recorder basically says hey
look at where you are right now you're
literally an engineer down to the
genetic level you were designed to just
be that smart and so again it's really
kind of cool to see a lot of this
changing going on with regards to the
Tua's character a lot of this expansion
be added here and so ultimately once we
get to the question of well what
happened next after the whole scenario
with the Grays Karen Gillan ends the
story so we will find out in the next
video what it is that goes on further
with the whole idea of Tony Stark
because where this seems to be pretty
self-explanatory and pretty interesting
on the surface when we get in-depth it's
gonna get a lot more interesting because
I will say this nothing here is as it
appears to be
okay so picking up with the second part
of the secret origin of Tony Stark
really the Starks origin the recorder
and and what's really what's really
going on with the motivations of
recorder four five one and what we end
up finding out here is that following
the birth of Tony Stark they effectively
call it a day like the recorders is kind
of like okay he takes off and that's
really yeah I mean because his jobs done
and it's really kind of cool here
because with everything that's happened
the question of Howard and Maria Stark
is what do we do now it's what a kind of
cool because I feel like that's the the
question almost every parent asks you
know I think that's one of the things
that makes you know parenting parenting
pretty exciting well the whole idea here
at least from what a recorder 451 tells
Tony Stark is that he was engineered for
a particular purpose and the purpose was
to basically pilot something called the
god killer armor now the god killer
armor is a really really cool concept
because it's basically like anti
celestial tech but the reason why is
because of the fact that remember record
451 looked around and basically said
people are gonna become jealous of the
earth are gonna become concerned about
the earth but because of all the
inhabitants because the super-powered
beings that exist here the earth could
one day become a beacon of peace in the
universe now we know that just by way of
like Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
that Avengers world will be formed
Avengers world will happen but we're
given this a little bit of history about
the Marvel Universe now something else
is going on and when in fact we'll
actually cover this in our story about
The Ultimates when we basically get to a
retcon of the universe all Ultimates is
basically retelling this entire origin
story um when it comes to the whole the
whole concept of the god killer armor
back in the early days of the universe's
existence that is to say this version of
the Marvel Universe which i think is the
seventh iteration of the universe a war
broke out between the Celestials and the
aspirants but the aspirants and the
Celestials are both vying for dominance
of the universe now what the motivation
of the aspirants were again we don't
know there are very emag matic race of
people all we knew is that the
Celestials basically procreate by taking
control of a planet impregnating the
planet with the energies of a celestial
and then when that celestial emerges the
plan is destroyed and then there's one
more celestial in the cosmos the idea
was it before the aspirants to basically
stop that from happening and to defeat
the Celestials but during the war
between the aspirants and the Celestials
themselves the aspirants had developed
the god-killer armor that stands 25,000
feet tall and this
odd killer armour served the purpose of
basically destroying Celestials and the
war was massive it was a universe wide
war now what we learned in Ultimates is
that this conflict is simply the seventh
time has happened that back in the
beginning of all things when the very
first universe came into existence that
universe was basically called the
firmament and that universe created
aspirants and it created Celestials both
of these beings were designed to
basically view the view the first
firmament as being you know kind of like
a an all-encompassing entity that is to
say they basically worshipped it the
problem is that some of these beings
namely the Celestials began to operate
with autonomy which is to say they
basically broke away from the influence
of the first firmament and became their
own beings and so because of this the
war between the Celestials and they and
the aspirants was actually a war between
those who are loyal to the first
firmament and those who were not and so
because of this the Celestials basically
won the first firmament was pushed to
the brink of all existence and the cycle
repeated itself each time the universe
took form so each time the universe
collapsed and a new ohm was born the
entire cycle repeated all over again the
exception to this is that the first
firmament existed outside of all space
and time and outside of the main
universe itself and just watched the
multiverse collapse and be reborn six or
seven times leading up to the formation
of the all-new all-different marvel
universe following the events of secret
Wars and so of course what we find out
is that with Tony Stark being here with
record of 451 still maintaining control
of his suit of armor what happened is
that when recorder 451 went to the
planet vol D led Tony Stark there and
then stole the heart of the baldy the
reason for that is because of the fact
that the heart was needed to power the
god-killer armor and the idea here is
that record 451 essentially engineer
Tony Stark's so that he and he alone
could pilot the god killer armor station
it on planet earth and become
essentially a warning to anybody who
shows up on earth that there would be
massive ramifications because you got to
thank anybody who showed up on earth
with the intention of attacking it would
be obliterated by the god killer armor
just because the amount of power that it
possesses I mean it's just ridiculous of
course in the middle of all this were
met by the arrival of death's head and
the reason why is because of the fact
that where the character of death's head
it was recorder 451 trying to wrap up
loose ends death's-head is for all
intents and purposes the best bounty
hunter in the entire Marvel Universe and
because of this with him being as
capable as he is the recorder basically
put a bounty on his head and so this
really kind of shows us the arrogance
and the hubris of the recorder to
basically try to eliminate the greatest
bounty hunter in the in the universe
by sending other bounty hunters after
him and so again what this does is
because of the fact that death's-head is
just a giant machine the recorder hacks
into him and essentially shuts him down
you know really just kind of makes him
into his own personal slave and so again
the commands that have been given to
these individuals that the recorder
hacks into namely the suit of Iron Man
and death's head is do not allow me to
be harmed do not harm me and carry out
my orders now they're given free will to
do anything they want to but if Tony
Stark tried to kill recorder four or
five one this suit wouldn't let him
if death's-head tried to kill recorder
four five one his body wouldn't let him
but he still maintains his own mind he
still maintains his own intelligence and
his own thoughts and desires and even
free speech he just can't kill recorder
four or five one and has to follow all
of his orders and so because of this
Tony Stark's required to think fast now
because of the fact that the suit itself
responds to Tony Stark as much as it
responds to Pepper Potts is really kind
of like a like a redundant system if the
Pepper AI essentially becomes corrupted
Tony Stark can basically purge it and
then operate the suit on his own and
that's exactly what he does of course
the pepper AI pretty much kind of goes
with this idea as well because it's the
only way to save what it is it's
happening but Stark essentially shuts
down the suit and then just runs and
that's it so at this point he's really
just kind of stuck on his feet but the
funny thing about this is that when
deaths head is shown up and it basically
fought on behalf of Tony Stark even for
only a moment he made reference to the
fact that Tony Stark's own weapons
systems had followed him there now the
reason why was because with the pepper
AI basically taken over by reporter
4-5-1 the AI was still able to function
and use all of its normal resources and
so what it basically did is it realized
if reporter 4-5-1 hacked into me then I
can basically recall all the armors of
Tony Stark when it doesn't realize
what's going on and Tony Stark and
basically just jury rigged the armour so
that they can work without having to
worry about you know record a 4-5-1
hacking into them and that's exactly
what he does he basically began routing
all these different suits of armor to
essentially wire them all together as a
dummy system sorry
quarter 4-5-1 can use them but the fact
remains that with regards to deaths head
because it's essentially acting to try
to destroy record a 4-5-1 it essentially
acts around the parameters that it
basically just kind of takes four or
five one and just dives off the side of
you know one of the ledges hoping that
it'll destroy recorder four or five one
at the same time because when they hit
the bottom of the god killer armor
they'll have been traveling almost five
miles because of how tall it is of
course you know record a 4-5-1 says
unhand me and that's that that's the end
of deaths head but again what this does
is it shows us the intelligence and the
ingenuity of Tony Stark but it's also
this idea that not everything is what it
seems and the reason why is because
Karen Gillan is hinting at the idea that
either something went wrong with the
plan of recorder 451 or Tony Stark is
not the child of Howard and Maria and
the reason why is because of the fact
that the child of Howard Maria was
programmed to be able to access indigent
to pilot the god killer armor when
record a 4-5-1 sends the god killer
armor careening into a planet hoping
that Tony Stark will seize control as
pilot merged with the armor and then
deterred away from the planet itself
Stark tries it and can't control the
suit he cannot control the ship and so
because of this the indication here from
Kieron Gillen is that Tony Stark is not
the biological child of Howard and Maria
now this is really interesting because
when this first struck it was the talk
of the town Tony Stark is not the child
of how and Maria that's crazy but the
fact remains here that with Tony Stark
unable to pilot the suit of armor
ultimately it ends up destroying the
planet now again this is where the the
whole views and the whole perspectives
begin to shift and the reason why is
because of the fact that from the
perspective of a recorder 4-5-1 Tony
Stark did not stop the god killer armor
from crashing into the planet because he
chose not to not because he couldn't and
so again this is really kind of
interesting because it makes me quarter
four five one very human in the sense
that he's he's just kind of ignoring
facts in place of what he believes to be
true because in truth he doesn't know
what's going on it also shows us how
durable and how strong the recorders are
I mean they're non stockholders in terms
of their physical structure in terms of
the durability now there's all different
kinds of things that he can do but
ultimately alongside the assistance of
pepper the hacking system of recorder
451 is destroyed which in turn frees her
from his control and really
kind of sets the stage for the recorder
system to be almost completely
obliterated now before this happens Tony
Stark actually grabs the recorder drags
him over to one of the interface devices
and forces the recorder to bear witness
to the fact that Tony Stark cannot
control it like you couldn't tell him
the truth you had to make him see the
truth with the recorder basically
realizing that the Tony Stark is not the
child of Howard and Maria the question
becomes then who is who is the child of
Howard and Maria now at this point for
the recorder it doesn't matter I mean is
his life is basically done I mean it's
really just kind of over and so because
of the fact that he says look I acted
him what I thought was the best interest
only for me to find out that I basically
screwed up my purpose is null it
essentially just kind of deletes itself
and so because of that Tony Stark really
has no way out I mean the doors are
sealed sure the god-killer armor is sent
away from the planet Earth but it's also
told by the recorder to begin the
process of jumping to another dimension
to jump to another reality and it'll
take Tony Stark with it it starts not
able to get out and so again building on
this intelligence of Tony Stark of
course he ends up grabbing the recorder
and then hooking up it's hacking system
and breaking himself free that's really
it just kind of gets him out as fast as
he possibly can and then they basically
just bail out but something else that I
also want you to hope I want you to
notice here is the idea of a Dyson
Sphere when the god-killer armor was
first introduced as part of this story
it was basically hidden away from all
things in existence inside of a Dyson
Sphere of course the Dyson Sphere
serving the purpose or serving multiple
purposes of being able to like absorb
solar energy you know built around a
star that kind of thing but it was
designed for the purpose of keeping the
god-killer armor hidden the reason why
this matters is because this is yet
another instance when Hickman will reach
into existing stories from the Iron Man
comics in the Captain America comics and
so on and roll them over into incursions
and everything when the Infinity
Gauntlet when the gems shattered and
they weren't able to use a gauntlet
anymore
Tony Stark decided to build a Dyson
Sphere around the Sun and then channeled
the energies of the Sun to destroy in
cursing planets so again it was really
kind of a cool idea in terms of how it
all just kind of reaches together and
how it all kind of comes back in but
what we end up having here is Tony Stark
arriving back on earth only to find out
that where he had basically taken off
before his birthday she essentially just
kind of held his birthday celebration
off until he got back and then it's the
Avengers and everything but the
important thing here is that Tony Stark
begins to remember what it
that went on with regards to recorder
4-5-1 the idea that the programmed child
of Howard and Maria Stark was made for
the purpose of being able to access the
god-killer armor the fact that Tony
Stark wasn't able to do that meant that
he was not the biological child of
Howard a Maria Stark now the reason why
he comes to this conclusion is because
of the fact that recorders are robots
they're not designed to be human they're
not designed to make mistakes in this
instance with everything that it was
that recorder four or five one had done
there was no reason to indicate that it
was wrong about the idea that only
Howard and Maria's child should be able
to access the god-killer armor and so
after going through all this
documentation and going through all this
different paperwork Tony Stark comes to
the only logical conclusion that he can
that Howard a Maria Stark do have a
child and that child is not him and so
what we do is we jump back to the
initial scenario when a recorder four or
five one appeared to Howard a Maria
stark and offer the option of allowing
them to have a child but stating that
there would be some genetic
modifications that would be made to it
and in this discussion between the two
of them they effectively just wrote
notes to one another asking the question
can it be trusted do you believe that it
has our best interest in hearts and so
again it really showed the idea that
from the very beginning Howard and Maria
Stark did not trust recorder 4-5-1 now
ultimately they ended up going through
with it the change to the plan came by
way of Howard Stark himself and again
this shows us just how smart he is and
so what we end up finding out here is
that when Maria Stark was impregnated
with a child and then recorder four or
five one began the process of
genetically modifying that child Howard
began to go through with all the notes
that he was given by recorder four or
five one and began meddling around and
investigating in terms of what was
happening and found a hidden line of
code that was basically designed for the
purpose of killing the child of how and
Maria Stark when it was around thirty
when it was in his 30s maybe close to 40
and so it was basically a suicide gene
now we know by virtue of reading the
story the gene was created by a recorder
four or five one so that it would be
able to grab the child of Howard Maria
stark whisk it off to the low to the
god-killer armor make it part of the
god-killer armor presumably infusing its
mind with the armor itself making it a
pilot and then his physical body would
just shut down so there would be nothing
left but the mind stuck inside the guy
Killer armor what Howard did is he
basically created a serum of sorts that
would disrupt this gene now the crazy
thing about this is he does not tell his
wife he does not tell Maria Stark about
what's going on but it's not because he
doesn't trust her he does it because of
the fact that a recorder 451 kept
extremely close tabs on Maria Stark
because of the fact that the future of
all the recorders plans hinged on this
child being born happy and healthy and
so what is up happening here is that
when the baby's born
it shows some struggling it shows some
wheeze enos and it's effectively born
with cellular degeneration and this is
when Howard Stark says I found a weird
kind of scenario a weird line of code
inside this kid's genes I try to find a
way to neutralize it and instead I
basically incapacitated our child their
mind will stay intact but they'll never
be able to use their physical body the
other half of this is that every quarter
4-5-1 ever found out about this it would
likely kill Howard and Maria stark and
start over again with somebody else
presumably somebody a little more naive
that can't quite investigate on the same
level that Howard Stark did and so in
order to maintain their position in
terms of keeping everything under wraps
what they ended up doing is they took
their biological child are no Stark they
put him in their own little Hospice of
sorts and then in turn they adopted Tony
Stark to keep their cover to make it
look like everything was going along as
planned and so the implication here is
that Tony Stark is just as smart as he
is because he's just that damn smart
because he's just that intelligent but
putting two and two together for the
first time in his life he encounters his
brother Arno stark and this is so cool
because
Arnold's first first you know really
statement to him is just so you know I
would have worked it out like a decade
ago and so for the most part they get on
with a pretty good start now of course a
lot of this seems to be because of the
fact that Arno is quite aware that Tony
Stark was never told about what was
going on so he's coming into this
completely blind stark never knew about
what was happening and so the results of
this is that with these two brothers
being extremely intelligent then the
question becomes if this is what Tony
Stark was able to do in isolation and he
does not seem to have the intelligence
that his brother has in terms of being
so capable what in the world could they
possibly do together and so what this
does is this sets the stage for the next
story
like here in Gillan called iron
metropolitan okay so getting into the
iron metropolitan what I want to do
before we start this is I want to run
over the ten rings of the Mandarin and
the reason why is because the fact that
what karen gillan is going to do is
basically turn the rings of the Mandarin
into the equivalent of Lantern rings in
Marvel Comics now the reason why I say
this is because of the fact that the
Rings themselves are actually going to
start seeking out people in this
particular story and going into the
rings of the Mandarin and the lantern
raised in DC Comics serve the same
purpose you have the ability to instill
great hope as the Blue Lantern rings you
have the ability to instill great fear
that's the Sinestro Corps rings because
of that it's really one of these
scenarios where Marvel's is kind of
borrowing from DC but it's done in a way
that still works now with regards to the
rings of the Mandarin there are ten of
them and each of the Rings has his own
distinct property or ability that makes
it separate from any of the other rings
now in truth I kept aired all the
information from the Marvel wiki to the
comics so the Marvel wiki is actually
right this time um as the word is gonna
kind of go with a list they have their
but the remake er is basically a train
that allows the Mandarin to manipulate
the atomic and molecular structure of
matter but it cannot transmute elements
or affect objects encased in force or
energy fields meaning it cannot turn
something into gold and if something's
behind a force field they can't do
anything to access it the influence ring
allows the Mandarin to generate and
project various beams of concussive
force pretty straightforward the spin
ring causes the air to move about at
high speeds like it were in a vortex and
the vortex can be used as an offensive
weapon as a means of levitating objects
or as a means of propelling the rings
wearer through the air basically giving
them the power of flight the spectral
ring allows the Mandarin to project a
beam of energy capable of destroying the
bonds between the atoms and molecules of
any particular object causing inanimate
objects to disintegrate the problem with
this is the ring has to recharge for 20
minutes after each use of course this is
basically a caveat that allows Marvel to
keep the Mandarin from being a guy who
can just manipulate matter on the atomic
scale anytime he wants to
now the night bringer ring allows the
Mandarin to create an area of Darkness
presumably using dark force energy to do
so now dark force energy is almost like
vantablack in a lot of different ways
those are the guys who don't know what
that is vantablack
is a
like that's so incredibly dark that
anything that's sprayed with the color
Fanta black basically just looks like a
hole in reality it's it's crazy how dark
it is like there's one image circulating
out there somewhere of a basketball that
was sprayed with anti black and it looks
like it's just a hole in reality it's
crazy how it looks like it's really kind
of mind-blowing but for those of you
guys were reading secret Empire a dark
force energy is what was used to
basically in case all of New York so
that doctors change it everybody was
just kind of trapped in another
dimension so again it's really one of
these things were just harnesses other
dimensional power but the demonic ring
allows the Mandarin to generate and
manipulate various forms of
electromagnetic energy of the
incandescence ring allows the Mandarin
to project blasts of infrared and
produce flame or ignite combustible
material the lyre which that's gonna be
one of the more interesting rings in
this story magnifies the Mandarin
psionic energies allowing him to
mentally manipulate the thoughts and
actions of others and will actually hint
on how that was used by the Mandarin
himself here in a little bit the
lightning ring allows the Mandarin to
reject blasts of electrical energy it
literally does exactly what it sounds
like it generates lightning the zero
ring allows the Mandarin to project
waves of intense cold and ice including
trapping foes in ice blocks and sheaths
so it basically just kind of allows the
Mandarin to manipulate cold weather
that's really it kind of like gives them
the power of ice man in a lot of
different ways now having run over that
list real quick the whole basis behind
the idea of really iron Metropolitan is
to show us what the potential could
possibly be with the arno and Stark
brothers remember of course in the last
video we talked about how Tony Stark had
learned about his brother are now
basically the the genetically engineered
brother
that's the biological child of Howard a
Maria Stark and that Tony himself was
basically just adopted and so again this
was really kind of cool because it
served two purposes
the first was creating a more compelling
story and the second was actually
bringing to us the idea that Tony Stark
is as smart as he is because he's just
that smart is just genuine natural
intelligence so again it's kind of a
cool scenario but with regards to the
future that really be holds the earth
for these two guys remember Tony Stark
was basically told by recorder 4-5-1
prior to its death more or less that the
earth was a potential beacon for peace
across the universe and we know just by
virtue of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers that time will eventually come
something like 10,000 years in the
future 5,000 years I don't member what
it is but there's actually a place
called Avenged
world but with regards to getting to
that place what we end up having is
really like this limps thirty years into
the future where Tony Stark and Arno
have basically generated peace across
the planet earth they have this massive
city called Troy and this city basically
creates pure energy for the world to use
it really creates a kind of utopia the
downside to this is that they currently
have an AI called
Helen and Helen is model largely after
Recorder 451 but as Tony Stark puts it
was designed to basically stay away from
all the glitches and the mistakes that
will come along with artificial
intelligence of course this turns out
not to be the case Helen goes awry and
begins the process of tearing up
everything that Tony Stark an auto star
can built now of course in response to
this they end up sending out you know
some 20,000 Iron Man suits they're
piloted by the a is modeled after Pepper
Potts after James Rhodes but in the end
it doesn't make any difference
everything they've worked for has been
destroyed so what we end up learning is
that this is actually a simulation that
both are no Stark and Tony Stark are
experiencing and in every single
instance of this simulation the AI Helen
that they create ultimately goes awry
now the reason why this is important is
because starker I guess Tony and Arno
take two different stances on this our
nose response is you cannot try with AI
every single simulation we've run the AI
will always become sentient and it'll
always run amok and Tony Stark's mind
there's going to be a way around it
there's got to be a way to basically set
up that AI so it will not go down that
path it will not become a villain more
or less so again it's really kind of
wild because we learn that Tony Stark
had basically brought you know record a
4-5-1 back to earth for the purpose of
really doing nothing more than just kind
of experimenting on and learning about
the technology that it has because
remember would that recorder having been
around for millions of years it
assimilated all different kinds of
technology from across the universe
technology that humanity hasn't even
experienced yet the only way to access
it is in recorder four five one so again
Tony Stark basically has preview tube
technology and advances that humanity
would otherwise never have access to but
at the end of the day his mind is still
that they can create this utopia for the
world and they can literally transform
earth into a beacon of peace across the
universe but the first step is finding a
way to salvage and to access all the
technology within you know recorder 451
and basically save earth it's
and so from here this is when we begin
the process of switching over to the
idea of essentially Marvel's version of
the Green Lantern rings in a sense that
one of the Mandarin rings arrives to a
woman by the name of Abigail Beryl burns
who really goes by the name red pearl
essentially as you know as she puts it
she's really more of like a a
journalist's where she goes through and
writes about corporations that engage in
seedy actions as different things like
that but she's really just kind of
pissed off at the world and like she
hates capitalism and different things
like that and so the result is that
she's given a ring and she's deemed to
be Mandarin seven and the idea is to
essentially take revenge against Tony
Stark now we don't really know why we
don't know why these rings are taking
revenge against Tony Stark and in fact
the Rings have never become sentient
before the Rings are only ever objects
that were used by the Mandarin to
basically fight against Tony Stark so
this is wholly new this is brand-new
stuff by by Karen Gillan and it's
actually really kind of cool to see it
all unfold but what we also end up
finding out here is the first stage -
Tony Stark's plan of basically revamping
the world is traveling to Mandarin city
now this is kind of interesting because
when Matt Fraction first introduced
Mandarin city there wasn't really a
whole lot to go on there it was just
there one day you know the Mandarin has
kind of had a base of operations in
Mandarin city the only indication we
were given was that it was some place
off the coast of China that the Mandarin
presumably used some kind of CDE you
know means used you know his lyre ring
for example the ability to manipulate
the minds of others to basically give
himself that Islander to take it from
China and that was really it but during
the whole longwaydown storyline when the
Mandarin basically kidnapped both
Ezekiel Stane the son of Obadiah Stane
and Tony Stark and forced them to begin
building these giant you know mechanized
suits that would allow the Mandarin
essentially to engage in world
domination they effectively turned
against him but where Tony Stark was
working to defeat the Mandarin using
technology and taking down these various
powered suits to so on and so forth
Ezekiel Stane actually fought the
Mandarin and killed him and so what it
did is it basically left Mandarin city
with a giant power vacuum and so what
started happening is that all these
different warlords and these petty
criminals who were living under the
Mandarin began to vie for power and so
you had triads you know who were showing
up you know these Asian base gangs is
someone and so forth and really Mandarin
City just kind of turned into a giant
war zone now Tony's start going in here
alongside Arno stark who's basically
piloting some of these art armors
designed for the purpose of basically
clearing the city out seizing control of
a mandarin city and then basically
turning it into like this refuge turning
it into this this safe haven and so what
we end up doing is we travel to
basically the core which is you know
within mandarin city more or less and
what we have tony stark doing is taking
the pepper AI removing her from him
putting her inside the core of this
system and renaming her helen and so
because of this it's really kind of Tony
Stark falling down the path of becoming
the guy that's eventually going to lead
to this helen robot losing its mind
destroying everything so again but it's
almost one of these scenarios where it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy from
here we kind of skip forward you know a
little bit or at least we kind of pick
up in the modern day we're started
previously you know kind of cleared out
Mandarin city but the fact remains with
all the construction and everything
that's taking place here once Mandarin
city is basically cleaned out and once
it's renamed to Troy we end up of course
having Tony Sark making a declaration to
all those who are present making a
declaration to the press that Troy is
going to serve as a beacon it's going to
serve as a place for those people who
are living in destitution those people
who are living in squalor they can leave
their struggling areas and they can come
to a place that's new now this is really
kind of cool because it's really one of
those scenarios where Marvel are really
curing Guillen's building on what's
already been established and that's
really kind of the way it goes in Marvel
Comics there was really a place called
asteroid M or Avalon depending on on
what you choose to call it that was
created by Magneto and it was designed
to be a safe haven for mutants away from
the oppressive regime of humanity now of
course this basically put humanity in a
state of fear when you end up having you
know almost all forces basically
withdrawing from an area that means
something really bad is going to happen
and so because of that you know humanity
looking at it from a wartime perspective
believe that you know magneto was
pulling all the mutants off of Earth
because he was in turn going to like
cleanse the earth in his entirety just
eradicate everybody on earth and so of
course humanity struck against against
Magneto magneto struck back issued a
blanket EMP around the planet the x-men
intervened and that led into fatal
attractions when Wolverine losses
adamantium so again it was really kind
of a cool cool scenario in terms of how
it all kind of unfolded and what led to
what and different things like that but
this is still very much the same thing
you know Tony start going into an
existing territory that's basically in a
state of flux co-opting it and then
making it his own the issue with this is
that while all this goes down we end up
finding out another
basically bonded to somebody else this
person going by the name of Mandarin won
now of course we don't know who this
person is but Tony Stark immediately
recognizes the signatures of the Ring
now of course abigail takes this
opportunity to effectively attack Tony
Stark so it's really more of an alliance
without an intention to be in a life so
so she's just kind of like jumping into
the moment and using the distraction as
a way to basically take on Stark now
sports donning his Iron Man suit we end
up finding out how far Stark has come
because remember all of this comes out
of extremists and so while Tony Stark
had long since abandoned the extremist
technology the fact remains here that
what he ends up doing is basically
creating a stealth suit for himself that
he's been wearing the entire time it's
just you didn't know it was there
because it's a stealth suit so it's
actually kind of cool but from here
things are pretty straightforward I mean
in the sense he's able to run off you
know Abigail for time and basically kind
of retreats and that's really about it
and so the question that Tony Stark has
is if that was a ring of the Mandarin
then what happened to the rings of the
Mandarin now the reason why we asked
that question is because of the fact
that the Rings are extremely dangerous
and they're not like Lantern rings right
like like if you were someone who just
walked up and picked up a Green Lantern
ring if you're not if it doesn't beam
you as being a person that's worthy to
wield it you wouldn't be able to use it
the rings of the Mandarin don't work
that way anybody can put it on and
suddenly they've got all the powers that
come along with it and so what Tony
Stark does is alongside James Rhodes
investigate the shield weapons vault
Omega now this is a multi-faceted fault
and the reason why is because of the
fact that if you've ever wondered what
happens to like the weapons of massive
villains who launch an attack and
they're defeated and so on and so forth
they're all basically stationed in
different vaults and there's a lot of
places like that around the Marvel
Universe but because the rings of the
Mandarin do not require any measure of
worth in order to be able to use them or
at least previously they didn't once
Tony Stark and James Rhodes begin to go
there and they basically start looking
around they see all the rings that are
there but having an AI scan it means
that the AI will see what's truly there
and will not see what their eyes see and
this is when we learned that the liar
ring had basically been duping everybody
that once a week a member of shield will
go down there they will investigate
they'll check and make sure all the
rings are there and if they are they'll
seal everything back up and they'll
leave the liar ring had basically been
making it appear as though all the rings
were there to the human eye messing with
people's psychological mindsets but an
AI does
not have a psychological mind it's
literally just tack and so because of
that Tony Stark and James Rhodes
basically informed all the other rings
of the Mandarin are just out there of
course the liar ring being the last one
to take off and do its own thing now
again this is kind of wild because the
rings are essentially becoming sentient
that's never happened before again we're
in uncharted territory here and so what
we end up finding out here is that where
abigail or red peril of course has been
chosen the wheel to one of the rings of
the Mandarin her allegiance is not so
cut and dry and that's what makes things
kind of cool it's because usually in
Marvel Comics when a villain or when a
person has given absolutely power and
they have an agenda they usually become
a bad guy abigail is not that way she
got a ring of the Mandarin and she has
this rings abilities but she's a
journalist first and whatever she is now
second a villain or an antihero
whatever you want to call her and so her
idea is to investigate the city what's
really going on does Tony Stark have an
ulterior motive or is he actually doing
the right thing and what we end up
finding out is that the way this city is
designed to function this design to
basically create perpetual energy is
designed to be a city where people won't
have to pay utility bills where it'll
basically feed people by generating food
they won't have to go and buy groceries
it'll be 100% self-contained renewable
system and that's something no one's
ever seen before this is a
tried-and-true utopia and once abigail
begins to realize this this is when she
comes to the conclusion that the city is
quite literally designed to make
everything better for anybody who's in
it so Tony Stark is actually benefiting
humanity instead of profiteering off
humanity and so what this does is it
really changes the perspective that
Abigail has of Tony Stark she still
looks at him as just kind of like a
weapons manufacturer and a profiteer but
in this instance he's trying to do the
right thing and so tearing the city down
would actually hurt people as opposed to
help them and so what we end up having
is basically her being led to the other
individuals out there who have the rings
of the Mandarin for example a guy who
has the remake a ring calls himself Lord
remake ER and so again because of this
you know this leaves really just kinda
like a massive conflict between you know
these other members of the Mandarin core
and I guess we could really kind of call
the Mandarin core but these are the
members of the Mandarin core Iron Man
with Abigail fighting alongside Iron Man
this is really kind of cool because
again she's very much an antihero here
in the sense that she's really kind of
working against Tony Stark as much as
she's working for him and this
that she's on his side but only for the
short-term but in this massive conflict
the building that houses are no Stark
effectively comes crashing down so this
is kind of crazy because the implication
here was that this would be the death of
Otto Stark and it would be kind of a
pretty lackluster scenario of that way
the case just because of the fact that
our knows proven himself to be one of
the most intelligent members of the
stark family I mean really he's in a lot
of ways I would surmise smarter than
Tony Stark and so because of this noting
that Stark is done here with regards to
Mandarin City the city of Troy none of
this would be possible without our know
Stark could just couldn't pull it off
of course we end up finding out that
Arno actually survived the blast and
what he's been doing is he had been
working on his own version of an Iron
Man suit but it's not really a
traditional Iron Man suit as we think of
an instead it's basically just a massive
tank now of course this is kind of funny
because it's half wish-fulfillment
and a half practicality one thing you
got to think of is that auto start you
spent his entire life confined to a bed
in an iron lung and so all the
intelligence of everything he had more
or less went to waste because he could
never use any of it but it didn't keep
him from imagining what kind of life he
could have in this scenario with the
work that they've done with the other
work that are no Stark and the work that
Tony Stark have done together being
attacked by this Mandarin core we
essentially have our no building his own
his own Iron Man suit this like this
massive battle tank and just kind of
like riding high into the conflicts it
is actually really cool to see because
again it's practical it's not designed
to be this super maneuverable suit
because there's already a ton of those
it's designed to be a suit that can
basically control the different the
different models that are out there the
reason be because of course you know the
Helen AI has more or less been taken
down at this point and so because that
the Iron Man suit is kind of flying
around on autopilot some of them are
being shot down some of them are
shooting at the wrong targets but having
a suit ran by Arno that can consolidate
the AI of all these other suits into a
singular source means that he can
control all the other suits and so what
we end up having here is one of the
members of the Mandarin Corps basically
just kind of vanishes out of nowhere and
no one really knows where he went to of
course Abigail begins to poke around and
finds out that the guy has been
decapitated
not only that her hands are basically
cut off by some unknown source and her
ring is taken from her and so again what
it seems like is someone around there
somebody somewhere it's consolidating
all these Mandarin Rey
unto themselves which begs the question
are they the ones that activated the
Mandarin rings in the first place and
made them Cynthia initially we're not
given this explanation instead all we
end up having is Abigail without hands
of course her hands are basically cut
off but she continues to kind of scream
at Tony Stark about her you know agenda
and so on and so forth and that's really
about it but at the end of the day
because of the fact that Troy is just
kind of collapsed the way that it does
because of the fact that Abigail made
the case that look you're building a
city here that's great for everyone that
lives here but the targets always you
everybody's always coming after you so
long as you're here you're making Troy a
target because of that Tony Stark
basically kind of gets up on a podium
and says look you know I tried running a
city it was really too much of a hassle
so I quit and then just leaves and
that's really it
instead he leaves the running of the
city to his brother Arno Stark and so
with that in mind what we end up finding
out here is that we're the hands of
Abigail were cut off one of the members
of the Mandarin Court was decapitated
the person who had done this was
actually Malekith via cursed of course
as we know one of the Dark Elves from
Sparta honk and so what this does is it
basically brings the Asgardians into the
mix and it really kind of asked the
question what would happen if a being
who's already godlike in terms of their
durability and strength were to gain
virtually godlike powers because of the
rings of the Mandarin ok so we are at
the final story of Iron Man before we
get into superior Iron Man but it's kind
of funny here because a lot of people
who talk about or know Stark the brother
of Iron Man this is the story where it
just ends and we never find out what
happens with him it's one of the biggest
irritations that Iron Man fans have a
lot of this is because of the fact as
superior Iron Man was just like a
holdover story until only all-different
marvel kicked off when we had Avengers
New Avengers secret Wars all that kind
of stuff but the idea with this is that
in the last video we had basically dealt
with the rings of the Mandarin now for
the most part where this continues that
story the rings of the Mandarin had
always been this interesting scenario I
mean I would go as far as to say that in
a lot of ways the reach of the Mandarin
were based off the Green Lantern mythos
that is to say Hal Jordan having a Green
Lantern ring the Green Lantern ring can
make constructs the reason why I say
it's largely based off that is because
in Marvel really in DC if I'm gonna be
honest for the most part when people
think of like superheroes that wear
rings they associate that with the Green
Lantern Hal Jordan with the Green
Lantern
those the general idea here is that the
rings of the Mandarin made their debut
actually all the way back in 1961 I
think it was and stranged hails number
89 and that actually dealt just with the
idea of the the mic luhan's I think is
how you pronounce their name I can't
remember but the idea is with the rings
of the Mandarin serve different purposes
each ring can function accordingly and
what this story actually does is it
flushes out the nature of the fact of
the rings have some measure of sentience
initially we open up with Malekith via
cursed now what we don't know is how
this ring managed to get to to the realm
of the Dark Elves but the fact that the
range captured by Malekith is a pretty
big deal now remember these are not like
the Green Lantern rings strictly a and
DC Comics right like in DC a Green
Lantern ring will pop up to you and
it'll say you whoever's watching this
video you have been selected for the
Green Lantern Corps something along
those lines but then if it turns around
decides you're not worthy it'll just
leave you and go find somebody else with
this it's not the same way the Rings
seek people out but people can just
capture them they can just take them and
use the Rings for their own purposes now
keep in mind somebody to take note of
here and what we had talked about in the
last video with the character of Abigail
burns and a lot of these other members
who had been chosen for these various
rings of the Mandarin they had basically
received their rings and the Rings were
acting in accordance of people who had a
grudge with Tony Stark
whatever that grudge may be maybe they
just didn't like him as a person in this
instance is actually they had a Broadway
playing and they fired the director
because he was one of those weird
hipster art guys and the result was they
were like hey look nobody wants your
interpretation they just want to cool a
cool show and so they ended up caning
the guy the result was that he was just
pissed and he was given one of the rings
of the Mandarin picked it up and just
started using it against Iron Man so
again it's not really a very strict
process the overall gist with this is
that with Malik if basically taking one
of the Mandarin rings the goal is to use
all the Rings for himself now what this
does is this picks back up with Arno
stark and I remember at this point Arno
Stark is very much a background
character if you're new to the whole
thing of Iron Man so far in our
different videos Arno Stark was
basically revealed to have been the
brother of Tony Stark that we never knew
about basically Arno is biologically
engineered he exists for the purpose of
basically being super smart he was
basically kept away this combined with
the fact that he was basically given a
short lifespan meant that he was
confined to a bed he really couldn't
move or any
thing this was because of the fact that
a Howard Stark had messed around with
the jeans and added a few modifications
and the result was that Arnaud did not
come out the way that he was supposed to
but the general gist of this and the
general idea is that this focuses
largely on the efforts of Tony Stark
to basically travel to fartole home
travel to the realm of the Dark Elves
basically capture Malekith and take the
Mandarin rings back because that's what
Malekith has been doing at this moment
there are four Mandarin rings that are
out there that we know about and what we
know is that Malekith has been running
around earth killing those individuals
who have those Mandarin rings and then
taking them now of course this also ends
up bringing in a girl by the name of
Siobhan and Siobhan is like a weird
situation when it comes to Marvel it's
like her dad sold her soul to the devil
that her dad turned out to be evil it's
this weird thing but it goes all the way
back to like 1992 and I cannot remember
the name of her story for the life of me
but she is very obscure in a lot of
different ways but she's one of these
characters that exists out there in
Marvel Comics where she's really
knowledgeable about being able to blend
technology with magic and the reason
this matters is because of the fact that
for Tony Stark while he could basically
go to hell for say hey look man Malekith
of the Dark Elves is basically running
around and grabbing these Mandarin rings
and he's going to become super powerful
and then probably invade Asgard Tony
Stark and Thor are not on the best of
terms remember this all follow this Hall
comes out to the events of siege and so
for the most part Asgard was destroyed
in siege now Tony Stark helped to
rebuild it but the idea is that Thor for
the most part still really just doesn't
like Iron Man following the events of
civil war where Thor learned that Iron
Man had basically cloned Thor and
created this cybernetic or the cyborg
version of him so again they're kind of
on weird terms now in truth for Tony
Stark's worth in this scenario the
argument that he makes is that this
could very well lead to a massive
Asgardian think because there's the
Council of realms and all that kind of
good stuff and if he shows up on Thor's
doorstep and says hey look Malekith is
capturing Mandarin rings well then it
turns into this big political thing it
turns into this Council of realms coming
together and then it's like okay you who
represent the Dark Elves what do you
have to say about this and then it's
well we don't have you know we don't
really know what you're talking about we
haven't really done anything then is
debating and then it's deciding if
they're gonna do anything it's all that
bureaucracy all that talk well I deal
with that why not just go directly to
the heart of the problem the issue with
this is that this
was supposed to be a stealth mission and
so because of this when Tony Stark lands
in the realm of the Dark Elves
he lands in the middle of everything he
literally lands in the throne room of
malakut this is a terrible situation for
him because under normal circumstances
if he was preparing to do this if it was
in the his intention to directly go
against Malekith he would have worn
armor that would allow him to do that
but in this instance this is black ops
armor this is armor that allows him to
basically camouflage this is armor that
doesn't make sounds and so because of
this you know showing up in the middle
of a throne room with armor that's
designed for secrecy as opposed to
combat does him almost no good now keep
in mind one of the discussions that we
had or one of the common threads that
went through our discussions when we ran
over all the different armors of Iron
Man is that all the armors were built
for combat on some level just because of
the fact that Tony Stark never knows if
he's gonna be on a recon mission and
he's gonna have to you know engage in
some measure of combat but there are
armors that are better suited for combat
than others and so again that's the
basis behind this this armor is not best
suited for combat at the same time
teleporting Tony Stark to Sparta Han is
huge because there's really only three
opportunities the Power Cell the power
basis used to do this is massive and so
what can only be done three times
meaning that if he sends something to
you know back to earth or if something
is sent to him and it uses three charges
there's no way for him to get back and
so the result of this is that he really
has no choice but to fight Malekith or
at least you know Finn Dolph as best he
can and then eventually bail out now of
course the reason for this is because of
the fact that Siobhan had basically been
working on a weapon of sorts on some
kind of technology that would allow him
to basically stun these range to
temporarily incapacitate the person
that's wielding them and then take the
Rings away but something else to point
out here and this is where we get into
the whole sentience of it the Rings
basically speak with one another and
historically speaking I do not believe
this was an element of Mandarin
originally but with the Rings
communicating with one another what
we're basically getting here is this
idea that the Rings all basically Harbor
a grudge for Tony Stark now why they
hate him again we'll get into that as we
get through this but one thing that ends
up happening is that the various forces
of Malekith really kind of descend
directly on Tony Stark and so of course
again kind of fleeing running for his
life doing the best that he can
a sing-off against these forces here and
they're using guerrilla warfare tactics
he's able to hold his own to a degree
but in the end he ends up calling on
Siobhan to basically teleport an item
for the third time directly to him so of
course this basically uses up all the
charges and does not give him the
ability to necessarily teleport out and
so what ends up happening here is we
basically have Iron Man dawning this
armor now of course I don't know if this
armor was directly specified in terms of
diversion that exists but is basically
anti Asgardian armor that's really what
it's designed for
this is armor that's designed to face
off against all forms of magic and
sorcery especially anybody who hails
from any of the other nine realms
and the reason why this matters is
because given the nature of this armor
is directly dangerous to the Dark Elves
themselves now the reason why I say that
is not necessarily because of like the
repulsor blasts of the of the suit or
anything on those lines but because Dark
Elves have an inherent weakness to iron
and so because the fact that they're
weak to iron this combined with a suit
basically being designed for combat
means that Iron Man is easily able to
overpower and incapacitate every last
one of them just by dispersing these
iron particles out into the air covering
them an iron dust of different things
like that so again this is really cool
because it really kind of hits home into
the idea of where Iron Man stands one
thing to keep in mind when it comes to
the character of Iron Man this is
something that people tend to forget is
the general public the average person
when the Iron Man movie was announced
one of the biggest issues that Marvel
had when they made the film was
convincing people that Iron Man was not
a robot that it was actually a person a
lot of folks didn't really know about
him he was a pretty obscure character in
terms of the general public the non
comic reader and so when you talk when
you start talking about where Iron Man
stands in relation to various
superheroes most people say he's a guy
in a suit of armor and at best he could
go against Captain America maybe Thor
depending on the circumstances what this
tells us is that what is with his
ingenuity his intelligence Tony Stark
and stand toe-to-toe against some pretty
big guys he's not like a lactis level
right like you're never gonna read a
story where Tony Stark is like yes I
have an armor that can withstand
Galactus and if there is a story out
there that story's getting covered but
as far as I'm aware that story doesn't
exist the general sense here is that
just kind of using the weakness of the
of the Dark Elves to iron to his own
advantage he's able to
we begin taking each and every one of
them out which ultimately leads to him
basically capturing Malekith and then
stripping the ring away from Malekith
now of course this leads to Malekith
basically teleporting away the idea that
one of his servants just kind of shows
up with another ring that she had
essentially captured for herself
Malekith ends up grabbing this ring with
the intention of using it but this is
the disintegration ring this is the
spectral ring now this is actually one
of those rings that has an interesting
caveat for the most part the Rings can
be used kind of endlessly when it comes
to the spectral range because of the
fact that is designed to basically break
down matter on the molecular level
if Marvel were to turn around and say
this ring can be used at any time then
you would literally have a person just
running around dissolving everything in
existence and so what they did is they
created a caveat to say the ring can be
used but it has to be charged or it has
to charge itself for twenty minutes
after each use what ends up happening is
that this ring had already been used by
the server to Malekith when she tried to
attack Tony Stark and so the result is
that when the ring initially pops up or
when Malekith puts it on he's got 20
minutes left until he can use it again
this also coincides with what appears to
be the arrival of the of the Asgardians
now of course this is not actually the
Asgardians instead these are basically
the six other ring bearers of the
Mandarin rings the six rings that we
haven't seen yet but one of these rings
is the lyre ring this is the ring that
serves the purpose of tricking the eyes
of individuals who the ring is used on
in this instance is used on Malekith
tricking him into believing all the
Asgardians are there now of course with
these various members who have all
popped up again a lot of these guys are
enemies of Iron Man himself but a lot of
them are just general bad guys but when
it comes to the arrival of these other
Mandarin rings this is basically what's
been happening where the Rings have been
communing with one another quote-unquote
where they've basically been talking to
each other their ultimate goal is to
defeat Tony Stark but with the other
four rings having been captured by
Malekith and being used by Malekith for
his own ends it basically disrupts the
plans of the other six rings and so the
goal was to essentially attach
themselves to six other individuals who
in turn would carry out the wishes of
the Ring capture the other four from
Malekith and then allow the Rings to
function in unison and then achieve
whatever goal it was they wanted to
achieve and taking down Iron Man and so
the result here is that this basically
boils down to a circumstance where the
enemy of my enemy is my friend with Iron
Man
these rings he can't necessarily put
them on his fingers because untruths I
mean he can't really use them through
the suit and so the result is that he
kind of has to rely on Malekith in order
to basically help him out now this is
when we start invoking the things of
like magical promises and so on and so
forth in Marvel Comics one of the most
notable villains that basically uses
trickery and deception when it comes to
magical promises is Mephisto and what
Mephisto will do is you'll pop up and
he'll say okay I'm gonna grant your
greatest wish and you'll say okay I wish
I had a million dollars and the Pfister
will say okay he'll give you a million
bucks but you won't live long enough to
use any of it that's the whole caveat
that comes with this character with
Malekith it's much the same way he'll
grant your wish but there's gonna be a
trick there's gonna be some kind of
deception to it and so of course witness
and mine and with Siobhan operating on
earth basically helping out Tony Stark
throughout this whole escapade
what she does is use her knowledge of
magic and technology to essentially
create this sort of binding contract
which is to say when Malekith says I
agree to help you out to help you get
out of this alive that there's no
trickery to it there's no backdoor deal
there's no fine print and so Malekith is
basically bound to this he couldn't
violate it even if he wanted to and so
because of that he essentially whisks
Tony Stark away you know when we gives
Tony Stark the ring and they essentially
teleport out and so the landscape is now
left open for these other six mandarins
to begin achieving their own goals now
of course what it does is it basically
brings all the Rings back together again
and so with these rings basically being
brought back the idea is a now Tony
Stark and are no working together look
to basically recapture these rings and
then use them for their own ends and
that's what is up happening here is that
with these other mandarins that are out
there their goal is again to basically
take down Tony Stark and so because of
this working together Tony Stark and I
know effectively invade their base of
operations now this is done in several
different ways you have Arno and you
have Tony who are piloting their own
suits of course onerous suit is
specifically designed to cater to the
fact that Arno doesn't have the ability
to walk or really move around at all but
then you also have things like the
Trojan army for example this massive
army of Iron Man suits that were
specially designed for the city of Troy
that city that we talked about in the
last few stories of course you also end
up having you know Abigail Burns who
basically shows up again it's one of
these really cool moments because you
sort of see this this giant Kingdom of
these mandarins just come crashing
around them and so ultimately what we
end up finding out is that the person
who was in possession of the liar ring
is actually a guy named Mark now mark
was a character who was introduced in
invincible Iron Man annual number one I
think it was in 2010 and that came from
Matt Fraction
and the whole idea with Mark was that he
was initially introduced as a guy who
was essentially gonna be like a stand-in
for happy hogan to a degree one thing to
keep in mind is that happy hogan died in
Marvel Comics like he's been dead for a
while I'm pretty sure the goal was to
basically begin the process of moving
Pepper Potts
give her an actual future and so in that
story Mark had basically proposed to her
after the two of them had spent time
together and of course she accepted the
issue at this was at marks perspective
of Tony Stark was a Tony Stark was a guy
who was really just kind of a dick and
so because of the fact that this built
up the idea that Tony Stark was so crass
that Tony Stark was so cruel to Pepper
ah what ended up happening is the liar
ring chose him to be able to wield it
and so that's the guy who's been running
around using this ring the entire time
this leads to Tony Stark defeating mark
and and that's really all it is but what
this does is it basically begins the
process of answering the question of why
it is these rings hated Tony Stark so
much and this gets into the nature of
the Rogell Ian's the Rogell Ian's
basically started sending out all these
recorders of course we talked about this
during the secret origin of Tony Stark
but they started sending out all these
different you know recorders for the
purpose of mapping the universe and
observing everything and then bringing
that information back in this instance
because of the fact that the Rings are
basically technological the explanation
essentially goes like this
back when the Rings were originally
created and the Mandarin just kind of
stumbled into them accidentally
discovered the range and then started
using them for his own ends the Rings
basically began to receive an imprint of
the Mandarin they basically kind of
began to instill his personality onto
the reins himself it was the idea that
the Rings began to absorb the idea that
Tony Stark was just a bad guy they just
wanted to take him out this combined
with the actions of the recorder 4-5-1
from the secret origin of Tony Stark
this same recorder had basically sort of
leaked its personality into the Rings
themselves as well and so the result is
that the Rings basically just kind of
became sentient and the goal was to just
take out Iron Man that's where all that
comes from and so the result is that
once everything begins to sort of get
figured out it all really just kind of
begins to wind down and that's really
about it of course the Rings are
basically left in the
session of Tony Stark himself for him
and Arno to do what it is that they want
to do with it to basically use them for
their own purposes the problem with this
is that again this is the last time we
see our no we have not seen him since
it's basically just Iron Man and Arno
going off to do great things and we
never find out what happened to our no
we never see or hear from him again and
that's the biggest issue is because when
all-new all-different marvel picked up
an invincible Iron Man started we never
found out what happened to our know we
don't know if he's back in his hospital
bed we don't know if he's still hanging
out he's never been seen or heard from
he's literally a nonentity and all-new
all-different marvel now of course Brian
Michael Bendis has said he's gonna go
back and revisit the whole issue with
our know the whole concept of where's
character is and what he's been doing
which is cool and I'm really excited
about that but you know for right now
this just jumps directly into Marvel's
Oxus event and then goes into superior
Iron Man
so superior Iron Man is like one of the
best stories ever and it's hilarious
because like you guys have been
screaming at me to do superior Iron Man
like Rob we need the superior Iron Man's
[Music]
it's pretty funny to me it's pretty
interesting because it really is just a
great story now here's the deal the
superior Iron Man comes out of two
things the first thing is the second
wave of Marvel now and the other one is
axis now we haven't done axis yet and
really the only motivation for me to do
axis was to lead into superior Iron Man
so I'll leave it on you guys I mean
accessive is a pretty cool story it's
interesting up to a point but with axis
it basically dealt with the aftermath of
Avengers vs. x-men remember an Avengers
vs. x-men we basically ended up seeing
Cyclops as really in possession of part
of the Phoenix force killing Charles
Xavier
now what this did is it basically sent
some Professor X and sort of this
no-man's land in the sense that what
ended up happening is that Red Skull
basically took the brain of Charles
Xavier and then rechristened himself as
onslaught he basically had Charles
Xavier abilities of course there were
other things going on like creating
concentration camps things like that but
the idea was that in order for Red Skull
to be defeated there was actually a
spell that was cast by Doctor Strange
and Scarlet Witch and what this did is
that basically inverted people's moral
compasses so good guys became bad guys
bad guys became good guys in the
instance of Tony Stark his comic book
character basically became Tony Stark
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that's essentially what happened now the
funny thing about this is that when the
spell was reversed again basically
meaning that people will return back to
the way that they were supposed to be
Iron Man's shielding himself and so the
result was that when everybody went back
to normal
Tony Stark stayed being a jerk now the
reason why Marvel did this is because at
the end of the run of Iron Man that we
had just finished so the whole thing
with like god-killer armor and Arno
Stark the secret brother of Tony Stark
different things like that Marvel had
about 12 months between the end of that
story the end of that run and the start
of all-new all-different marvel and the
idea was that with Secret Wars coming
Marlowe was basically winding down
stories that's why you saw things like
the last days of of different characters
last days of passcard
last days of like the Punisher different
things like that and so what Marvel did
is instead of just crafting this you
know grandiose story with Tony
and last days different things like that
instead Tom Taylor was brought on board
and just gave us like this short run of
of caiafa
Ironman where he was basically just a
jerk and it's amazing so so with all
that exposition out of the way again
what this does is it actually picks up
with San Francisco now this really just
kind of follows Tony Stark moving from
New York to San Francisco proper and he
actually takes up residence at Alcatraz
but it initially picks up with with
she-hulk facing against some villain
named teen teen abomination which is
kind of a weird scenario but of course
when iron man's head gets knocked off
people start to panic only for us to
find out that it's not actually Tony
Stark himself instead it's one of his
autonomous suits we end up finding out
is that he's partying with like a bunch
of superhot chicks back at his place now
of course this leads into Pepper Potts
now one of the things that I want to
talk about here for a second and we'll
cover this a little bit more as we get
into the next video is something called
stark resilient but stark resilient was
the Matt Fraction run of Iron Man and we
actually hadn't covered that that was
the run of Iron Man that took place
before the one that we just did and in
truth it's really like the aftermath to
Civil War so is basically Tony Stark as
director of shield now the idea here is
that with stark resilient it was
basically Iron Man trying to
quote-unquote
turn over a new leaf it was Tony Stark
back then basically saying okay I don't
necessarily want to be the weapons
manufacturer what I want to do is I want
to start creating products they could
just make life better for the world so
when it comes to like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
Ironman when it got to the point in the
first film when he basically created the
Iron Man armor the actual real Iron Man
armor and then told Obadiah Stane he
wanted to drop weapons manufacturing
that's basically that element of mass
fractions run rolled over into the movie
least I'm pretty sure that fractures
right happened before then but stark
resilient was a new name of that company
so it focused on new forms of technology
different things like that phone
development so on and so forth and all
that served the purpose of just making
the world a better place the issue was
that Tony Stark realizing that pepper
was a person who would always be in
danger and aside moved her away from
Stark Industries and put her in stark
resilience so they basically run two
different companies now the idea here is
that with Pepper Potts basically running
up on him what we're introduced to is
the new Iron Man armor the endow sim
armor now this is probably one of the
coolest
suits ever like it's one of the coolest
Iron Man armors ever not only does it
just look amazing but it's an armor that
actually respond
to the psyche control of Tony Stark now
again that's not new extremists the
extremists suit did the exact same thing
but the whole idea here is that this is
modeled and predicated on the Venom
symbiote now the Venom symbiote is
basically this simia that is sentient
it does think for itself that works
alongside the host the idea here is that
with this suit Tony Stark as Iron Man
can basically modify it in a litany of
different ways it basically serves the
purpose of being an extension of himself
and so it just looks really awesome now
there are some perks to it that we
haven't really seen before and we'll
actually see those as this video
progresses but again this is really him
just being a dick what he had basically
done is he had used this extremist 3.00
app in order to give everybody in San
Francisco the ability to be beautiful
now this is where we start coming out of
the whole Arno stark storyline and
that's the biggest issue with superior
Ironman is at the end of our last run we
had talked about the rings of the
Mandarin different things like that
are no Stark the brother of Tony had
basically taken the extremists
technology and then modified it to
essentially become something that can be
used to like heal people it was
basically this like humanitarian
technology what Tony did is he took that
extremist Tech from Arno and then he in
turn modified it just for selfish means
and what he did is he distributed this
app among the entire population of San
Francisco granting them what they
perceive to be the perfect life meaning
they were all beautiful people the
problem with this is that the app only
has a trial period and when the trial
period ends they go back to looking like
their normal selves well this progresses
exactly as we would think it would in
the sense that people just start
freaking out because for them now it's
like an addiction not only that you have
those who see themselves as beautiful
and those who don't have the apnea they
don't have you know a phone to tap into
it or ever the case may be but it's not
activated for them and so the result is
that it's basically creating this social
clash the social war among the various
classes that exist now of course this
also brings it to the equation daredevil
now historically speaking daredevil has
almost always operated out of New York
but when writer Mark Waid took over with
daredevil volume 3 with issue number 36
or 38 I believe what he did is as part
as the second roll out the second phase
of the original Marvel now event he
basically moved Matt Murdock to San
Francisco and that basically saw the new
solution Nelson and Murdock as a lawyer
team and so it was kind of sitting at
Murdoch
along his own way but the idea was that
with Mark Waid it was changing things up
now again powder pots really kind of
panics here and that's the cool thing
because you remember in the Ironman
landscape Pepper Potts is consistently
the voice of reason
she's like the responsible parent and
Tony Stark's just the irresponsible
teenager and so with this a trace period
ending Ironman is charging people ninety
nine dollars a day in order to be able
to continue using this app it's
absolutely crazy it's like an Apple
product so because of this what we end
up finding out is that somewhere along
the line the mind of Tony Stark was
backed up in a digital form what we
actually end up doing here is taking
this segment where we wind all the way
back to like 1972 with Iron Man number
53 and I want to say all the way up to
1975 with Iron Man issue number 72 I'm
not gonna swear to that but there was a
villain that was named black llama and
of course we'll talk a little bit more
about this but he was a guy that was
created by a dude named Matt Friedrich
essentially what had happened is that
the mind of Tony Stark
at least when Tony Stark had been
defeated because he was almost
guaranteed death and escaped by the skin
of his teeth his mind was backed up and
so the result is that this is basically
Pepper Potts talking to a earlier
version of Iron Man now of course at the
moment we didn't know this all we knew
is that it was somebody donning the Iron
Man suit but because of the actions of
Tony Stark and swindling the people of
San Francisco this leads into a direct
conflict between himself and daredevil
because of the fact that you know Tony
Stark is really just kind of turning a
darker approach here the idea is to
basically start weeding out people that
might try to defy him and so what he
does is he actually gathers the entire
city of San Francisco which is just an
insane number of people and actually
says hey look show up at this location
is such-and-such and you'll all get like
a free sample of the whole extremist
tech now of course this leads it to a
direct conflict with a guy but of course
this again highlights another instance
of what the armors capable of in the
sense that he can basically turn itself
translucent it can make it appear as
though he's not covering his face which
he actually is but this also shows us
the darker lengths of Tony Stark
remember Tony Stark had always been a
guy who was teetering on the edge and
for years and years and years and years
alcoholism was always a major part of
his character he was always this thing
where it was like if anything was gonna
bring the Empire start crashing down it
would be his addiction to alcohol now of
course this really seemed to culminate
in the demon in a bottle storyline fun
fact it wasn't until the final issue of
the story that it was actually called
demon in a bottle where
his alcoholism almost did cost him his
entire company but coming back from it
all it basically resulted in him kind of
moving forward and trying to be a good
guy and so for the most part well I
wouldn't say he was like a humanitarian
he was certainly falling more in line
with what a traditional hero should be
as opposed to the way he was before
which was more geared towards capitalism
and so because of this this is a stark
contrast no pun intended with how he
used to be in the sense that now he
basically tells this guy look your son
literally ran up on a chick and tried to
rob her and so I can make this go away
the only thing you need to do is go down
there and tell people that you agree
with my ideas my motivations and
extremists take now on the surface it
doesn't seem like a huge thing but it is
because this is basically a superhero
blackmailing a small-time guy just for
the purpose of trying to make sure that
the world believes that what he's doing
is actually right and that's why it's so
enough arias in the aftermath of this
and with daredevil watching all of it
unfold it leads to him kidnapping Tony
Stark now of course this is really
daredevil just trying to interrogate him
as soon as stark wakes up he immediately
recalls us into some armor to himself
and then in turn tells daredevil I'm
giving you a gift and this is one of the
most mind-blowing moments of the story
because when Matt Murdock wakes up what
he ends up finding is that he can see he
has his eyesight back now this was a
huge moment in the story and it's really
one of the biggest moments for Matt
Murdock's character the reason for this
is because his lack of eyesight has been
the defining attribute of who he is as a
person in the comics it was always a
cornerstone of every writer who ever
focused on daredevil how he deals with
the world around him while
simultaneously trying to be a blind
superhero and in fact there were years
and years and years and years when no
one knew he was blind and even now in
the Marvel Universe with the time the
story was written a large bulk of it
don't know that he's blind and so in
this instance with his blindness being
one of the most defining attributes of
his character considering it's been part
of his life since he was a child it's
been how he's learned to cope with the
world to suddenly have his eyesight back
is this temporary gift now again he's
told by Tony Stark you're not gonna have
it forever it's a temporary thing it's a
very short thing but I want you to
experience this I want you to see what
the world is like and then ask yourself
are you really willing to give that up
now the other half of this is it really
shows us how far gone Tony Stark has
come when he basically says look that
whole thing with axes the whole thing
with the Red Skull
so on and so forth that showed me who by
truly and then I've basically been
dumbing myself down and were to make all
of you out there feel like you're
intelligent instead why should I do that
and so he's run drunk on his own power
his own abilities his own intelligence
so on and so forth and so again this is
a pretty dark fall for his character
because what this does is it leads into
this quote-unquote
return of teen abomination teen
abomination basically breaks out a
shield custody and then when a man shows
up he just kind of whisks him away and
says look you know I will take you under
my wing I'll basically try to help you
as best I can
now this comes out of the fact with this
revelation the teen abomination is
actually just a 13 year old kid that's
really all it is he was just blasted
with gamma radiation somewhere along the
line and that was really about it but
with Matt Murdock's character again this
is one of the saddest moments because
switching back to him he goes and he
sees foggy Nelson because he just wants
to see what he looks like with his own
eyes if only ever one time if only ever
for a brief moment for a few seconds he
wants to see what he looks like of
course his eyesight fades away he ends
up going back to seeing things the way
he normally does but this is a huge
situation for Matt Murdock because it's
this very tempting thing okay I give in
like I will I'll take my eyesight I'll
fall in line with a whole you know stark
ideology I'll do whatever it takes in
order to make sure that I could continue
seeing literally sacrifices rule as a
superhero in order to go back to being
able to see again and stuff continuing
on with with Tony Stark this is when we
start to get into this really nefarious
aspect of his character and what's
really going on with the extremis tech
in this instance it's basically this
idea that he has now implemented these
cameras so to speak you know the iron
drones whatever is it he calls them that
are basically parading around the city
of San Francisco and because that's what
they're doing is they're watching
everything everyone does all the time
basically declaring the place to be a
crime free zone and so it's really Tony
Stark setting himself up to be a
dictator becoming a villain he's really
just becoming a bad guy and so in this
moment when Matt Murdock basically makes
his return on Tony Stark and essentially
says I'm not willing to take in my
ability to see in order to fall in line
with what it is that you do I'm not okay
with that in return stark basically
takes him prisoner and then wipes his
mind basically just takes away Matt
Murdock's knowledge of everything that's
happened over the course of the last day
so again this is a huge moment these are
the kind of things that Tony Starks
doing that wiping people's minds
spying on people all the time it's
very dictatorial it's very bad guy and
so again it's interesting to see it
happen because it's just such a change
but God man he is a total jerk he is a
total bad guy and so from here what we
end up doing is we actually pick up with
a woman named Katrina and this falls in
with the whole origin to a degree of
teen abomination but it also falls in
with the idea that Tony Stark has always
had this under the surface
it's just now showing itself in this
instance Katrina was basically in a
relationship with happy Hogan
essentially the assistant of Tony Stark
but in this scenario there was a process
that was being undertaken that involved
gamma radiation but the shielding for
the lab was not when it needed to be and
so what they ended up doing was
basically seeking out Tony Stark and
saying we need more money to improve
this and Tony Stark's response was no it
was basically you're not gonna get what
you need that money can be spent better
elsewhere and so when the whole
experiment ended up taking place and it
all went awry things played out exactly
like we thought it would it resulted in
Katrina being blasted with gamma
radiation her son being blasted with
gamma radiation which explains how teen
abomination got his powers but then it
starts to fill things up a little bit
more when we end up learning that in
this instance with everything kind of
going under with the whole project
basically being scuttled by Stark
Industries and Katrina being put out of
work that in the moment where you know
her son asked for something that he
can't get he lashes out he freaks out
and he in turn turns in a teen
abomination destroys the house and kills
his mom and so because of this Tony
Stark is effectively responsible for the
creation of teen abomination and the
death of teen abominations mom this also
explains the whole backstory when it
comes to Tony Stark's mind being backed
up and it's basically him talking about
fighting a villain named black llama but
the idea was that when it runs over the
whole event of him basically facing off
against black llama and then ultimately
having the back of his mind in the
process what we end up learning is that
he essentially forgot everything that
had happened his mind had been wiped
from the time that he arrived back home
until whatever it is it happened the
next day and so what isn't happening is
when he basically sends Tina bomb
ination off when he says yes sure but
get things sorted out we'll get you
returning back to normal what he begins
doing is asking the question who wiped a
day out of my mind who made me forget
what it was that happened over the
course of that day and so that's where
the second half of the story picks up
who was it that screwed over Tony Stark
who is it that white that day during his
mind and what was it that happened
during this day of course you know how
do things they're not progressing over
the course of superior iron
okay so giving in to superior Ironman
really into the conclusion of this story
I told you guys previously this is
pretty short superior Ironman is a very
short story but it's also really cool
because this is really just kind of like
place filter leading into Secret Wars
but the idea for those of you guys who
have not seen the first video which
you'll find the Ironman playlist down in
the description but the whole idea
behind the first video was that this
basically served the purpose of giving
us this really dark and sarcastic and
really kind of sadistic version of Tony
Stark after the events of axis of course
axis being the event where it basically
saw the personalities of a lot of
Earth's superheroes
being inverted meaning good guys became
bad guys bad guys became good guys now
we're the spell was eventually reversed
Tony Stark shielded himself from the
spell he's basically a bad guy now and
as it unfolds it's actually not gonna be
one of these things where it's like well
I mean he's kind of a bad guy depending
on how you look at it he's actually
gonna be a bad guy and again the way
this really starts out is with the idea
of him meeting up with the federal
government now remember when it came to
superior Iron Man in the first video we
had talked about how he had basically
launched extremest 3.0 which is to say
the third iteration of this extremist
tech that could be used to biologically
alter people now he had done this for
the purpose of making everybody in San
Francisco beautiful and then charging
them $100 a day in order to basically
stay that way but the idea is that he's
shooting for much bigger here and again
that fits in line with Tony Stark and
we'll talk about that here in a minute
but of course what he ends up doing is
selling something to the federal
government which is worth about 200
million dollars but of course he also
tells the tells the US military he has
an offer for China and for the for
Russia as well presumably for the same
thing now we're not told explicitly what
it is that he's selling but whatever it
is if he sells it's worth 200 million
dollars now what he sells is not
relevant what is relevant is the fact
that he's got 200 million bucks and the
questions being asked what's he gonna do
with it now of course this question is
being asked by Pepper Potts as well as
classic Iron Man and that's the other
half of the equation because of the fact
that Tony Stark had basically become a
villain of sorts what we ended up
finding out is there was an instance
where by he fought a villain called
black llama and because of the fact that
the battle almost cost him his life on
the off chance that he ended up being
killed Tony Stark actually backed up his
own mind with his memories experiences
the whole nine yards so that if you were
to die that backup could be used
presumably thrown into a cloned body or
something along those lines and he in
turn would be able to continue on his
normal life and so because of this this
backed up version this classic Iron Man
is basically his original self it's the
way he was before the events of axis
ended up taking place now of course what
this does is it makes things on a
strange here because what we'll actually
find out is that because they're
basically the same person that this
classic Iron Man is actually gonna have
some pretty nefarious motives what we
also end up learning is that with this
$200,000,000 the goal of Tony Stark is
to actually travel to one of the biggest
media Mongols in the world buy them out
and then use them for his own purposes
now with this instance it's all done for
the purpose of him basically forcing
these guys hands now
this is a publicly traded company and
what that means is that he's actually
able to go through and just take it over
where the hostile takeover by a massive
amount of shares but in order to
basically force their hand what he
actually ends up doing is leaking to the
press the idea that he wants to buy this
news outlet now it puts these guys in a
rock and a hard place and the reason why
is because while this guy is the CEO and
while he is basically the guy that
helped to build the company
he's beholding to the shareholders his
company is only as valuable as its stock
value and so if the stock price begins
to fall and suddenly his company will
become virtually worthless but because
of this Tony Stark uses that to his
advantage to basically say people are
gonna start pulling out if you don't
give them answers so either you can
accept my offer or you can turn down my
offer but my offer is gonna go through
one way or another now of course what we
end up finding out here is this company
is not going to sell out to Iron Man and
the reason why is because they already
have a buyer and that buyer is in the
form of Pepper Potts now in the last
video we had talked about how Pepper
Potts a massive amount of wealth that
she has at her disposal comes by way of
resilient resilient was basically this
company that was formed by Tony Stark in
which Pepper Potts was put in charge of
just because of the fact that with her
close proximity to Tony Stark to Ironman
as part of Stark Industries it
constantly made her a target for the
various villains that he was facing and
so the idea of Ironman was to basically
form this company called stark resilient
that would serve the purpose of creating
all these different products for making
people's lives better phone products and
different things like that
and then in turn Pepper Potts would be
put in charge to that come
that way anybody coming after Ironman
would have no reason to believe that she
was attached to his company and so
because of that she has this massive
corporate wealth behind her and of
course she ends up buying out this major
media outlet because she had really just
kind of guessed that's most likely what
he was going to do but what this also
does is this Brees classic Tony Stark
and superior Tony Stark face-to-face and
so what ends up happening is this suit
of course takes off it ends up battling
superior Iron Man for a little bit but
then almost immediately takes him
prisoner and what ends up happening here
is this suit of armor reveals its own
purpose this classic Iron Man or this
classic Tony Stark basically says that
superior Iron Man is a bad guy the world
is better off without him and so what
does classic Iron Man intends to do
against the wishes of Pepper Potts is to
actually wife the mind of superior Iron
Man and put his own line in its place
again basically achieving this ulterior
motive for its creation in the first
place albeit against the wishes of
superior Tony Stark and so once they
actually into the mindscape is really
kind of cool
because what this does is it gives us
this perspective of how superior Iron
Man actually sees himself I mean as we
would expect with Tony Stark he's all
about himself when they go into the
mindscape of superior Iron Man it's
exactly what we think it is it's just
super hot chicks parties all the time
everybody thinks she's the most
important person ever and people idolize
him that's really about it but what
classic Iron Man does not know is that
superior Iron Man's actually using his
armor using his endo sim tech to
actually infiltrate the classic Iron Man
suit now remember this would be like if
you faced off against a version of
yourself from ten years ago the version
of yourself and ten years ago does not
have all the experience that you gained
over the last 10 years and so because of
this the immediate goal is to seize
control of superior Iron Man and then in
turn just kind of move forward from
there now of course what this also ends
up doing is it leads to superior Iron
Man of course destroying this armor by
virtue of using his own sin doe sim suit
the problem with this is it's like the
Terminator series in trying to destroy
Skynet Skynet was everywhere it's like
trying to stop the Internet the
Internet's all over the place because of
that this digital backup cannot be
destroyed through conventional means
which is to say it's not housed in a
suit instead as long as this suits
destroyed another one will come for
superior Iron Man it'll always work that
way because it's a digital backup
so the idea of superior Iron Man of Tony
Stark is to basically figure out where
this AI is being stored and then destroy
its location deleting the artificial
intelligence the problem with this is
that trying to locate Tony Stark becomes
infinitely more difficult and the reason
for this is because of the fact that he
actually takes refuge back in San
Francisco and literally just starts this
massive party now this is important
because if this were superior Iron Man
going for somebody else it would just be
collateral damage and he wouldn't care
that's how his personality is now that's
how it's been inverted
but with this classic Iron Man
collateral damage it's not something to
consider it's better to simply not
attack and to attack where innocents are
present what this does is it allows a
superior Iron Man the chance to
basically begin going through all these
documents going through these databases
chasing down information as best he can
until it manages to come across where it
is that this digital backup is being
stored at now of course with him making
this declaration that he knows what's
going on that he knows where everybody
is taunting this classic version of
himself to come after him what it does
is it leads to the endo sim armor facing
off against all the previous suits I'm
Iron Man and that's cool because what
this does is it's designed to highlight
just how far Tony Stark has come in the
development of his Iron Man suits now
the idea here is that with the Indo sim
it was designed to be superior that's
how Iron Man operates and it just makes
logical sense each suit is supposed to
be better than the last and so because
of this the idea of Iron Man is to
basically use the Indo sim armor to take
out every single one of these suits
which he for the most part successfully
does but not without having to bring out
the big guns because of the fact that
he's facing off against suits like the
Hulkbuster armor dealth suits different
things like that what he ends up doing
is actually utilizing the Indo sim armor
to its fullest capacity and that was the
purpose of it right like the purpose of
the Indo Samar mer was to be this
all-encompassing suit it was literally a
Swiss Army knife it could be anything
for any given situation and so because
of that he literally just cuts a swath
through every single one of these armors
that he has it's no real contest he's
able to take every single one of these
guys out until Pepper Potts emerges in
her own Iron Man suit now this gives
Tony Stark pause to stop and the reason
for this is because on the surface it
actually looks like he still cares about
Pepper Potts basically says look okay
I'm not going to attack you now of
course where he refused
to stand down pepper ends up using a
sonic device on a suit now the reason
why this seems to work is because the
endo sim armor is designed and modeled
after the Symbian suit which is to say
venom carnage with a venom and carnage
symbiotes sound is one of the biggest
weaknesses they have as well as fire I
do not believe fire is a weakness for
carnage but I believe it is for Yana I
know what it's for venom but regardless
because it's based on symbiote tech it
just made logical sense with pepper
potts knowing about the history of Iron
Man being well aware about all the
villains that exists out there to
basically use whatever ability she can
to her own advantage to take out the
suit now of course this knocks Tony
Stark out brings him back to stark
resilient that kind of a thing but
because of the fact that he had figured
out where the database for these Iron
Man suits are out where this digital
backup was located what he did is
actually instill a virus inside stark
resilient and what this does is it
literally sources out and it goes
through every single thread of code it
goes through every database every hard
drive the whole nine yards and it seeks
out every little bit of this digital
backup of himself that exists out there
and deletes them all and so because of
this once it's done and once it's pulled
off he literally just says and we're
finished here of course he donned a
superior Iron Man suit and walks away
but not before throwing a cherry on top
what he basically does is wear Pepper
Potts believes he can still be redeemed
what he says is no I tricked you I led
you to believe that you could defeat me
when Pepper Potts makes a case of saying
hey I - I stripped you of your honor
once before I could strip you again he
basically says look do you really
believe that I would have made a suit
that had a weakness to loud noises all I
would have to do is fly through a
construction site and suddenly I lose
everything suddenly the suit comes
crashing down or something along those
lines and so what he basically reveals
here is that Pepper Potts is not someone
he cares about Pepper Potts is a means
to an end now this is huge because
historically speaking when it came to
pepper while there was some sort of a
you know strained romantic relationship
between the two of them where were
always those instances where Tony Stark
basically indicated he wanted to get
with pepper they never really did and so
because of that pepper feels a huge
betrayal because despite all that they
were still extremely close friends
pepper was like the one person in the
world that Ironman trusts and she
trusted him more than anybody else and
so because of that for him to basically
say no yura means to an end
you're just a way for me to basically
achieve my goal it destroys
everything that she believes about
herself it destroys the idea that she
felt like she was actually a friend to
him so what this does is it basically
picks up of course with Tony Stark at
Stark headquarters and then it segues
itself into Secret Wars now the problem
with this is the continuity of this
story we could argue this story resides
just before the incursions we could
argue this story resides before the
incursions even started happening we
don't know the exact placement of this
or at least I haven't been able to find
it I mean there's reading orders and all
the reading were simply say this is the
story before Secret Wars because the
last page says on to Secret Wars 2015
let's go check it out but in terms of
the events of the story all indications
seem to be that in Secret Wars issue
number 0 where Captain America and Iron
Man fought for the last time did that
version of Ironman that version of Tony
Stark is superior Iron Man that he's
still basically the bad guy but again
it's just kind of the things that he
says that leads us to believe that more
so than a declaration of I am superior
Iron Man and I'm funning against Captain
America now but alright so I am starting
to come down with a cold and that sucks
because no one ever says yeah I got a
cold wifey Kentucky sucks like I need to
rent an apartment in Florida and just
like live in Florida for the wintertime
you know and they come back to Kentucky
in the summertime that's what I need to
do because Kentucky sucks in the winter
club anyway so we're covering Civil War
the problem I guess that'll work too the
problem with this is a civil war - its
massive I mean it's eight parts it
really feels like it could have been
like 16 parts you know 16 regular issue
comics but it still works out pretty
well I mean maybe you closer to like 10
or 12 but it still comes out it so comes
up pretty solid it's what we're gonna do
is were actually gonna split this into
two parts and both parts will be out
today so I won't make you guys wait like
a week you know for part to you but
there was actually an interview that was
done with axel alonso and i think joe
cassano there were two separate
interviews and both of them basically
said that like Civil War two was done to
capitalize on the movie like that was
really the only reason why it was
written they had to plan it out in a
really short amount of time in order to
take capitalize in the film that would
really make a whole lot of sense to me
because Captain America Civil War was
based on Civil War one but but in any
event what the story does is it actually
opens up with the introduction of a new
inhuman named Ulysses now those of you
guys who are just now getting into
Marvel Comics and I imagine there's
probably a lot of people who are just
now jumping onboard Marvel has kind of
been doing this push of the Inhumans
not really like eclipsing the x-men
because the x-men are getting their own
solo stories so it's not like they're
being shunted off to the background but
the Inhumans are certainly being moved
out
the realm of obscurity because that's
really what it the way used to be
forever and ever and ever the Inhumans
were backup features in like Fantastic
Four there were backup features and like
Thoris stories they would have
miniseries like inhuman volume two by
apologies and jaylee but it was never
like you know an ongoing thing the
Inhumans never really had like top
billing I guess in Marvel comics and so
because of this during the events of
infinity when Thanos invaded the planet
Earth looking for a son
the conflict between Thanos and black Bo
led to the detonation of the Terrigen
bomb which allow the Terrigen mists to
spread across the world and start
awakening new Inhumans but what it also
did is allow writer Charles Soule to
start expanding on the inhuman mythos
telling us that were we previously
thought it was just the Inhumans in at
Ilyn but they were actually inhuman
camps all around the world that nobody
knew about and they had been existing
for hundreds or thousands of years but
they were just operating in secrecy was
actually kind of a cool concept but it
also allowed Marvel to come back and to
basically bolster the roster of the
Inhumans now things were also kind of
shaping up too and changing around a bit
in terms of all-new all-different marvel
for example Johnny Storm is back he was
one of the first members of the original
Fantastic Four to reappear in Marvel
Comics but he's currently with Medusa
right now of course we have beast with
them and so on and so forth but nyan
humans are really kind of split into two
groups right I mean it's basically kind
of like the situation where you have one
group that does field stuff where they
go out and find new Inhumans and then
you have Medusa discount of ruling from
the Inhumans city and taking those
Inhumans who have been discovered and
then giving them leadership giving them
direction so it's kind of a a two sided
operation but from here we basically
pick up with New York and I downtown
Manhattan and the reason why is because
we essentially have all the Avengers by
at least all-new all-different Avengers
uh not to mention the Inhumans and we
have Thor we have a multitude of
different heroes all coming together for
the purpose of fighting off this
celestial destroyer now this destroyer
is a plot point I mean is it's not like
something that we're gonna see later on
I mean it's not a major focal point but
what it does do is it shows us how
dangerous things could be and it shows
us how important Ulysses is at least the
way that that Brian Michael Bendis is
presenting him to us the reason why I
say that is because you know while
everybody's kind of celebrating and
everybody's like yeah you know we did a
great job guys we defeated the celestial
destroyer and send it back to its own
dimension and so on and so forth the
question is asked by by twenty stark and
Carol Danvers and a few others how was
it you know who tipped us off I mean
because at the end of the day they were
all just kind of called to this location
to fight this is a celestial destroyer
there was no real answer in terms of the
who it was that brought them all
together and what happens here is Medusa
of the Inhumans introduces them all to
Ulysses and this is where things start
to spiral out of control now a lot of
people will say that civil war 2 lacks
the grandiose nature of civil war 1 in
the sense the Civil War 2 was like super
rushed but one of the things a lot of
people tend to forget is that civil war
1 it was one moment Tony Larkin and
Captain America and friends the next
moment they were enemies I mean it was
literally the instance where shield
tried to arrest Captain America and he
jumped off the shield Helicarrier and
went underground that suddenly he was a
bad guy so it was the turn of a page
that that that Captain America was now a
vigilante and that's really what what
business is giving us here this is kind
of the cool thing because for me and
Civil War to Bendis really invokes like
these these fundamental emotions right
like as we go through this you're going
to hate Carol Danvers there's no two
ways about it you are going to hate her
character but the fact that business can
craft this story in such a way that you
just hate her that you're just like
aren't Carol Danvers is the worst person
in the history of Marvel Comics shows us
how good of a writer he is in terms of
situational storytelling and that's why
I say I think Bendis is a better writer
when it comes to developing characters
than he is doing major crossover events
I feel like he's really really good at
creating a character developing that
character and then setting that
character loose into the Marvel Universe
I think he's he's super good when it
comes to that kind of thing but again
you know the idea of Ulysses I mean you
can see the future raises a lot of
questions so ones versus the superheroes
do is they basically grab Jean Grey now
keep in mind this is all new x-men Jean
Grey right so this is Brian Michael
Bendis is all new x-men before Secret
Wars happened when beast went into the
past and grabbed the younger x-men and
brought them into the present day and so
it was basically a way to kind of
reinvigorate the x-men series without
you know going all the way back to the
very core roots of it all so because
this this is basically the young Jean
Grey the one that old man Logan is
really creepy about where he's like
creeping all over her it's weird like
it's it's it's it's weird that's the
best way to put it
it's weird in any event Jean Grey is
kind of like the go-to psychic you know
the go-to telepath because member
Charles Xavier isn't here we have no
idea where Charles Xavier is as far as I
know he's gone so because of this with
Jean Grey going through what she says is
I am essentially going to cordon off a
part of your mind at least some part of
your mind that deals with these visions
you're going to have a vision and then
I'm basically going to act as an anchor
and I'm going to allow everybody else to
see these visions that you're having the
problem with this is that when Ulysses
tries to under
the process of creating a vision in the
industry field that his mind simply
can't be read that it's not possible for
Jean Grey to tap into it now this raises
even more questions than it answers
because of the issue now is well is
Ulysses immune to telepathy is he like a
cosmic entity is he some wildly powerful
equivalent of omega-level mutant when it
comes to with humans you know what's the
whole deal now because of this because
of the fact that he's essentially like a
black box of information it creates some
very serious trust issues because right
off the bat Carol Danvers is like yeah
man like we trusted him you know and he
told us a celestial destroyer was gonna
show up and then it did and then we
defeated it and it was only possible
because of him like he is the future
he's going to be a way for us to stop
crimes from happening but Tony Stark's
like mad I don't know there's this this
inhuman that we know nothing about we
can't read his mind we don't know his
motivations we don't know how his powers
work and we're going to take it as an
absolute truth that what he's telling us
about the future is actually going to
happen
it creates a really really cool
situation because again this is very
much the the idea of if I go to you if
you know a member of the Rob core you
watching right now let's say your name
is Steve I have no idea if your name is
Steve or not but let's say your name is
Steve and I say Steve you're going to
win the Powerball jackpot of 100 million
dollars on Saturday now if you go and
you buy a Powerball ticket and you win
did you win because you were going to or
did you win because I told you you would
and you wouldn't have bought a ticket if
I didn't tell you that you know that's
that's the situation that's being
presented here is which one is it is it
she can come before the agra to the egg
come before the chicken and so it
creates a really weird situation for all
the superheroes because they're trying
to understand how it all functions the
other half of this is that we
essentially get the back story of
Ulysses now there's not a whole lot to
offer here within the confines of the
main civil war story itself I think we
actually got its high in more or less to
the civil war event the focused heavily
on Ulysses um he's an interesting
character but he's kind of a one-off I
mean it's one and done with him but all
it really says is that you know he was
at his Ohio University or I guess at
Ohio State the Terrigen mist came
through he emerge from his cocoon he
didn't feel different but then suddenly
he started having visions of the future
and this is why I say things begin to
switch around and things begin to create
a rift between Harold Danvers and Tony
Stark now the cool thing about this is
that badness does not make this rift
immediate I mean it is to a degree in
the sense of they don't really see eye
to eye but it's really more of like a
disagreement or like a heated debate as
opposed to if you go through with this
Carol Danvers I'm going to kill you it's
not like that you know it's not that
violent but it is enough for us to know
that things are gonna be going in a
screwed-up direction tougher here we
jump back
two new Attilan again off the coast of
New York and we basically have you know
Ulysses having another one of his
visions and he ends up you know calling
and Medusa and says we need to grab the
Ultimates because remember the Ultimates
are like the ultimate Avengers they are
essentially the Ultimates from the
Ultimate Universe which was like deal to
be universe version of Avengers they
were The Ultimates rolled over in
all-new all-different marvel with the
same name but given a different role
they were just more on a cosmic scale
kind of situation but the idea here is
that with Ulysses calling in The
Ultimates we know something huge is
going to happen and so what we do is we
transition over to Tony Stark's
laboratory now keep in mind here he's
still dealing or he still has his AI
Friday and Friday actually came before
Secret Wars she was a really a really
cool concept but then we still I guess
we also have Mary Jane Watson running
the show now Mary Jane Watson running
the show was part and parcel to the
events of invincible Iron Man under
Brian Michael Bendis I think and it was
really just a situation I can true it
was a Tony Stark was doing but he had
done something who screwed things up and
the board was trying to kick him out and
what they needed was somebody who can
operate in his stead in a business
capacity and then Mary Jane Watson was
brought on board to basically say I
speak on behalf of Tony Stark and you
guys need to get the hell out of here or
you guys are you guys are all gonna end
up being broke that's that's the reason
why Mary Jane washes here at the moment
I know that part of that is is like the
amazing spider-man I know that an
amazing spider-man a lot of that was
covered it was kind of a back and forth
between spider-man and Iron Man but you
know having his attention drawn by
Friday and Mary Jane Watson Mary Jane
Watson says you know Rodi Rodi is
basically gone you know it's the message
rody is dead and so from here this is
where the riffs really begins to grow
this is the the point at which it's the
event horizon it's it's the point of no
return it seems like there's really no
way that this riff can be mended between
Tony Stark and Carol Danvers because
rumor rody is the closest friend that
Tony Stark has had for quite some time
and so what we learned is that ulysses
at old Carol Danvers look you know
Thanos is coming and when they went to
go ambush him it resulted in all of them
being crushed a lot of them being
defeated now for Stannis was defeated
well the issue is that Thanos was not a
cakewalk you know even on his weakest
days even when Thanos was at his weakest
he is still wildly dangerous because
you're talking about a guy with
thousands of years worth of experience
you're talking about a guy with some of
those most advanced technology of the
universe a guy with all kinds of
battle-hardened tactics I mean Thanos
has fought Galactus and survived to tell
the tale so if you're talking about a
very formidable threat
you know with intelligence in the whole
nine yards and during this conflict
James Rhodes had basically been killed
and she-hulk was injured to the point
that she had to be hospitalized now this
is why the rift is created because of
the mind of Tony Stark Carol Danvers is
at fault here you know Carol Danvers led
them into a conflict against Thanos
against one of the most powerful beings
in the Marvel Universe you know and
because of her foolishness because of
her foolhardy desert because of the fact
that she just trusted the vision of a
guy that she's known she knows nothing
about she effectively got James Rhodes
killed and so because of this what we
end up doing is we actually switch over
to Tony Stark's that night when he ends
up travelling after and trying to find
he lyses now for those of you guys who
are reading Hydra Captain America this
is why I say NIC Spencer changes the
entirety of civil war a Hydra Captain
America was a storyline that came after
a vendor's standoff when the cosmic you
basically reformed into comic this young
girl that was used by the Red Skull to
effectively warp the past of Steve
Rogers and alter it so that he was
always an agent of Hydra NIC Spencer
while all this is going on right now you
know while Tony Stark is fighting Medusa
is in the home of the Inhumans you know
while he's trying to kidnap Ulysses all
of this is being washed by Steve Rogers
and we don't we don't see it here it all
happens off Hanul that's why I say like
Nick Spencer's Captain America is a
really really cool thing because it
gives us the other half of this and it
really bolsters this as a Hydra agent
this is what Captain America wants he
wants the Avengers to effectively fall
or at the very least to be fractured to
the point that they can never really be
whole again the problem with this is
that Tony Stark's still wildly
intelligent and and to be honest here
with the exception of Hank McCoy there's
really no one here right now among the
Inhumans or the Avengers that really
matches up to his level of intelligence
I mean the smartest people in the Marvel
Universe right now are really just just
Tony Stark Hank McCoy and Black Panther
I mean that's really you know Reed
Richards isn't here I guess you have dr.
doom but he's off doing his own thing
right now he's not really part of the
equation but in terms of the civil war
to event those are really like the three
top guys in black hands who doesn't care
what happens as long as nobody attacks
Wakanda so because of this it really
just leads you know the idea that that
Tony Stark would have broken up into new
Attilan the fact that he basically
kidnapped ulysses while tricking the
Inhumans into believing that he was
fighting them basically creating a decoy
it's essentially created a circumstance
where he's effectively waged war against
the Inhumans now the reason why he did
this is because we're tony stark just
accepting the visions of ulysses as an
absolute truth is not good enough Tony
Stark is a man of science all right Tony
Stark wants to be able to sit down
this has to be able to be traced I have
to be able to find a way to verify that
this is true you know if I can do that
then I can say okay let's trust this but
if I don't know how it works on a very
core very fundamental level you know at
its very essence then I won't take it as
absolute truth and so what he begins to
do basically is he doesn't really
torture Ulysses so much as he begins the
process of trying to stimulate him in
such a way that it'll produce villain so
you know scaring him threatening to beat
the hell out of him there are things
like that now he doesn't really have
like a vision per se but the part of his
brain that basically controls these
visions the frontal lobe were the very
least the part that would see these
visions begins to light up more so than
it showed it so at the very least Tony
Starks being able to deduce that the
activation of these visions are based on
his emotional state now this will
actually become a very important thing
later on down the line as we get further
into the story but what is up happening
is of course Carol Danvers basically
shows up it says hey look you kidnapped
a member of the Inhumans you effectively
waged war against the Inhumans
themselves we want to try to keep this
tone down we don't want things to get
escalated but what we do want to do is
effectively take you into custody for
kidnapping now while this whole debate
is going on while this whole argument is
going on
Ulysses begins to have one of his
visions and the vision that he has is of
the Incredible Hulk basically just
rampaging and killing everyone now
somebody else I'd like you to keep in
mind about these visions of Ulysses is
that all these visions or apocalyptic in
nature and something I hope you seemed
so far the the vision of Thanos
attacking everybody the vision of the
celestial destroyer the vision of B
Incredible Hulk it is people just losing
their minds you know villains coming in
or some entity from another dimension
coming in and laying waste to everyone
and there's a reason why Brian Michael
Bendis is doing this and we'll find out
at the end of all this but um ulysses
you know and he has this vision for the
first time since he began having them
he's able to share them with people so
they feel what's going on they see
what's going on it's like they're in the
vision alongside Ulysses and so what
they basically discovered or at least
what they have what they've been led to
believe is that the Incredible Hulk has
reemerged from from Bruce Banner and
basically killed everyone and so because
of this it leads Carol Danvers to
against a proactive and to say okay
we're going to be going after Bruce
Banner like we got to find a way in
order to to curtail this whole thing now
what this does is this actually picks up
in a courthouse now the cool thing about
this is that Bendis starts jumping back
and forth between this trial and the
events as they once folded so basically
we're being told what's happened by a
way of this trial but essentially what
had taken place here is Carol Danvers
had shown up and said
okay Bruce Banner you need to come with
us now this is why what I really just
started hating Carol Danvers because I'm
just like well the guy hasn't done
anything but you kept knocking on its
door and you're like you need you're
under arrest it's like why it's like
well because somebody said you will do
something later on because that's really
what Carol Danvers is going on here
she's going on here say that's that's
really this guy Ulysses is like hey that
guy's gonna do something and the curled
in was like okay let's arrest him that's
really what it is I mean that's that's
she's just going on the belief that what
Ulysses is predicting is actually true
now the other half of this is that Bruce
Banner is experiencing an insane amount
of betrayal because keep in mind despite
the fact that he has been the Incredible
Hulk although at this point it's really
like the Incredible Hulk
essence it's kind of a transfer to
Amadeus Cho and so Amadeus Cho is The
Incredible Hulk
because of the fact that he's been the
Hulk in the past there is some measure
of distrust and the sense that people
don't know if the Hulk is gonna
reimagine and what will happen if it
does but Ed's Bruce Banner he's one of
the most respected people in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe one of
the most respected people among all the
scientific community I mean there have
been instances where people who distrust
him because of the fact that he's the
Incredible Hulk
would go to him and ask him for help and
in fact that's the whole crux of the Red
Hulk storyline that we're doing right
now and what we're Hawks is that
Thunderbolt Ross doesn't trust Bruce
Banner but he does need his help and so
again it creates a really interesting
scenario here the problem with this is
that as he's basically being
interrogated you know when Carol Danvers
was coming along and saying look we have
reason to believe that you're gonna hurt
back is the Incredible Hulk again when
they basically have Hank McCoy hacked
the files of Bruce banners computer and
discover that he's been experimenting on
himself using dead gamma cells all
arrows seem to point to the idea that
Bruce Banner is trying to find a way to
reactivate the Incredible Hulk
now we don't know the full story here
you know Bruce Banner tries to explain
and say hey look these experiments that
I'm doing are the only reason why the
Incredible Hulk hasn't emerged over the
last year as it was entirely possible
that Bruce Banner was using these dead
gamma cells to verify the cells are dead
and that they're staying dead or the
very least to understand why those cells
are dead and how to keep them from
reactivating so the Hulk will never come
back we don't have the full story
instead in the midst of being
interrogated by Carol Danvers in the
midst of being betrayed by a lot of his
friends he's suddenly killed by a rogue
arrow now at this point this is what we
learn the basis of this trial the reason
why this trials been put together is
because Hawkeye killed Bruce Banner he
shot him through the eye with an arrow
the reason why I heart are why clip
Martin did this though is what he
basically says that Bruce Banner asked
me to now this is where things begin to
get a little iffy because according to
Hawkeye's testimony and as far as they
know at this particular moment in time
paka is the only one that can can verify
this or the only one that really has any
information on this but he says his
Bruce Banner sat down with him one day
and said hey look on the off chance that
I ever turn into the Incredible Hulk
again here is an arrow of my own design
use it to kill me you know take me down
and keep me from being able to Hulk out
now Bruce Banner didn't specify it as
far as I'm able to tell he didn't
specify if he meant for Hawkeye to wait
until he became the Hulk or her Hawkeye
to be in a situation where it looks like
he's going to become the Hulk and then
take him out it seems like it was really
just kind of left of Hawkeye's
discretion and that's when Hawkeye says
you know Clint Barton says look banner
told me that if there were ever a
circumstance where he looked like he was
gonna Hulk out again put him down I made
a judgment call based on what banner
told me not only that when Hank McCoy
calls to the stand hey McCoy says this
custom arrow tip was basically designed
by Bruce Banner looks like it was
created it was invented by banner
himself there's also a video diary where
banner basically says I have asked clint
barton to kill me if I ever end up
becoming the Hulk again now this is
where the subtleties of law began to
come into play and because the question
that's being asked here is okay if Bruce
Banner told you to kill him if he ever
became a Hulk does that mean that he
wanted you to kill him if he was going
to become the Hulk if it looked like it
or to kill him after he became the whole
and Hawkeye basically says I was never
given definitive answer here but I did
what Bruce Banner asked me to do Bruce
Banner said if it ever looks like he's
going to become the Hulk I should shoot
him and so because of that he basically
killed him now the reason why this is
important is because this is going to be
one of the things that that creates a
rift in the superhero community but it's
also going to be one of the reasons why
Hawkeye becomes very popular among the
Avengers not only that the question is
asked of Carol Danvers regarding you
know this whole use of Ulysses as you
know as part of this pre-crime
initiative whether or not it's actually
successful in what she says is yes it's
been successful more often than not
there have been a couple instances where
Ulysses hasn't necessarily been right
but they have been able to use this to
prevent prevent crimes from happening
and now the other half of this is Tony
Stark steps up a Tony Stark says that
doesn't matter we don't exist here for
the purpose of being proactive you know
we don't exist here for the purpose of
taking people out before they commit
crimes you have to let them commit those
crimes and then arrest them
otherwise anybody could be arrested for
anything you don't actually give them a
chance he basically removed free well
now a lot of people will look at Tony
Stark from Civil War one and say well
which seems like he's just reversing
things now you know he's he's ignoring
his own past that's actually not true
Tony Stark during Civil War one was
reactive you know he was he was reacting
all he simply said was superheroes need
to be registered they have to hand over
their identities they have to hand over
what their superhero names are they have
to hand over what their powers are and
they have to operate on behalf of the
government what he wasn't saying is
let's arrest people before they commit
crimes now they are two separate
arguments in terms of the impact that
they have but in all honesty I would say
the Tony Stark wasn't wrong and I still
say he's right when it comes to the
first Civil War of him because my
arguments always been of what use is
free will to a society that would use
that free will you know use that freedom
to destroy itself if a society uses
freedom to destroy itself then freedom
was pointless in the first place you
know keep society going even if it means
you make them living conditions they
otherwise wouldn't want to live in a
totalitarian kind of government so
because of this I always kind of sided
with with Tony Stark on now but again
I'm kind of digressing here because I
really love the moral arguments of a
civil war one but for Tony Stark you
know looking at the death of Bruce
Banner for him he really looks at this
as Carol Danvers is screwing up all the
way in a lot of ways he says what Carol
Danvers has a hit list Carol Danvers is
taking out heroes that she thinks her a
threat to her she took out James Rhodes
she took out the Incredible Hulk who
else is she gonna take out next is she
gonna take out Captain America is she
gonna take out you know Nova is she
gonna take out spider-man you know who
all is she going to take out next and
again this is really just Tony Stark
being angry this is him lashing out just
because of the fact that he's still so
emotional about James Rhodes but what
also happens here is the Friday AI sits
down and says look I've been analyzing
the brain of Ulysses I'm not 100% on
what it is it's capable of yet
but I do have a reasonable argument that
I can make here and what seems to be
going on here is that Ulysses brain is
not 100% accurate it's not 100% perfect
now this was also something that was
covered by way of Captain America Steve
Rogers because Steve Rogers discovered
almost right off the bat that Ulysses
predictions were not 100% accurate
because when it when it came to someone
who said I could see the future and
here's the future that's going to happen
all it takes is one incorrect guess to
verify that he's not 100% accurate
because when you're when you're dealing
with absolutes the instant
that absolute stops being absolute if
there was in doubt and so Steve Rogers
had discovered somewhere along the line
where Ulysses was basically wrong and so
he said okay fine let's use this and
let's turn the Avengers against each
other so keep in mind behind the curtain
and all this stuff you know the the man
behind the curtain is Steve Rogers and
he's pulling the strings he's the reason
why these Avengers keep going against
each other he's a reason why they keep
fighting one another because he's
basically engineered this entire
situation again you could find my
Captain America video down in the
description at this point we basically
pick up with Carol Danvers breaking the
news to she-hulk you know and she tells
us she Hulk look you know Bruce Banner
is dead [ __ ] I killed him Hawkeye said
that he was asked to kill Bruce Banner
by Bruce Banner himself he's been put on
trial for it and when she Hulk says what
was the verdict was Hawkeye found guilty
or not guilty we learned that Hawkeye
basically walked that Hawkeye was free
now the cool thing about this is that
Mars Morales provides some insight here
when he basically says but there's never
really been a case this riveting before
because a lot of people looked at the
situation as it was I said well I mean
Bruce Banner asked Hawkeye to kill him
it was a mercy killing it was you know
he euthanized him basically
you know he it was assisted suicide you
know it was Bruce Banner asking for
something and Hawkeye giving it to him
who is anybody to say that it's rock now
the idea that creates a really
compelling argument in itself you know
the moral philosophical argument if
someone asks you to kill them is it okay
for you to do it you know you're
literally granting a wish they want you
to want you to hand over but again it
creates kind of a weird situation
because what this is doing is adding in
so many themes but this is one of the
reasons why civil war 2 was kind of hard
to follow because it was so much stuff
packed into a really really small story
how do you do a really short story
honestly this should have been a lot
longer than it that it was but what we
end up doing here is we basically we
pick up with with Tony Stark and Tony
Stark I get my dogs dreaming right now I
really hope you guys can hear that but
for Tony Stark
this creates kind of a no I keep saying
it's kind of a weird situation but it
really is in a lot of different ways
because for him again he's looking at
this from a science perspective it's not
enough for Tony Stark to sit down and
say hey look you know maybe it's just a
guy that has these weird powers
everything has an origin everything has
a function in terms of how it works and
what he says is this guy Ulysses you
know if he sees the future then he wants
to know everything about him I mean if
these visions affect him emotionally
then it stands to reason that his
emotions affect the visions of the
future and so if he has a vision of the
Incredible Hulk but he's scared then
does that mean that his vision will be a
terrifying vision it'll be
that'll reflect his own fear in the
sense that he's like well The Incredible
Hulk is a very scary being and so what I
have a vision of the Incredible Hulk
I don't see the Incredible Hulk running
around you know like frolicking around
in a field full of daisies
I see The Incredible Hulk killing all
the superheroes because that's the worst
possible situation for me to see and so
that's what Tony Stark is asking he
wants to know these are legitimate
visions or if these are visions that
he's just kind of spouting out that
reflect his own personal concern not
only that what Stark also says is that
the mind of Ulysses works in such a
fashion that it basically just draws on
the existing energy around him and then
it puts it basically spits that energy
back out in the form of a vision so it
is essentially like if you were standing
in a room and you had pieces of paper
all around you and you gathered up all
those pieces of paper which are just
forms of energy it doesn't matter what
kind of energy it is it's just forms of
energy you gathered all those pieces of
paper up and then you handed it to
somebody in the end you know if you
handed it to your brother or sister or
somebody like that and you said this is
a vision of the future it's not actually
the future that he's seen what his brain
is doing is his brain is grabbing all
these different energies that reflect
what is us going on right now so the
conflict on the other side of the world
between these two warring States Bruce
Banner you know working on the you know
working on his research of the
Incredible Hulk Carol Danvers having it
out for Tony Stark you know all these
different things that are going on right
now the energy they put off reflects
their current state of where they are in
their lives and how they're feeling and
so what Ulysses does is grab all those
energies put them together and say
here's the most logical mathematical
ability on what direction things are
going to go in it's not a future that
he's seeing it's just a relatively
correct view is it's the logical outcome
of things and so it's so I don't know if
that makes any sense to you guys I don't
know if that clears things up a bit but
it's basically not the future that he's
seeing he's not actually leaving his
mind and going into the future to see
what happens all he's simply saying is
well Bruce Banner is working on
Incredible Hulk research and so you know
the the mathematical probability of the
Incredible Hulk reemerging is 80% and so
that's what his vision ends up giving
him is the most logical mathematical
ability the kicker about this is that
that was actually not Bruce Banner The
Incredible Hulk that was Amadeus Cho
but the entire explanation as it's being
given here by Tony Stark is really being
given to like Carol Danvers Captain
America Steve Rogers all these guys you
know and Carol Danvers still doesn't
want to listen when he basically says
hey look he's not seeing the future he's
just spouting out a mathematical
probability you know the question he
asked Carol Danvers is what percentage
would
be correct for you to act on this if
Ulysses said there's an 80% chance that
I don't know Galactus is gonna show up
on earth and he's going to attack the
earth you know is that good enough if
there's a 10% chance that Thanos wants
to acquire the Cosmic Cube you know at
what point do you do you draw the line
and that's a really legitimate argument
here because returning Sark again he's a
futurist and so what he's basically
saying is you have to let people commit
acts you have to arrest them for what
they've done not what you think they're
going to do because then at that point
anybody could be arrested for anything
and so again this just continues to make
a red suit to create a rift between the
two of them I guess who used to create
you know a rough circumstance so the
reason why is because during her
dealings with regards to using the
information of Ulysses the first major
error that had cropped up and his
different views came from his belief
that there was basically a woman or a
banker where he saw her working as a as
an agent of Hydra who was carrying a
briefcase Carol Danvers and shield
stepped in they arrested her for being
an agent of Hydra opened her open her
briefcase and didn't find anything in it
there's been no evidence to suggest over
the course of her life that she's had
anything to do with Hydra she's you know
got a fiance she lives a relatively
quiet life but Carol Danvers still
believe she's guilty and so because of
this she begins interrogating her now of
course this woman's like look I have no
idea what's going on I'm not an agent of
Hydra I've never had anything to do with
Hydra all I want to do is go home and
because of this or at least in the
middle of all this where Carol Danvers
says she's guilty and all we have to do
is just find the evidence to prove it
Nightcrawler basically teleports in and
gets her out of there and so what this
does is this tells Carol Danvers that
essentially Tony Stark is now taking up
arms against her that he's having his
own guys go through and teleport people
away cause problems and essentially lead
into a major conflict between the two of
them but without being sent in the next
video we'll pick up on the actual war I
guess the conflict between the various
characters themselves you know the Carol
Danvers team and Iron Man's team
fighting against each other but
okay so recording audio with a head cold
is like one of the toughest things to do
because my mind is all over the place
what we do here is we simply pick up
with all these superheroes fighting each
other now the craziest thing about all
this is that this is really just heroes
fighting each other for a little while I
mean there's really not a whole lot to
it it's pretty straightforward but the
other half of this and what bindus
focuses on is that Ulysses powers are
evolving and his powers are growing that
it's not just having visions anymore
that it's about his powers and his
visions becoming a little more complex
and in some ways a little darker the
other half of this is that Ulysses
visions are also getting to the point
where he's able to discern them a little
bit better and differentiate between
those visions that are more likely to
happen and those visions that are least
likely to happen the issue with this
though is that as he goes through and he
begins to witness this fight between all
these different superheroes or Carol
Danvers team of Iron Man's team the
guardians of the galaxy the
extraordinary x-men you know the all-new
all-different Avengers so on and so
forth what he does is he has another
vision where he essentially shows
everybody the idea of Miles Morales
killing Steve Rogers and so because of
this it's really Carol Danvers kind of
panicking and actually moving towards
the idea of arresting Miles Morales now
this is the point at which everybody
turns against her because she's talking
about arresting a kid it's one thing if
it's an adult it's one thing if it is
somebody who was more likely to commit a
crime but Miles Morales has done nothing
but fight the good fight he's done
nothing but be a superhero he's not like
Hawkeye right I mean Hawkeye was a bad
guy before he was a good guy and even
then he wasn't really like a bad guy per
se he was just kind of a victim of
circumstance he was more or less duped
into being a villain when he first
showed up he basically rectified his
errors and that became part of the
Avengers but with the rest of these
superheroes looking around and seeing
the Carol Danvers is talking about the
idea of arresting a child for a crime
that he hasn't committed yet Tony Stark
kind of loses it and says look you're
talking about a kid you're something
you're not arresting a kid and treating
them like they're an adult now in truth
the only person who really should have
anything to say here is Captain America
because he's the one that Miles Morales
supposedly killed at some point in the
future and so of course Steve Roger
steps up now remember I can't keep
harping this enough because I feel like
it's something easy to forget this is
Hydra Captain America and so while he
puts on this show of hey look like let's
be reasonable here you know let's calm
down we have to make sure we're doing
the right thing this is all a show this
is all him acting the way he is for the
purpose of
creating a rift in the superhero in the
Avengers community and the way this
comes about is what he basically says
hey look there may come a point where
Miles Morales might kill me but he
hasn't done it yet and until he does it
you guys don't need to do anything in a
lot of ways because of the fact that
he's so respected Captain America's word
is law I mean that's just the way it is
when Captain America says we're going to
do things a certain way people are like
okay let's go do it now Carol Danvers
doesn't want to listen to this Carol
Danvers is like no no no you can't just
let him go like that it calves it
America's like yes I can and he's going
home Thor take him home and Jane Foster
you know basically leaves and Carol
Danvers still wants to arrest him and so
because of that because of all this
because she's basically turned to this
point where nobody really seems to
recognize her for her I guess
everybody's starting to see her for what
she is and somebody who's so dangerous
somebody who's willing to go to whatever
mics and were to make sure that her
agenda is maintained basically everybody
begins turning against her of course
Tony Stark was already against her but
now Captain America's turning against
her shield is willing to arrest her
you know to chala black panther he
essentially sits down and says I will
follow Captain America to the ends of
the earth Captain America is a man that
I look up to he's a man that I idolized
even if I don't necessarily agree with
everything that he does I do recognize
that the side the Captain America is on
is always the right side and so he says
look I've been around this long enough
I've watched you screw up long enough
I've watched you make mistakes long
enough I'm not doing that anymore I'm
siding with Captain America this kid's
gonna go and I'm I'm a tiger I am no
longer in your corner anymore not only
that our man's team takes off daeun
humans basically abandoned Carol Danvers
and so it's really just her now at this
point this is when we start to get into
ulysses powers beginning to grow and
beginning to expand because the Inhumans
sit down and try to talk to him and
humans really look we need to talk to
you right now but he's wildly immersed
in everything that's going on in
addition to this all the other members
of the superhero community are trying to
figure out what to do next this is
really just Mar what kind of set in the
stage right I mean this has been -
saying hey look guys after Civil War -
is over we basically get into Marvel now
2.0 that's how things were supposed to
happen this was really kind of like the
Secret Wars
Fiasco all over again in the sense that
Secret Wars was supposed to finish and
then we were supposed to just segue
right into all-new all-different marvel
but because of all the delays the
all-new all-different marvel titles
started coming out before Secret Wars
ended that's basically what's happening
here you know with regards to Civil War
- you know in the sense that because of
all the delays civil war - basically
ended before the Marvel now 2.0 titles
came out
for those of the guys who were getting
into like ultimate squared or those of
you guys who are reading unworthy Thor
you know different things like that
who were reading you know the new Iron
Man with RiRi Williams a lot of these
things were supposed to come out after
this was finished and so this should
provide some clarity in terms of where
these characters are coming from
something else to note here though is
that RiRi Williams is still a part of
what's going on with regards to these
all-new all-different Avengers she's
kind of a weird situation she's kind of
a mixed bag here in the sense that she
was really figuring out you know what it
is that she was capable of doing with
regards to her makeshift eye a man's
suit while this whole Civil War 2 event
was going on that was one of the major
tie-ins of her character with regards to
the backup features and the invincible
Iron Man line of stories under Brian
Michael Bendis but something else that I
want to point your direction to is that
it's Carol Danvers herself this is why I
say that Brian Michael Bendis is so good
at developing characters because again
if you have this very visible reaction
to Carol Danvers listen that you hate
her in the story so far
then Brian Michael Bendis has done his
job and that's really the mark of a good
writer because if you were kind of go I
do this and you were like you know then
the story didn't really resonate with
you but if you were anything like me you
hated Carol Danvers you were mad as out
was Carol Danvers you know and so
business was basically doing his job
correctly not only that he shows us that
she is remorseful in her mind's eye she
sees the face of James Rhodes in his
final moments in her mind's eye she sees
Bruce Banner dead and in her mind is all
because of her is all because she
basically started all this now she would
never admit that publicly and in fact
she refuses to you know when we have
storm in the extraordinary x-men along
with you know Jean Grey and a handful of
others that show up she never comes out
and says look I'm the reason why all
this is going on but a lot of us because
of the fact that there's no time to
because things are basically moving a
mile a minute where Steve Rogers had
told for get miles morales out of here
and then Miles Morales had Thor drop him
off before he got to his home he ends up
taking off and showing up on the Capitol
Steps in Washington DC which of course
is where Ulysses had the vision of him
killing Captain America and so this is
again Carol Danvers acting in a reactive
way now from here we jump back to
Ulysses and this is actually what the
story gets kind of cool because now we
get aundrea sorrentinos aren't being
mingled and with the art of david
marquez now we something as David
Marquez um with this bit of storytelling
here this is basically Ulysses kind of
leaving this plane of existence so to
speak and actually traversing and
meeting old man Logan now the first
person he encounters is a member of a
Hawks family
course old man Logan kills him but
business doesn't really give us like an
explanation of exactly when this takes
place all we know is that this seems to
be in the old man Logan universe or
universe that is similar to it but keep
in mind when it comes to those realities
when it comes to the stories the future
of the old man Logan universe when it
comes to Days of Future past those are
all alternate realities at some point
along Marvel's timeline that was the
future at some point along models
timeline Days of Future past was the
future until it was stopped and then it
became an alternate reality at some
point along the line old man Logan was
the future until it was stopped and then
it became an alternate reality that's
how that works and so what your lyses
really seems to be doing is jumping into
these different realities
all of which were at one point the
future of the main Marvel Universe and
so because of this new way he's talking
to old man Logan this is basically the
future of the Marvel prime the main
Marvel Universe if the conflict between
Tony Stark and Carol Danvers keeps on
going in its direction the problem with
this is that he doesn't really get a
whole lot of answers here while he's
talking to oh man Logan he's like what
led to all this you know where are we
what's going on here old man Logan says
well I mean it was Tony Stark that
happened Tony Stark pushed her too far
he doesn't say who it was you know and
even when ulysses asked who is it that
you keep referring to when you say he
pushed her too far Logan doesn't respond
he doesn't answer instead he listens
just kind of yanked back to the present
day and he's essentially just kind of
talking to the Inhumans so things are
left a little ambiguous here not only
that we of course have Steve Rogers
heading up to meet with Miles Morales
now this was also covered in the Nick
Spencer Captain America Steve Rogers
story when he was basically
acknowledging the possibility that going
out and see Miles Morales here could
possibly result in his death but because
of the fact that Steve Rogers is a Hydra
agent his goal was to bring down the
superhero community and orchestrate the
fall of superheroes in and of themselves
allowing Hydra to basically take its
place the problem with this is that in
the midst of all this exposition between
Carol Danvers and Maz miles Steve Rogers
we suddenly have Tony Stark making his
appearance with his war machine armor
elite some more advanced iteration of
his armor the problem with this is that
while Carol Danvers and Tony Succar
fighting one another the indication here
seems to be that Carol Danvers basically
kills Tony Stark now that's not
necessarily the case and the citizen she
doesn't blast his armor but the reason
why Carol Danvers is able to do this is
because remember she's still binary now
this is something that a lot of people
don't know about when it comes to Carol
Danvers and I want to touch on this for
a second so we're neck in the day when
she first showed up she was just a woman
who was part of the Air Force there was
nothing
about her but she was enamored with
marvel of the Kree who operated s
Captain Marvel because of this there
came a point where she was basically
exposed to the psych magnetron and her
desire to be the equivalent of Captain
Marvel resulted in her developing the
powers that she had and so she went
forward as Miss Marvel's that was really
kind of the crux of her that happened
for quite some time but Marvel really
lost the ability to do anything special
with her because they couldn't find any
compelling stories now eventually she
was rolled over to the x-men
under Chris Claremont and he basically
made her this person that had the
ability to absorb all different kinds of
energy and then use those energy for her
own ends energy projection enhanced
strength so on and so forth and so she
wasn't really a mutant per se so much as
somebody who just had these cosmic level
powers to a degree and so because of
that following the whole era of her
being binary under Chris Claremont as
part of the expand franchise eventually
she was rolled back over and the binary
element of her character was rarely ever
seen but it was something that still
existed and that's why if you go through
and you look at Carol Danvers in like
the 1990s going into the early 2000s
even up to the present day every once in
a while you would see her use energy
blast because that's something she was
capable of doing she doesn't use it very
often but she does from time to time now
having said that and focusing again back
on Ulysses his continued experiences are
really just hide directly into watching
all these events unfold and again these
possible futures the problem with this
is that as Carol Danvers and Tony Stark
continue to fight one another ulysses
visions eventually lead him to the
ethereal plane to beyond the realm of
normal existence not only that he
basically grabs the mind of Carol
Danvers Nova Miles Morales for all these
different heroes and basically says here
are all the futures that I see here all
the things that could happen you know
there's futures Ramon stirs run
everything there's futures where the
x-men have taken over the world there
are future is where Steve Rogers is
killed by my house there are all these
different features out there Days of
Future past
Ultron takes over everything there's all
these different realities that exist and
then suddenly he moves beyond the
stromal plane of existence and he
encounters eternity now something I want
to clarify here because a lot of people
have been asking this question about
Marvel when it came to the Kimberley
idea of each comedy being chained and
The Ultimates line of stories eternity
isn't changed in this story he's not in
Chains there's a reason for that and
Ultimates squared I think it was the
Galactus actually revealed that the
Eternity doesn't she
is the multiversal eternity and that was
something that had never really been
explored before it had to a degree
mentioned maybe like once or twice but
it was nothing Marvel actually went with
instead all they ever said was well
every universe has its own version of
eternity what ultimate squared reveal is
that there is a multiversal eternity
there's one eternity that represents the
multiverse you know one eternity that
represents all the different universes
in the multiverse that eternity is
changed but all the other eternity from
within each universe which are like
these child units so to speak
they're still able to operate
accordingly so again it's kind of a
weird situation with regards to Marvel
in terms of what they're doing with the
cosmic entities is a classic example of
the left hand not knowing what the right
hand is doing and it's one of the
reasons why despite it being all new and
all different continuity errors still
reigned supreme but the fact remains
here that in this climactic battle which
does kind of feel a bit rushed we
basically have Tony Stark who's kind of
left unconscious and while he's not
necessarily dead he seems to be in this
weird kind of catatonic state now Bendis
gives almost no explanation as to why
this is all he really has be sick is
that well Tony Stark's been
experimenting on himself and beast is
afraid to do anything because he doesn't
know what kind of impact it will have
and so there's kind of leaving Tony
Stark in this weird catatonic state now
we know by virtue of what Tony Stark has
done that he's basically made himself a
computer projection we know this in the
Ironman stories and an infamous Iron Man
when he basically starts talking to dr.
doom when dr. doom becomes Iron Man we
also know this in the new Iron Man
stories when he appears to riri Williams
as her new AI or at least as the AI for
her new suit and so Tony Stark really
seems to be kind of shunted off to the
background right now and he may come
back at some point in time but this is
basically setting the stage for Tony
Stark to be removed from the position of
Iron Man for Doctor Doom to take up the
traditional Iron Man role and then Ruby
Williams to have Tony Stark being her AI
for when she becomes the Iron Man
character but again things just kind of
wrap up relatively fast I mean there's
not a whole lot of exposition here
there's a lot of questions that are kind
of left open-ended in terms of the fact
that no one knows that Captain America
is still a Hydra agent we don't really
know what direction things are gonna go
on with she-hulk but it's really kind of
the situation where everybody's dealing
with the fallout of Civil War tube in
their own ways again you know Ruby
Williams is becoming Iron Man she-hulk
is still pissed off the Bruce banners
Dan Captain America still plotting for
Hydra to take over the world Miles
Morales is still trying to deal with the
realization that he was almost arrested
for a future possibility of him killing
Captain America
people really just kind of coming to
terms with their own place in the
superhero community knowing the possible
futures that could exist for them where
the story ultimately wraps up with some
enum attic phrase about Carol Danvers
saying that she has some ideas for the
future but again we don't really know
what this means but again this story was
kind of rushed in a lot of different
ways especially when it came to the
ending it really does reflect the notion
that it was a story written for the
purpose I just kind of being a cash grab
on the main civil war movie that was
coming out Captain America Civil War but
okay so as a general rule when it comes
to comic books especially Marvel side
I really prefer more of like the darker
and edgier stories and stories like
champions I absolutely love if you can
look past all the social justice warrior
stuff it's a really really really good
story it's just sometimes it is kind of
gets in its own way
but infamous Iron Man is this story is
going to be a perfect demonstration of
what happens when Brian Michael Bendis
cares about what he's writing because
this story is amazing it is it's so good
now the weird thing here is that bindus
split it up in an odd way
usually when comic books are done
usually have just story arcs and a lot
of times those story arcs should be
collected in trade form where you'll see
like infamous Iron Man vol 1 or
something along those lines now for the
sake of my channel I just split
everything up on story arcs and just
call it volumes that way it's easier to
follow it doesn't necessarily mean that
what you see listed as a volume on my
channel will be a volume on Amazon but
it does mean that it makes it easier for
you know to follow my story so the weird
thing is that infamous Iron Man is
actually nine issues long but Bendis and
Marvel's split it into six and three so
the first story arc is six issues the
second story arc is three and then
presumably it'll come to an end but the
cool thing about this is that what this
does is this picks up previously in the
history of Marvel comics with regards to
the Cabal now the Cabal was an
organization that we're at least as it
seemed to exist here was around the days
of Dark Reign and so this of course is
when Norman Osborn had basically taking
control of shield from Tony Stark after
stark was ousted and Norman Osborn was
put in his place as director but it was
also around the time that Osborn began
to form hammer but the Cabal is a
general name given to various groups who
have existed throughout Marvel Comics
that serve the purpose of just acting as
their own little organization I mean
it's not like you know the Cabal is a
singular faction it's just it's a name
that can be used at any point in time
for example Thanos had his cabal during
time runs out
thanos the black order and name was a
submariner which by the way we will
cover the black order will probably go
through all that stuff what I'm trying
to do is I'm trying to time things so
that by the time between the time the
first infinity war movie comes out and
the second infinity war movie comes out
we're covering all the Thanos cosmology
eventually leading up so like Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers and all that
kind of stuff because yes I will finish
that for those guys who were asking
there's just other amazing stories that
I want to tell the fact remains here
that this is basically Mendes kind of
showing us who dr. doom used to be and
it's kind of interesting because it's
almost like we don't really need a
reminder it's like we know who Doctor
Doom is like we know what Doctor Doom is
about but it doesn't hurt and it's cool
because it's not like some grandiose
display of power or something like that
and what it actually does is a focus is
on an interaction between the hood
Parker Robbins and Doctor Doom now
Parker Robbins is an interesting
situation in Marvel Comics and the
reason why I say that is because of the
fact that he's basically this guy who
has access to like a lot of weapons and
stuff like that and he's more akin to
like the kingpin than anything else
but he's also been extremely dangerous
and powerful for example he is accessed
and harnessed the powers of the infinity
gems so that shows you how capable he is
and it's just an instance where he's
been able to attain absolute power for
himself on more than one occasion not
only that he's very good at being a
demagogue which is to say rallying
people to his side and positioning
himself as the sort of warlord the
interaction between Parker Robbins and
Doctor Doom here is basically a
discussion about how Parker Robbins is
asking questions that he has no business
asking in the sense that we basically
asked him about his history is it true
you gain the power of the Beyonder you
know way back in the original Secret
Wars VIN because keep in mind dooms had
the power of the Beyonder before that
was the first secret war story and then
he lost it and then you know someone and
so forth but you know basically Parker
Robbins begins asking him about the
various powers that he's had now Parker
Robbins actually also makes reference to
a story called triumph and torment I
think it is and the way this works
that's like she's gonna be a very
important part of this story and we'll
delve into this a little bit more as we
go on but the way this works is
basically it was Doctor Strange and
Doctor Doom freeing the mother of Doctor
Doom himself now again we'll get to that
as we get further into this story but
the fact remains here that because of
the fact that Parker Robbins is just
asking too many questions
doom basically just whisks him away
using his powers and it's kind of funny
to see you know because everybody's
reaction is like did you
and dunes like no I didn't kill him I
just whisked him away that's really how
these cabal's
work in the sense that there's this kind
of unwritten rule that you don't go
prodding when prodding isn't necessary
people don't start asking him a frost
about her personal life they don't start
asking namor the sub-mariner about what
it means to be king they don't ask Loki
why he's a chick and you do not ask
Doctor Doom about his mom and so because
of this it kind of jumps back to the
modern day right now now with regard to
this a little bit what I want to do is I
want to kind of sidetrack from this
story for a quick second and I want to
refresh some people or the very least
get some people caught up who are not
familiar with what's going on with
Doctor Doom in Marvel Comics right now
because I imagine there's probably a
little bit of confusion there
so doom as we know him were Doctor Doom
as you think of him the green cloak
which actually will look amazing on the
Iron Man armor oh my god that looks so
good Doctor Doom with the green cloak
with the you know the iconic suit that
Doctor Doom existed from the time he
first appeared until seeker worst but
what ended up happening is during the
main Secret Wars event when Doctor Doom
was fighting Reed Richards and they were
having as much of an emotional battle as
they were a physical battle doom finally
admitted that his greatest regret are
the one thing he hated most was that he
was not equal to Reed Richards he didn't
have Reed Richards life dr. doom did not
have a season storm of his own he did
not have a Johnny Storm he didn't have a
Ben Grimm you know he didn't have that
family connection that he loathes Reed
Richards for having and so because of
that you know the question was asked by
doom if you could do it all over again
would you do it different Reed said yes
and so what happened was the molecule
man Owen Reese who was basically the
go-between for Doctor Doom to access the
powers of the beyonders took that
ability away from Doctor Doom and gave
it to Reed Richards and what Reed
Richards did was set everything back
effectively resetting the universe now
of course this was Jonathan Hickman said
in the stage for Marvel to basically
reboot which of course Marvel botched in
the extreme and didn't do and so the
result is that when Reed Richards set
things back to the way they were
supposed to be instead of making dr.
doom inherently a bad guy instead what
he did is he restored Victor Von dooms
face and Victor Von Doom effectively
abandoned Latveria and went on this role
of basically trying to restore himself
and trying to prove himself to being a
good guy now on the surface the premise
might seem kind of lackluster but the
storytelling is anything but this is
some amazing storytelling with Doctor
Doom and that's what I'm kind of glad
that rhyme
Bendis is the one running the show here
just because of the fact that if it was
anybody else um I'd be a little hesitant
about it
but Brian Michael Bendis is amazing when
it comes to developing characters when
it comes to writing characters it's like
the one thing that he's good at above
all others and he's got a lot of other
stuff too storytelling and so on but if
I wanted to see a new character created
I wouldn't leave it to Brian Michael
Bendis to be the one to do it
but get me back into the story again
what we end up finding out is that El
Diablo has managed to capture Maria Hill
now this is kind of weird because keep
in mind this part of the story takes
place before the events of like Captain
America Steve Rogers the oath where
Captain America becomes director of
shield that hasn't happened yet you know
as far as this part of the story is
concerned and so because this Maria hill
is still director of shield but the
funny thing is that with Victor Von Doom
basically walking around no one really
knows what his face looks like all they
can do is recognize him by his voice now
of course Doctor Doom is showing off
where I guess victory you know showing
up to El Diablo there's no contest here
I mean there's it's not even remotely
close El Diablo was a deed level villain
at best I mean he was a guy who was so
irrelevant that you you've probably
never even heard of him before and it's
not even worth explaining it's really
just he's a guy who's like this genius
biochemist and basically just starts
making chemicals and things like that to
allow him to perform you know magical
stunts or what what appear to be magical
stunts now this is the funny thing here
is because there's a difference between
what El Diablo does and what Victor does
El Diablo is you know chemistry
masquerading as magic Victor Von Doom is
magic and sorcery he's the real deal and
so because of this El Diablo is is
easily taken out and in fact he's
eradicated by Doctor Doom and that's the
crazy thing is because Victor's
basically showing there's no holds
barred here but in the idea of him
killing people or really killing bad
guys it's a reflection of the idea that
he's basically trying to revamp himself
he's trying to restore himself now we
don't know how it was that el Diablo
took Maria hill prisoner and even then
Victor doesn't really address how it was
that el Diablo took Maria hill prisoner
he just says look you were captured by
like a d-list villain so I'll walk away
you walk away I won't tell anybody and
the Maria Hills just kind of like what
and that's what makes this so cool but
something else that I also hope you
notice here is the Doctor Doom as he's
being drawn in this story looks a lot
like vincent cassell
you guys don't know who that is vincent
cassell was the guy who played night fox
in Ocean's thirteen and I could imagine
I'm sorry oceans oceans twelve rather
and I could imagine him playing Doctor
Doom in like a movie that Fox didn't
screw up if if Marvel got like the
Fantastic Four back I could see him
playing Doctor Doom and it would
actually be pretty cool to be honest
about what is up happening here is
Doctor Doom transitions over to a woman
by the name of a mirror Pereira now Amir
Pereira was introduced over the course
of really you know the first Iron Man
story arc as part of all-new
all-different marvel and the white
Bendis introduced her was really kind of
like a what just happened kind of
situation where you know she meets Tony
Stark the two of them you know have
drinks and so on and so forth she makes
it clear right off the bat she's not
gonna sleep with him but her
genius-level intellect is established in
the fact that she's developed a cure for
the mutant x-gene but has decided not to
use it now it's really just one of those
Brian Michael Bendis things where he's
just like here's how smart they are and
we're never gonna use it you're never
gonna do anything with it or we may
downline we have no idea but again it's
really just kind of establishing the the
intelligence of her character and what
she's capable of now from here it's
really kind of a discussion about what's
going on with regards to Victor Von Doom
himself as well as what's going on with
Tony Stark and Amir Pereira now of
course we know there's no real romance
between the two of them or at least
there doesn't seem to be but in this
part of the story or at least in this
segment we've basically moved past the
events of Civil War to you and what's
basically happened is this is the
aftermath of Tony Stark when he's
presumably died and so because of this
doom really addresses a really speech
with America about the feelings that she
may or may not have had about about
twenties talked about even if those
feelings were budding at the very least
is something that she can't act on right
now because of the fact that Tony Stark
is no longer part of the equation a so
what Doom is basically doing is he's
effectively turning over a new leaf he
really just kind of goes to speak with
her now this is a circumstance where his
his reputation precedes him in the sense
that when he introduces himself when he
basically says I'm Victor Von Doom the
first thing to come to mind is Doctor
Doom and so right off the bat her heirs
were initial responses this is a bad guy
like he's a villain now of course doom
isn't here for anything grandiose he's
not here for anything major he's not
even hitting on her or anything like
that it seemed as basically saying I
came here because I know who you are and
you remind me of someone and I just
wanted to meet you and so what is up
happening is the actress kind of
teleports himself away and the reason
seems to be that instead of him
continuing a conversation or instead of
him just being here strict
for that purpose who is more or less
forced to leave and the reason why I was
forced to leave is because of the fact
that almost immediately after he takes
off Ben Grimm arrives now with regards
to Ben Grimm and Marvel Comics that's
kind of again another one of these funny
situations Marvel has yet to
re-establish the Fantastic Four and we
don't know if they ever will just
because of the fact the Marvel got mad
the Fox wouldn't give them the rights
back to the Fantastic Four
so well took their ball and they ran
home so because of that we'll probably
never see the Fantastic Four restored
unless Marvel gets the rights back to
the Fantastic Four in film form but in
lieu of that we still have Ben Grimm we
still have Johnny Storm now of course
Johnny storms with the Inhumans and Ben
Grimm is basically an agent of shield
he's effectively their strong arm he's
the guy that goes out and carries out
missions that require a kind of finesse
that can't be found outside of somebody
who doesn't have super strength and a
really bad temperament if you understand
where I'm coming from he beats people up
that's basically what he does um but
it's still kind of cool you know but
from here again we don't really know
exactly why it's here or why he's here
all I really know is that he's here just
because of the fact that he's presumably
chasing Victor Von Doom now at this
point we jump over to Victor when he
actually begin as the process of making
himself
Iron Man off force again because of the
fact that Tony Stark's physical body was
killed more or less means really just
kind of in stasis
what Stark had done is he had downloaded
his mind into a computer program now
Marvel doing this served two purposes
the first was to allow us to continue to
see interactions with Tony Stark
but the second was to basically separate
the lock from the key and what's gonna
happen here later on down the line is
we're going to see Tony Stark's mind
restored back to his body and Tony Stark
will return it's just a really easy way
of ensuring that that is that
availability is there but also allowing
us to see something that goes on with
his particular character now the
discussion between the two is actually
really interesting because this half
admiration and half dear god I hope you
don't take my suit that's really what
cut it goes on here keep in mind despite
the fact that they've been been enemies
and the world of Marvel Comics when it
comes to people of a certain level of
intelligence there's a shared respect
among all of them just because of what
they're capable of so Doctor Doom is
hated by by De Charla because of the
fact that doom basically invaded Wakanda
during doom war but there's still some
measure of respect in terms of his
intelligence and the idea that you know
to Charlet would not underestimate the
intelligence of Doctor Doom
I mean he respect him as a person I mean
he despises him as a person but he
respects his intelligence and it's
usually like that when it comes across
these different characters in the realm
of Marvel Comics now with regards to to
Tony Stark's conversation here with
Victor keep in mind
Victor's appearance and his role in Tony
Stark's life uh you know really showed
us how much Victor had changed in the
first story arc of invincible Iron Man
when Victor had basically established
that he had abandoned his role as ruler
of Latveria and it actually helped Tony
Stark to capture Madame masque and so
because of this Victor basically says
hey look I mean at this point you're
just a hologram so there's not much you
can do to stop me but I'm turning over a
new leaf if you can't be Iron Man
someone needs to and so because of that
basically what ends up happening is doom
undertakes the mantle of Iron Man and
whisks himself away but the crazy thing
about this is that the entire situation
is being monitored by dr. Doom's mom
who's effectively you know who simply
has returned to life where there's also
some disembodied voice that's
communicating with her someone that we
can't see so again the idea of dr.
Doom's mom you know being alive here is
a huge revelation and the reason why is
uh she was basically the basis behind
dr. Doom's character I mean she was
really the origin behind everything from
the time that Doctor Doom was a little
boy and his mom was convicted of
witchcraft you know and then eventually
was killed he had always been on in an
effort to gain power in order to free
her soul and that's effectively what had
happened she had delved in witchcraft
she had sold her soul to Mephisto who
passes with a devil and in Marvel Comics
and the result was that following her
death
Mephisto was gonna hold her soul forever
well eventually we ended up finding out
that there was a bargain that was struck
between doom and Mephisto that doom
would be allowed to fight for the
freedom of his mother's soul once a year
and if he was successful his mother
would be freed now this was Mephisto
toying with doom and the reason why is
because of the fact that the demon lord
Mephisto is the most powerful in his own
realm essa was almost impossible for
Doom to win and so this led into the
triumph and torment storyline when dr.
doom and dr. strange came together and
then managed to fight off Mephisto and
free dr. Doom's free the soul of dr.
Doom's mom which in turn went on to
heaven now that was the end of her
character that was that I mean it was it
was done it was over from that point it
was just kind of fleshing out dooms
character without the the holdover of
his mom's soul being held by really by
the devil or by Mephisto and so because
of that what this does is it comes back
and it says
somewhere along the line presumably
because of the events of secret Wars his
mother's soul has been freed from heaven
and she's basically been returned to her
physical body and so what this does is
it changes everything because now dr.
Doom's mom is alive and the question
becomes what happens when they meet now
at this point we transitioned back over
to back over to Ben Grimm him being in
Latvia exists strictly for the purpose
of tracking down doom that's really all
it is I mean there's not a whole lot to
go on here it's really just him kind of
trashing the place and then basically
convincing the people in Latvia I guess
the the members of this of this ruling
class to basically tell him where dr.
doom is but they don't know they really
have no idea where it was that he went
to all they know is that he effectively
just abandoned them so again you know
it's just a demonstration of the fact
that there's a lot going on besides dr.
doom becoming Iron Man there's still
some pretty nefarious things now at this
point we actually pick up over at
Cambridge in England and again we join
dr. doom showing up to meet with America
rare but the funny thing about this is
that he calls out her name and then she
turns around and shoots him she shoots
at the shoulder he's like what you shot
me you shot me for all you Austin Powers
fans what was that guy's name was it
Mustapha I can't what is what his name
was it was Will Ferrell who played the
character it was a really really funny
moment from that from that movie but uh
the idea here though is that again this
is really just kind of dr. doom meeting
with her but it's also this idea that
her life is drastically being changed
because of the actions of dr. doom and
the reason why is because it's not
enough for him to just kind of show up
in her life and then start turning
things all topsy-turvy by saying hey
look I'm trying to be a good guy you
know I kind of good stuff but Ben Grimm
also has managed to track down Viktor
and so because of this the fight between
the two of them is pretty interesting
it's pretty short but it's pretty
interesting ah but the result of this is
that we end up finding out that dr. Deyo
had of course overcome Ben Grimm but it
happens off panel instead when is what
we end up doing is we actually jump
directly to to where it is that America
rare has been taken by dr. doom which is
basically his own little base of
operations his own little refuge outside
of Latveria and what is up happening
here is it basically says hey look you
know I'm here because I'm trying to be a
good guy well then a mayor's response is
but why though like what happened to you
that's changed your entire view of the
world and this is when dr. doom this is
when Brian Michael Bendis references
secret Wars and
that's one of the coolest things here is
because when all-new all-different
marvel first kicked off there was almost
no reference to Secret Wars it was
almost like Secret Wars never happened
we knew it did and there were maybe a
handful of people who remembered but
that was it it wasn't like everybody
remembered what was going on with Secret
Wars and everybody was talking about hey
man you know that time the doom that
absolute power it was like this dirty
little secret that was swept under the
rug which of course again I kind of
think was Marvel response to the idea
that they chose not to reboot but with
Brian Michael Bendis focusing here on on
on Secret Wars is basically doom just
recounting his story to Amir Pereira
telling her look there was a time when I
had absolute power there was a time when
I was God but it's also Brian Michael
Bendis injecting a little bit of his own
history with regards to to doom in the
sense that doom goes on to basically say
I've always tried to gain absolute power
even after free my mother's soul you
know I always continue to gain absolute
power and the reason why was because I
thought I was living up to my potential
I thought I was doing the right thing I
thought it was my lot in life my role in
life but he basically says time after
time I consistently failed whether it
was capturing the power of beyond her
the first time
whether it was capturing the power of
Galactus the first time whether it was
harnessing a cosmic cube you know
whether it was gaining just these insane
abilities you know whether it was
getting the power of the beyonders the
second time when I invaded Wakanda and I
forced Black Panther to render all
vibranium on earth completely inert
every single time I went on these
campaigns to gain absolute power I
always failed and so his idea was if I
failed in that direction
maybe I would succeed in the other
direction and so for him it's really
just kind of logic at this point in time
now there's also a lot of things that
Brian Michael Bendis doesn't say that
he's really inferring here in the sense
that when Doctor Doom essentially
remembers everything during Secret Wars
he also remembers his conflict with Reed
Richards he always remembers what he
said and it could simply just be the
fact that there was a lot of catharsis
that came out of Victor Von Doom
admitting to Reed Richards that he
always wanted to be him maybe it's just
that was one thing that he was always
holding on to and the reason why he
simply could not become a good guy again
Brian Michael Bendis one of the reasons
why I love the way he writes characters
is because he treats them like people
and so he doesn't tell us every single
thing they're thinking because when you
have a conversation with someone they
don't tell you every single thing
they're thinking it is kind of forced to
read between the lines if you choose to
do so and get a better understanding of
where they're coming from by how it is
they say things why they're saying
things and there
you know their own body language and so
because of them you know bidness
basically this kind of says look you
know you got to infer a little bit here
but in the end doom is trying to become
a good guy
doom is trying to do the right thing now
of course what is up happening here is
we end up having Ben Grimm actually
transition over to the old lab of dr.
doom and when he gets there we end up
actually finding out like the little
chunks of rock on his face and on his
body start falling off and this is where
we actually find out the reason this is
happening is because of the fact that
dr. doom is mom is residing inside of
his old laboratory and so again this is
really really cool it's one of these
really cool situations that begin to
unfold simply because of the fact that
we end up having dr. Doom's mom showing
that she's extremely powerful in terms
of her abilities now at this point we
switch back over to Maria hill and the
funny thing about this is that Maria
hill of course if she was smart would
have kept this information to herself
regarding the fact that she was somehow
captured by El Diablo but what she's
basically done is she's she's more or
less done that to a degree but she also
kind of has everybody out looking for
dr. doom or at the very least Ben Grimm
looking for dr. doom this is the reason
why Grimm's looking for him in the first
place is because Maria Hill tasked him
to do so now the reason why it was Ben
Grimm and not all of shield is because
it's really just Maria Hill trying to
make sure that her capture by El Diablo
and her being freed by Victor Von Doom
is kept under the radar if the world
became aware of the fact that the
director of shield the world's foremost
into the intelligence gathering
organization and peacekeeping force was
captured by a d-list villain people
would lose faith and shield in its
entirety they would say shield is the
most inept organization ever run by the
most ridiculous person ever we should
not allow them to have the kind of power
that they have it would just bring
shield crashing down to the ground used
to go to the fact that everybody in
there would look like buffoons and so
because of this dr. doom basically just
arise on the Helicarrier which is really
kind of funny here because this is one
of those these are these little goodies
right these little these little tidbits
he's these fun little things that we get
with his character the way he's written
by Bendis when he shows up here Maria
Hills like what are you doing here and
he says well let me think about it this
way if I had
done something if I had shown up on the
radar somewhere then you probably would
have sent everybody in shield to come
after me maybe you would have sent you
know other individuals Ben Grimm or
somebody like that to come after me but
I appear here which saves you all kinds
of money it saves you dozens of
man-hours it saves you all kinds of time
and it keeps you from losing face you
know and so basically it's dr. dim it's
kind of like I did you a favor but the
question becomes me why are you having
Ben Grimm coming after me why are you
having him chase me I literally saved
your life and so there's a little
back-and-forth that goes on here you
know with regards to their their
discussion you know and their their
conversations but the idea here is that
that dr. dim basically says look I saved
your life you owe me for that all right
take Ben Grimm off my tail
and stop having shield monitor dr.
pereira now the question that also comes
after this is where is Ben Grimm at the
moment you know where is where is he at
at this particular point in time and the
reason why this question is brought up
is because dr. doom makes the statement
that he basically defeated Ben Grimm
well because of the fact that Ben Grimm
hasn't returned
Maria Hills question is where is he at
which point you know we end up having
one of her ages basically say he's in
Latvia well at this point doom whisks
off and the reason why is because of the
fact that he knows no good can come out
of Ben Grimm being in Latvia the other
half of this is that Ben Grimm may start
stumbling around and asking questions
that he has no business asking about the
history of Victor Von Doom outside of
the various you know escapades of the
Fantastic Four have been involved in
with Doctor Doom over the course of his
history as their main villain and so
because of this this is when Brian
Michael Bendis basically shows us the
current state of Latveria and the reason
why this matters is because of the fact
that in the first story arc of
invincible Iron Man we saw what Lavery
was about to a degree but only insofar
the place was in ruins following Doctor
Doom abandoning it but we haven't really
through you know we hadn't really
learned how far it had fallen and what
we end up finding out is again it's
basically you know Brian Michael Bendis
refreshing us on the fact death a
general who is left in charge by Victor
to basically restore Liberia or keep
Liberia in check has essentially become
corrupt and he's more or less turned it
into a totalitarian state giving himself
absolute power now of course Victor
basically takes all this out I mean you
know he basically goes you know to to
karateka I think his name is the general
at the time and says look you're not
going to be the one that runs this place
with absolute power I clearly cannot
trust you to do that
I clearly cannot trust you to be the one
who controls things with
absolute certainty and so what he does
is he says go find a woman by the name
of Angela cor now Angela cor is an
example of where Bendis just kind of
injects his own little bit into
individual stories because Angela cor is
basically a new character she never
existed before we've never really seen
or heard of her before she's been
created by Brian Michael Bendis for the
sake of this story in order to basically
allow doom to operate outside of Liberia
and presumably return to his normal role
without having to worry about rebuilding
Liberia eventually we'll go back to its
normal self but what is up happening
here is Doctor Doom basically stumbles
into Ben Grimm only for us to discover
that the little bits and pieces of Ben
Grimm have fallen off all over the place
all at the hands of dr. Doom's mom now
this encounter between the two of them
is crazy and it's one of the coolest
things ever because Victor's response to
this is the most predictable response
and again this is why I love the way
that Brian Michael Bendis writes
characters Victor Von dooms response is
who are you and why are you acting as my
mom well of course
Cynthia begins to effectively say hey
look you know I am your mom like I am
your mom in every sense of the word but
Victor does not want to believe it and
the reason why is because if he did
everything that he's worked for up to
now would feel as though it's
essentially been lost because over a
majority of his life was defined by his
mom's soul having been captured and is
one of these situations where it's like
if everything that happened to me led to
where I am right now then would I go
back and change it and do what say no I
mean we've had that conversation with
Adam and where he basically says
everything I've done over the course of
my life and the motivations behind those
actions have led me to this moment right
now if any of those variables were to
change well then suddenly everything
could change it could be that I would
wake up tomorrow and suddenly I have the
Infinity Gauntlet in my hand and I have
absolute power over the universe so dr.
doom essentially says look you know if
his mother is alive then the question is
how did she come back and if she is
really back then what role is she going
to play but it's also the idea that at
the same time this is all the reasons
why I love this so much at the same time
this is Victor Von dooms mom you know
for those of us who have lost a family
member that's very very close to us what
would we give to have that family member
back I don't know about you guys with
are those individuals in my life that
I've lost then I would literally
sacrifice everything I'd walk away from
YouTube forever and I'd give up
everything I owned if it meant that I
could spend like another day talking to
them and I would talk to them for the
whole day I would literally walk away
from everything
admit that I could do that so that's one
of the cool things is that's one of the
other reasons why I love Bendis the way
he handles characters is because it's
Doctor Doom at his most basic it's the
idea that Victor despite all the bravado
despite all the pomp and circumstance
and all the power and all that kind of
crazy cool stuff at the end of the day
it's him it's a son who is really kind
of forced to believe that his mother may
very well still be alive but when is up
happening here is his mother actually
says look I'm proud of who you are right
now like I'm proud of what you've become
I'm proud of what you've done at this
point in tunt but the other half of this
is she's still very much a dark
character she's not evil evil or at
least hasn't seemed to be that way
instead her initial response is this guy
this Ben Grimm thing needs to go away
we need to eliminate him we need to get
rid of him dooms responses no he lives
send him away just turn him back to
shield wherever it is that he needs to
go to but what isn't happening here and
what's basically taking place she
basically just leaves when Doctor Doom
is again refusing to believe that she's
alive
when doctor dooms refusing to believe
that it's his mom she says look fine
we'll get back together we'll get our
heads cleared we'll get things sorted
out when you're more inclined to be
receptive and so what is up happening
here is we switch back to Cynthia Vaughn
Dean we switch back to her base of
operations where she's you know engaging
in all her magic sorcery different
things like that and what we find out is
that the disembodied voice that she's
been talking to you belongs to Reed
Richards from the Ultimate Universe so
this is crazy because what it means is
that Reed Richards from the Ultimate
Universe is still alive Reed Richards
from the Ultimate Universe is presumably
going to be the main enemy of Victor Von
Doom but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
guys are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and leave a comment down
below and let me know what you think
because I'm gonna tell you right now I
love like Victor Von Doom is Iron Man oh
god it's so good it's so cool I mean
it's gonna be short-lived it's not gonna
be something that'll last forever and I
think that's the most disappointing
thing is because it'd be cool to see him
dawn the Iron Man armor like every once
in a while when he goes into a conflict
I mean I still want to see like the
return of the old Victor Von Doom but
for the story you know for what we have
at the moment for the direction
it's going yeah it's a beautifully
written story and I really think it
probably one of the best that Brian
Michael Bendis is done for a little
while but okay so we are finally back in
the infamous Ironman I've seen a lot of
you guys asking for it
one thing you guys got to keep in mind
is that when it comes to Marvel and DC
rebirth has spoiled me so bad when it
comes to this one of the things when it
comes to Marvel is they publish a story
once a month so when the story finishes
if it takes six issues we have to wait
six months I can't make them put them
faster as much as I wish I could which
is one of the downsides to Marvel legacy
is it'll probably six months before a
lot of the stories are finished although
they may be cranking out for issue story
arcs in which case it's only four months
but the fact remains we've had to wait a
while until this story got finished but
infamous Iron Man is still one of the
absolute best
Iron Man stories ever I love do my man
and I love Ruby Williams Iron Man right
there they were great you're I guess
iron Harbor there are other great
characters but doom Iron Man just brings
this pizzazz like a villain turns
superhero in such a cool way so for
those of you guys who are playing
catch-up with regards to this few guys
never saw the first one it'll be down in
the description in the Iron Man playlist
but the idea of infamous Iron Man all
really came out of two things it came
out of all-new all-different marvel and
it came out of the believed death of
Tony Stark after Civil War - so of
course Secret Wars 2015 basically dealt
with the idea of Victor Von Doom
becoming God he had just an insane
amount of power I mean he controlled
battleworld and he had the power of the
beyonders and he could do anything you
wanted to and it was like the
culmination of everything from his
introduction and Marvel Comics all the
way up to Secret Wars in the way that
Pikmin did it was absolutely amazing but
the fact remains here with regards to
the events after Secret Wars 2015 going
into all-new all-different marvel it was
somewhat of a redemption story doom had
basically been reborn more or less by
Reed Richards with his face completely
restored that was a hallmark of his
character is that his face was scarred
just because of his experiments and so
on and so forth but the idea is that
during Civil War - when Tony Stark hit
battled Carol Danvers and was believed
to have been dead dr. doom picked up the
mantle of Iron Man alongside riri
Williams so we're really Williams
followed the character as Iron Heart
Doctor Doom basically became the new
Iron Man
form of infamous Ironman and the way
that he did this was really more along
the lines of just using a combination of
Iron Man's technology along with his own
magic and it was super cool because one
of the first things that we ended up
seeing was him basically going through
and trying to convince everybody he was
a good guy but in the background there
was this subplot with the return of dr.
Doom's mom now cynthia Von Doom was this
character who was largely intertwined
into the origin of Doctor Doom and this
story will actually build off of an
existing story called triumph and
torment which is amazing it's a dr. doom
Doctor Strange crossover and it's super
cool but the whole idea is that the
origin of Cynthia was that she was
basically a character who had dabbled in
witchcraft and the result was that she
was basically ousted by the villagers
they really just kind of condemned her
and different things like that and that
was the end of her of her passing was a
huge part of a Victor Von Doom but the
idea is that going forward into his
futures publication history we ended up
finding out that his mother's soul had
been bonded by Mephisto who was
basically the representation of Satan in
the realm of Marvel Comics and the idea
was that dr. doom had gone again and
again and again in an effort to
basically rescue her soul with no
perceived way to be able to pull it off
basically Mephisto being as powerful as
he is in his home dimension was
seemingly unstoppable doom couldn't
actually win so it seemed like his
mother soul was going to be bound for
all eternity to the realm of Mephisto
now this led in a triumphant torment
which dealt with dr. doom and Doctor
Strange teaming up and then going to the
realm of Mephisto defeating him and then
freeing the soul of victor von dooms mom
and so that's how things kind of resided
going all the way up until Secret Wars
2015 the problem with this was that when
all-new all-different marvel launched
and cynthia von doom showed up we didn't
really know what was going on because
she's not part of the clutches of a
Fisto anymore she's out doing her own
thing and so it seemed like just kind of
reintroducing her character in a way to
tell new stories the other half of this
was that she was allied with Reed
Richards and that was a crazy thing it
was the Ultimate Universe Reed Richards
but Reed Richards nonetheless and that's
where the plot started to thicken
because it was the idea what do these
two characters have in common and if
they're working together do they have an
ulterior motive to get revenge on doom
as Iron Man so the idea is that this
basically results in really Williams and
Victor Von Doom meeting each other for
the very first time and it's a really
cool exchange because
his whole storytelling everything that
goes on with her character is a fact
that she doesn't really know what she's
doing she's experimenting she's trying
to figure herself out as a hero she has
the AI of Tony Stark to guide her as
best he can but when it comes to being a
superhero it's riding a bike sometimes
you just got to jump on start peddling
and hope you don't fall
Deerling countering Iron Heart is a cool
scenario because in truth
she's woefully over her head because
you're talking about trying to battle
one of the most powerful sorcerers in
all of Marvel Comics and when I say the
most powerful sorcerers I'm talking
about a guy who was able to steal the
power of Galactus so doom is not just
some guy who's really strong on earth
he's powerful across the board the other
half of this is that it's more of a
conversation than an actual battle
between the two of them partially
because iron hearts listening to what it
is a Tony Stark's saying but the other
half is because she's just curious she's
curious about Doctor Doom because of the
two of them being as powerful as they
are really him being as powerful as he
is and then suddenly becoming a good guy
it begs the question what could he
achieve and that's the cool thing about
infamous Iron Man with Doctor Doom being
one of the most powerful beings in
existence if he becomes a good guy
imagine what he could accomplish imagine
what he could pull off and so ultimately
this conversation between him and iron
heart leads to the idea of doom
basically saying that he had a spirit
Ernie of sorts he had this sort of
vision where he communed with someone
from the future didn't know who they
were and they were in possession of
incredible technology and the idea is to
regain that vision now bindus isn't just
pulling this out of nowhere it's
basically been distilled anan all this
stuff when it comes to dr. doom
despite his arrogance and his hubris and
all those aspects of his character that
he displayed before he was nothing if
not methodical and whatever was it he
came across something he didn't fully
understand it was research research
research research learned everything
there is to know and then make a move
and that's what he does here he's
basically just kind of received the
spirit vision somewhere along the line
and the goal is to duplicate the process
which was basically heightened
adrenaline that led to this vision and
then in turn decipher it find out what
it is and then see if there's a way that
he can use it the cool thing about this
is that in order to pull it off he
basically just has iron heart attacking
he's just like attacking with all the
energy you have but the funny thing is
that when this happens and he's
presumably kind of knocked unconscious
he basically ends up finding out that
the person he's communing with
is Tony Stark and this is crazy because
it looks like Tony Stark
with the powers of dr. strange and so
it's kind of weird because we have no
indication of where this is going is
basically just the idea that Tony Stark
is communing directly with dr. strange
from some point in the future in a city
of New York that just seems to be wildly
technologically advanced now again this
is one of the reasons why I love Bendis
when he ties into continuity he doesn't
always do that but sometimes he does
during Jonathon Hickman's run on
Avengers and New Avengers it was the
first story arc when Captain America
basically destroyed the Infinity
Gauntlet he tried to use it to stop the
incursions Earth's crashing into each
other the Infinity Gauntlet couldn't
handle it all the gym shattered except
for the time stone which disappeared
into the time stream the idea was that
when that happened nobody knew where the
time stone went
eventually it popped back up again a
grad Captain America and a handful of
others and sort of jumping them into the
future there was a point where Captain
America ended up something like 50,000
years in the future and the world was
just a giant sentient mind and so it's
cool to see how those things play out in
the sense that maybe this is part a part
of that time stream and so this kind of
thing is something that linda's will
probably build on for the moment it's
basically just you know Tony Stark
saying you cannot be Iron Man anymore
you have to stop but we don't know why
the implication is that he's drawing the
wrong kind of attention from some
external force out there but we don't
know for sure the other half of this is
what goes on with this version of Reed
Richards this ultimate read he really
just seemingly popped out of nowhere and
it was the idea that he initially
appeared to Ben Grimm and that's kind of
a big deal because remember ever since
Secret Wars ended in all-new
all-different marvel started valaria
Richards the Franklin Richards Susan
storm and Reed himself we're basically
just out there in the middle of nowhere
creating universes using the molecule
man's powers and then just throwing them
out there and that's all they've done
now we know because of Marvel legacy we
know they're still out there doing their
own thing what it did is it left Ben
Grimm and Johnny Storm back on earth to
pick up the pieces and so they still are
reeling from the after-effects of being
part of the Fantastic Four for so long
only to have no idea where Reed and
Susan are at at the moment what they're
doing and why they haven't made their
presence known now of course this is
Marvel basically handling the pipe
perlmutter push to keep the Fantastic
Four out of comics so long as Fox has
the rights to them in film form but it
does
for some cool storytelling because it's
basically the idea that Ben Grimm
encountering this ultimate version of
read does not believe that he's read and
it actually results in a fight between
the two of them but it also deals with
the idea that Ben Grimm is still getting
over the fact that read isn't there that
Johnny Storm is still getting over the
fact that read isn't there they're
dealing with it as best they can when
Ben Grimm goes to Johnny and says hey
some version of read showed up to me I
don't think it's our read Johnny Storm
can't handle it he's like look it's too
soon it's too close and he just leaves
it's the Johnny Storm bravado it's the
wall you know I've gotta put on the big
front and I've got to look like a tough
guy instead of allowing his motions to
kind of be exposed to Ben Grimm that's a
hallmark of the other characters in the
sense that when it comes down to it they
fight together but in moments of peace
when there's no real conflict they're
very guarded in terms of how they relate
to each other with Doctor Doom and
having passed out after his Vision Quest
and then being dropped off at a shield
Helicarrier by riri Williams because
presumably it's the only thing she knew
to do what isn't happening is one of the
shield agents shows up and then actually
kills a couple of agents and then goes
to at least seems to try to kill dr.
doom now of course we end up finding out
that this was basically mind-control
done by doctor dooms mom which is really
kind of cool because then the question
becomes what's her motivation here
what's her basis behind this now with
her bringing dr. doom back to her home
what it does is it introduces a little
bit of a retcon here and the origin
story of Doctor Doom we had the idea
that his mom was practicing witchcraft
wouldn't really know much about it what
this does is it injects the idea that
his mom tried to get him to practice
witchcraft he was terrified of it and
ran off and his mom considered him a
coward for it but it's a little tiny
retconned but it's cool because it
revives this really interesting context
into how it is that Doom views his mom
then maybe his mom despite the fact that
she was practicing witchcraft was not
the great mom that we believed she was
when it came to dr. doom that she was
basically witchcraft above all and if my
son won't do it then my son is a coward
and basically just kind of cut him loose
and so again it's interesting because in
this moment is the question explain to
me what's going on how are you here I
thought your spirit went to heaven how
are you back here how can you exist in
this realm and a lot of these questions
aren't readily answered instead it's
just kind of like well I'll meditate on
it you know we'll get together and what
is kind of meditating and we'll maybe
have this discussion somewhere along the
line but
that's it there's no real answers given
to him by Cynthia Von Doom the only
thing that she really hits at is that
you are safe here this is a safe place
she keeps hitting at the idea that she
has greater plans for her son now this
also begins to show itself in the sense
that she's teaching him more about
witchcraft and that's the important
thing when it comes to dr. doom he's
wildly powerful but he doesn't know
everything about everything there's
always something new to learn that's the
basis of his character ultimately in the
middle of all this we end up having Reed
Richards show up out of nowhere and
basically say we had a plan he's not
supposed to be here and so that's why
this is cool is because the plot
thickens it gets more complicated
because when Ben Grimm shows up in
Latveria and doom is just sort of sent
flying out of this dimensional plane it
says dude you have to run you have to go
we end up finding out that Ben Grimm had
transported him to a shield Helicarrier
and that's when Doctor Strange starts to
come into the mix one thing to keep in
mind when it comes to the Marvel
hierarchy among the various characters
there are a lot of people that can use
magic dr. strange is the sorcerer
supreme now while there are other
characters who may be more powerful than
him in one form or another and at one
point or another for the most part he is
the authority on magic usually Doctor
Strange is considered to be the most
powerful of all the magic wielders but
momentarily somebody will pop up with
more power than him but because dr.
strange is the sorcerer supreme and
because both strange and doom had fought
together in freeing the soul of cynthia
von doom from the clutches of Mephisto
they have this kind of bond between the
two of them but dr. doom despite the
fact that he could leave this shield
Helicarrier chooses not to and the
reason why he chooses not to is because
he's scared
notice this moment when dr. strange says
if you're here it's because you're
afraid and if you're afraid then I am
terrified and that's why it's so cool is
because doom is seen in done at all if
there's something out there he's
terrified off it's something either it's
strange is not encountered before or if
he has encountered it it's of a level so
extreme that it terrifies one of the
most powerful sorcerers in the world and
so as they begin going through and as
they begin talking about what this
threat may be with Ben Grimm just sort
of watching all these events unfold
suddenly Reed Richards shows up and
immediately starts challenging all these
different members of shield and as these
conversations go back and forth these
two things are juxtaposed right next to
each other read read
it's just like you know making his way
in there saying hey look I'm not here to
attack I'm here to just talk to Victor
Von Doom tell me where he is and then it
gets to the point where Von Doom says I
do not think that's Reed Richards I
think it's someone else
and then suddenly everything changes and
that's what we end up finding out this
is not Reed Richards
it was never Reed Richards this person
is Mephisto and that is who Brian
Michael Bendis kudos
when Mephisto reveals himself but Doctor
Strange starts putting the two together
and basically begins to realize it's
Mephisto and so the question is has he
rebound
Cynthia von dooms soul well then we end
up finding out that's not the case at
all instead Mephisto does not readily
engage them in battle he does to a
degree but it takes the combined efforts
of Doctor Strange and Victor Von Doom to
kind of run him off what we end up
finding out here is that Cynthia Von
Doom was never there that Reed Richards
was never there all of this has been a
ruse by Mephisto revenge for freeing the
soul of Cynthia Von Doom now let that
sink in for a second we're talking about
two of the most powerful sorcerers in
existence Doctor Strange and dr. dear
both of them
duped by Mephisto that's how he works
Mephisto doesn't usually pop up and then
just start saying absolute power and
immediately start attacking everybody he
works behind the scenes to dupe people
he appears an immortal guys presumably
aiding you and the idea is to trick you
into asking for his help and when you
give it to him he'll take your soul when
you die that's how it works with him
it's one of the coolest things when it
comes to Marvel College because he's a
cosmic entity who's insanely powerful
but doesn't readily delve in action in
battle and so the idea is that because
people still don't necessarily trust dr.
doom and because Mephisto says this was
all just a ruse for me to trick you
that's all it is I'm just giving you a
hard time and I will be back for more
then it puts infamous Iron Man on edge
because it's been dismissing the Fisto
will probably be a big part of the
stories later on down the line we'll see
more of him here than we probably have
anywhere else but it's also infamous
iron man trying to basically instill the
fact and shield and almost everybody
that he is there to be a good guy and so
at the end of the day they say fine then
we'll just let you do that we'll let you
be a good guy we really don't have any
reason to stop you because you haven't
done anything with in recent memory that
we can do anything about because
remember not everybody remembers the
events of seeker wars and so because of
that
it's basically him just kind of going
forward and him just being a good guy
continuing to be a hero it's this great
story dealing with how he became Iron
Man some of the most important moments
of his life
come to bear and Mephisto getting this a
little bit of revenge and then
presumably coming back later on down the
line okay so we are picking up with the
hunt for I guess really the search for
Tony Stark this is a big story this is
something like like eight issues long or
something like that and Bendis doesn't
usually do stories that long those you
guys who don't know more often than not
in Marvel Comics most story arcs are
about six issues long for Iron Man this
comes after the events of secret Empire
now of course you could Empire as most
people know is one of my favorite
stories ever when it comes to the
character of Captain America well really
it actually goes far back in civil war
to when Tony Stark was basically killed
by Carol Danvers essentially Tony Stark
you just kind of been in a catatonic
state he was just in a coma and that was
it and it was a way for like Marvel and
bindus to basically put him on the back
burner and then on an you know bring in
riri Williams as a character who I
absolutely loved but the fact remains
here when it comes to Tony Stark being
in a catatonic state there were a couple
things that happen the first was that
you really saw like Amanda Armstrong
picking up really Amanda Armstrong and
Mary Jean Watson picking up at his place
and we'll talk by them here in a second
and then you picked up with Tony Stark
basically turning himself into an
artificial intelligence and then
basically becoming the trainer for Ruby
Williams when she became the new the new
Iron Man more or less but she was Iron
Heart and so what this does is this
initially picks up essentially at the
stark Expo this whole you know event
that Tony Stark puts on you know year
after year in order to bring together
some of the greatest minds now Amanda
Armstrong is really the one leading the
charge on this whole project since Tony
Stark is gone now Amanda Armstrong was
introduced as part of International Iron
Man and that dealt with the idea of Tony
Stark tracking down his actual
biological parents because that was a
holdover from Karen Gillan who had
introduced the secret origin of Tony
Stark and revealed that Howard and Maria
were not actually his biological parents
and instead he was adopted and so Ben is
to kind of continue that trend going
forward in the future of the Iron Man
stories and so an International Iron Man
you track down his actual mother who was
basically a rock star from like the 80s
uh and then we still don't know who his
biological father is or at least we know
now that the story's finished but at
this point in the story we don't know
and so basically a man is kind of going
through and saying hey look guys like
we're put on this whole stark Expo
because it's what xx Stark would want
for her perspective this is a really
crushing experience and the reason why
is because by and large she never really
got to know her son
when it came to Tony Stark introducing
himself and meeting Amanda for the first
time it was hey come back over here to
Stark Industries basically become the
new CEO which is something that he had
implemented after he had essentially
died you know it was part of his was
last will and testament but she never
really got to know her son now her and
Mary Jane Watson have really been
running the show ever since of course
Mary Jane Watson involvement came by way
of a combination of Dan Slott spider-man
and Brian Michael Bendis as Iron Man but
the idea here is that between the two of
them they're basically fending off the
Board of Trustees if the board is trying
to take over control of Stark Industries
since Tony Stark isn't there he was
really like the one person keeping them
at bay and so because of the fact that
Tony Stark might as well be dead for all
intents and purposes she ends up
bringing in riri Williams now at this
point we transition to a guy named Eric
Lynch now Eric Lynch is one of the
higher ranking members of the board but
he's one of these guys has really been
kind of like pushing the way for the
Board of Trustees to be able to take
everything over and it's really just
kind of like lying in wait and saying
hey look there's only a matter of time
only a matter of time before you guys
screw up what's been going on really off
panel and behind the scenes here is that
Eric Lynch and the board have been
exhausting every conceivable legal
option they have and essentially what
has come down to is that because Tony
Stark has been gone for so long and
because the the company really is
supposed to be owned by Tony Stark and
the person who owns it isn't there that
gives all authority to the Board of
Trustees this is essentially a hostile
takeover now at this point we transition
away from like riri and all that kind of
stuff and we focus on Doctor Doom this
is where things get a little crazy it's
because what you had is you had
invincible Iron Man and then you had
like the new Iron Man with dr. doom and
with infamous Iron Man this this story
arc they took place of Doctor Doom
because there were two distinctly
separate books when it got to the end of
International Iron Man and it got to the
conclusion basically going into like the
end of secret war I'm sorry the end of
secret empire with businesses a
invincible Iron Man he combined the two
together and that's why you see two
distinctly different art styles because
as far as most everybody's been able to
guess they were supposed to be two
distinctly different books but with
Bendis basically getting out of marvel
handing the reins over to whoever it is
it comes next the results that they were
just kind of crammed into a singular
book but the idea here is this is really
more of like businesses take almost on
the events of New Avengers it's kind of
him a way for him
to bring that back now so if you guys
don't know what that means uh back in
the day with Avengers being one of those
titles that was ailing because a lot of
people think Avengers has always been
successful it's actually not true
throughout the 90s the only real
successful titles Marvel had were
spider-man and the various x-men related
titles when the Avengers title was
canceled with Avengers disassembled and
then relaunched as new Avengers the
first story arc was called the raft and
it dealt with the idea that the villain
electro had been contracted by Elektra
to essentially break all the prisoners
out of the raft and it was a way to kind
of bring the New Avengers team together
but this is very much a repeat of that
and the reason why is because it Rikers
Island a whole bunch of people have
escaped now this is really just kind of
repeat of that in the sense that you
have infamous Iron Man Doctor Doom who
basically responds and there's a handful
of people who have escaped now we'll
figure out who these guys are but of
course this also sort of ties into the
idea that Ben Grimm doesn't really trust
infamous Iron Man now one thing to bear
in mind here for those of you guys who
have been watching for a little while
this took place before the events of
Marvel two-in-one so that's one of the
reasons why you don't really see Ben
Grimm and Doctor Doom on good terms and
they even during true and one they
weren't really on good terms but this
takes place before that but switching
back over to back over to Amanda and
everybody what you end up finding out
here is basically the body of Tony Stark
has vanished the reason why this is so
significant is because of the fact that
with Tony Stark having been part of the
superhero community for a long time
having been director of shield being
really one of the founding members of
the Avengers having faced off and and
sided with the x-men he knows a lot I
mean he his hands are in everything and
so if somebody were to get their hands
on him and then simply like start
forcing him to divulge information they
could bring the entire security
infrastructure of the world crashing
down to say nothing of how easily they'd
be able to take out the various Avengers
now from here what you what we end up
doing is basically picking up with the
arrival of a guy by the name of hijack
now when it comes to David Bond the
reason why they call him hijack is
because of the fact that he literally
hijacks vehicles like you know
technological stuff now he originally
made his appearance back in 2013 I'm
pretty sure with uncanny x-men vol 3
issue number 6 I'm not gonna swear by
that but I'm pretty sure I'm right but
he was a Brian Michael Bendis creation
now anybody who's familiar with Bendis
will tell you more often than not he'll
use his own creations or he'll use
things that he's previously done to kind
of push along stories of these cadet
he's writing at the time but hijacks
showing up is really just like he's he's
basically a merc but he's here because
he was hired by the start board of
directors to essentially bring down like
RiRi
like kind of good stuff now this is one
of the funny things because the suit
that RiRi has was not Devon and not
designed by Tony Stark himself it was
designed by her but Tony Stark has been
influencing her and teaching her how to
use these different things but when it
comes to this whole thing in this
situation popping off for the most part
has hurt is sort of taking guidance from
Tony Stark kind of out flying these
various forces and so on and so forth
and then eventually getting outside the
range of hijack to the point that he
can't really control these these ships
anymore and then ultimately she ends up
just kind of crash landing and you know
or she makes her escape anyway and then
ends up crash landing in around
neighborhood things like that of course
this also comes by way of Mary Jane
Watson
macing David bond of macing hijack in
order to take his concentration away but
it's kind of a cool little thing here
that's one of the cool things about
Bendis riding is that a lot of times
he'll focus on smaller characters who
normally wouldn't really have anything
to contribute but then gives them
something as small as it is and it just
makes all the difference and again it's
just kind of a way to develop characters
but the fact remains here when it comes
to uh really to Doctor Doom Ironman just
kind of an aside not a great big huge
thing this will become important later
on but basically the guys who bro who or
who are broken out of Riker's Island or
essentially like targeting really more
does kind of like harassing and
bothering him trying to find a way to
like defeat him and kill him now these
are small-time guys living laser
different things like that nobody who is
ever really significant and so what we
end up doing is picking up of course
when Williams crashes back in her local
neighborhood and she's talking to Xavier
and that's one of the cool things I like
about Ruby's character for the most part
I've always loved her like I always
thought the development behind her was
awesome but she's also like this young
girl and when you're looking at someone
like her who is trying to step into the
role of becoming the new Iron Man it is
kind of funny because you have a
tendency to sort of forget she's a
teenage girl which means she goes
through teenage girl phases there's all
those small little things you know being
nervous around boys they know boys she
likes different things like that and
it's kind of a cool moment but once she
gets inside we basically end up finding
out that like her home is being rummaged
through by like essentially you know
groups editor I guess you know handful
of people who were sent here by stark
stark you know Stark Enterprises by the
Board of Directors and they're really
pulling out all the stops now the way
that reira plays this is actually pretty
smart she basically says the entire
place is not really booby-trapped but
being monitored by like 17 separate
cameras and that is she you know if they
end up you know if they end up basically
saying hey look we're gonna continue
with this and like the whole thing will
be turned into a video and then it'll be
sent out there which is kind of a kind
of a significant moment and so what we
end up doing is actually transitioning
to Tony's
proper now this is where things get a
little hairy Tony Stark just kind of
fell out of this birthing container
that's really what it was you just kind
of fell out of a container of sorts and
we have no idea where he is we have no
idea how he got there instead he's met
by the arrival of his mother now this
really looks like a newborn Tony stork
that's really how this appears in terms
of the way he's drawn design all that
kind of good stuff
but the idea seems to be he's still in
possession of all of his memories up to
the modern day now is it a cheap way to
bring Iron Man back definitely but how
do you really bring Tony Stark back
after he's quote-unquote dead
you know after he's essentially dead but
it's kind of interesting because as he
goes through and starts talking to
really his mother they have this really
really touching tender moment here and
it's him basically saying like the one
thing that allowed me to hold on is that
it was basically you like what I've done
is I've essentially rebooted myself mind
body and soul I'm a recreated version of
myself when he's talking to her he's
kind of having this moment it's like hey
look I always wanted us to meet I always
wanted us to see each other and then you
have Mary Jane Watson who walks in you
know and Mayor Jean Watson is like well
you know they're on their way
everybody's showing up here everyone's
been looking for you and then he's met
with a full contingent of the Avengers I
mean everyone you know like riri
Williams and and Moon Knight and like
storm and vision and all I kind of stuff
you know the x-men are there I mean it's
like the entire Marvel superhero
community because of the fact that he's
such a significant and important member
only for us to find out that James
Rhodes is also there and this is when we
start to realize the whole thing is an
illusion it's basically a dream that
he's having and the reason why is
because James Rose is dead James Rose
died you know and really in the lead-up
to Civil War too and so it's kind of a
cool moment here it's actually kind of
kind of interesting because when you're
talking about this return of Tony Stark
it would have been a pretty easy
situation to just say and now he's not
done you know and it's like a to issue
story but it's he'd been just kind of
drag it out and sort of you know invoke
all this character involvement is
interesting because then what we do is
we basically pick up with the arrival of
Parker Robbins now Parker Robbins was a
character created by Brian Kavon he
originally appeared in his own solo
series called the hood and he's one of
these interesting guys he's not really
on the level of dr. strange but he's not
a baseline human he can kind of
manipulate magic to a degree and he
basically fights demon energy or shoots
demon energies from his guns the
difference here with the hood is that
he's actually achieved a lot of pretty
significant things in terms of his
supervillain career I mean he was
inspired to become a supervillain that's
one of the reasons why he does what he
does but he's essentially really good at
forming what is for the most part like
masters of evil those you guys who don't
know back in the day the Masters of evil
if I remember correctly I want to say it
was a Roy Thomas creation but anyway it
was basically an alliance of the most
notable villains at the time that were
basically villains of the Avengers the
roster sort of changed over the years
when it came to when it came to the
Masters of evil but with Parker Robbins
forming his own kind of army the roster
also changed as well but that's why you
see small-time guys like living laser
because the Masters of evil were people
like like radiation man Ulysses Klaw
small-time villains that even at that
point in time weren't super relevant
they weren't really all you know that
big of a deal but basically Parker
Robbins shows up and like turns his guns
on dr. Jim and so it's really kind of
these things were worried you know
business leaders know like a minor
cliffhanger like a small little
cliffhanger and so what is up happening
here is Amanda starts to put two and two
together right their wife I'm sorry the
mother of Tony Stark starts to put two
and two together and she's talking to
like all the Avengers like the Mighty
Avengers and then the whole nine yards I
mean it's like it's black panther it is
Luke Cage it's spider-man I mean it's
all these different characters and the
response is we have no idea where Tony
Stark is no one can find him this guy's
off the radar now this is kind of a cool
thing and it's actually it's actually an
important thing to important thing to
remember and the reason why is because
when it comes to someone like Tony Stark
where he was director of shield while he
wasn't necessarily on the same level as
like Nick Fury he still has a much
higher level of intelligence but also
access to everything that was going on
with regards to to shield he did learn
about all these little nooks and
crannies and secret locations and places
like that here and there and that's the
reason why wherever Tony Stark is he's
totally off the reservation nobody can
find him because no one knows the
different places that he knows it's just
things that he was privy to as director
of shield or figured out along the way
and this is what a man that kind of
starts putting two and two together
she's like if Friday is the AI of Tony
Stark that he created before he died
then she's a program she does what she's
programmed to do and she's programmed to
protect Tony Stark and the response of
Amanda Armstrong is if she's programmed
to protect Tony Stark then why then she
has to know the location of Tony Stark
and then me of course you know Friday's
response to this whole interrogation is
I really don't know where you know I
don't know where he is you know the only
way for me to know what be you know to
basically be in his head and that's when
she jumps into the basically to the AI
constructor of Tony himself that's been
helping out Reba Williams this entire
time and it's the coolest thing because
when she jumps in she basically kind of
switches bodies you know kind of
switches them back and there's the
really the question this asked here is
where is Tony Stark and the AI
contractors Tony Sidley responds by
saying well to be fair no one ever asked
me directly where he was indicating this
version of Tony knows exactly where
actual real-world Tony Stark is like and
it's kind of funny because it's like
well all they ever had to do is ask ok
so we are continuing on with invincible
Iron Man and it's actually kind of cool
I mean I'm pretty excited about this
because this is basically the return of
Tony Stark but it's one of these things
where you can tell that Bendis had
somewhat set the stage for what was
supposed to come after this now whether
or not it was the plan of bindus to do
this and they continue writing and then
ultimately jump ship and head over to DC
Comics for the ships not sinking then
you know we don't we don't really know
like we don't know if that's if that's
the case or not
um at this point is just kind of like
then to set it up for things to come
after this so in reality it's really
kind of like anybody's guess on what
direction things going but initially
this picks up really with Parker Robbins
now again we talked about in the last
video the Parker Robbins the hood has
really kind of been on this campaign to
try to take out Victor Von Doom now we
didn't initially know why this was the
case instead it was basically Parker
Robbins kind of reforming the sort of
modern-day masters of evil more or less
using some pretty low-level thugs and
then launching these little you know
small-time attacks against Doctor Doom
only for us to find out that the reason
why he's doing this is because his goal
is to basically steal the gold in
Latveria that's essentially the goal of
Parker Robbins here is to steal gold in
Liberia it's a pretty primitive goal but
then again Parker Robbins was never
really that great of a villain in the
first place and so it's one of the cool
things it actually goes on here's one of
the interesting situations uh what we
end up finding out is that one of the
guys he's brought along a guy by the
name of corruptor has the ability to
basically create these kind of psycho is
this sort of psychoactive effect in the
mind to force people to see like
hallucinations of the have the body
reacted in an exceedingly violent way
but he can only do it through like
physical contact but it's kind of a cool
thing because then at this point we
switch over to twenty Stark now remember
Tony Stark you know despite the fact
these kind of resurrected himself more
or less in like a new body basically uh
he's been having these hallucinations
you know with regards to like members of
the superhero community and even his own
family and in this instance he has a
hallucination of his dad now in reality
this is really more of like a
subconscious concept working its way to
the conscious mind and then him
basically dealing with
specifically with regards to the fact
that he was adopted because this was a
concept that Tony Stark never really
dealt with proper in the sense of like
he knew that he was adopted but he never
really was able to come to terms with
his father about it because his father
was dead but in this moment when he's
kind of going through this sort of
hallucinogenic state when his mind is
sort of restructuring itself and when
his bodies physically recovering he kind
of has this internal argument with his
father about the fact that you know we
never told me I was a dog to different
things like that but a really cool
points made here is that Howard Stark
basically says well the fact that you're
adopted is here relevant like you're
still my son
like I raised you as my son I taught you
everything you know I left you an empire
Neil I am as good as and in reality it's
true
while Tony Stark is a doctor the fact
that Howard Stark taught him everything
he needed to know about what it meant to
be a man to be successful to build on
his intelligence those are the only
things that really matter you know his
father was never in his life his father
was never there to teach him those
lessons Howard Stark was the one who was
and so really if if Tony hadn't been
told that he was adopted everything
would still stand everything would still
be the same so there really is no
difference here between Howard and the
actual father of Tony but the actual
father of Tony wool will make it
appearance here in Lowell law now
something else has been going on here is
that Friday has basically been kind of
subverting or programming to a degree
and going through and like hunting down
or trying to trace down the location of
Tony Stark which they were ultimately
successful in doing it was actually an
old shield bunker so again kind of
hitting back at the old Nick Fury era of
comics where he always had these safe
houses but when they get in there they
end up finding this the armor that Tony
Stark was in but he's basically outside
of his armor now he's essentially left
and so it's kind of cool because he's
out there doing his own thing
presumably trying to find a way to come
back now another funny little caveat
here this is kind of wild is what ends
up happening is that while Ruby Williams
is pondering the idea of walking away
because Oliver Tech was basically taken
by Stark Industries by the Board of
Board of Trustees when she's sitting
there basically mulling over the idea of
returning to MIT she's met with the
arrival of blade now apparently blade
works for shield I have no idea it's
been 15 years as I read a blade comic so
I can't tell you what the world blades
been doing all this and all this time I
mean I remember him from the movie and
that's it like this I am I am I know
almost nothing about blade anything
that's happened in the last 15 years
I don't know but she ultimately ends up
basically traveling back to MIT now when
she does what we end up finding out here
is that there are a handful of people
who are basically trying to track down
in addition to Ruby Williams herself one
of them is Tony Hall actually the the
daughter of Hinson ho the person that
helped when he start building mark one
when he was kidnapped in Vietnam and
then the other one or really though
there's a couple others but one of them
is Arno stark now if I'm being honest
here I don't really like the way that
bindus handles are no story he's just
kind of like a guy who's there and
that's sort of disappointing because
those of you guys who read Karen
Gillan's run of Ironman autostart played
a huge role the idea of him you
basically know after being revealed then
Arno is the actual biological son of
Howard a Maria that he's basically
smarter than Tony Stark you know that
he's kind of reduced here just being a
guy who needs the help of Ruby Williams
in order to crack a code it's kind of
weird because it's like saying like Reed
Richards can't figure something out on
his own and so he has to go to Ironman
to do it I mean you're talking about one
of the smartest people on the planet so
the fact that autostart would need any
body is a little mind-boggling here so
it's a little weird to me but again it
does give a pretty cool role to reread
in the sense that she asked something to
contribute here but at this point we
basically end up dealing with Ironman
being more or less defeated by Parker
Robbins now it's really more of a
smaller thing but this whole situation
basically has them traveling back to
Liberia and then basically Parker Robins
arriving with this huge you know army of
street-level thugs basically and then
all of them using their various powers
to take down the Doctor Doom is Iron Man
now it's kind of a funny thing here
because Bennis is somewhat playing on
the idea that Doctor Doom is you know
quote-unquote reformed right I mean if
this was classic Doctor Doom from like
Fantastic Four annual number two or
number four where's uh he would have
just made short work if he would just
kill them all and that would have been
the end of it he would have been like
you're done but he guys are all dead but
the fact that he's kind of trying to
turn over a new leaf trying to do the
right thing basically means that it's a
way for them to subvert his power ah to
essentially overcome him and then in
turn to feed him now some of its also
because of the fact that there's just so
many people there they just basically
overwhelm him the problem with this is
that once they manage to get through
they managed to essentially like break
into his armor he's gone he's basically
teleported out and so that information
is basically gone with him and so again
it's essentially a part where Robin is
kind of sitting around and saying okay
in order for us to find the location of
the gold in in Liberia we have to track
down Tony Stark because that's where
Doctor Doom is gonna go he's gonna go
find Tony so again it's kind of like
this mad rush everybody's looking to
find 20 Stark now switching back to
blade what we end up finding out here is
that in this whole situation what it
basically happened is he had gone to
really Williams and said a lot of people
are looking for a Tony Stark released
what
used to be show it's not really shield
anymore after secret Empire but it's
like a lot of people were looking for
Tony Stark you need to go to MIT because
there are people there that will help
you find Tony which of course now we
know is or no and and and Tony Howe and
so on and so forth but with them
basically banding together and then
going to seek out Tony what is up
happening is Friday software is totally
corrupted and she's basically possessed
by Tony Stark himself who literally says
stop looking for me like I have things I
need to take care of stop trying to
track me down like let me go do my thing
and then I will come and find you when
the time is right and so it's kind of a
cool moment here it's a cool little
segment to see the Tony Stark despite
the fact that he is believed to have
been dead or it lived very least he's
operating on bare-bones tech is still
able to out class almost everybody there
now what Tony actually ends up doing is
traveling directly to meet his mother
basically say hey look there's a few
things that I'm sorting out here but
it's kind of cool because that's this
you know the connection between the two
of them is pretty strong remember
they've only recently met each other and
so it's like the one thing Tony's been
trying to figure out is how to get back
to his mom and say hey look here's where
things stand everything's okay she's
kind of freaked out that he's bald a
little bit and he's like well you know I
mean I basically resurrected myself in a
new body so you know that happens but
what Tony does is also throw her
microphone of sorts and say like tell me
about my biological father now this is
the first real indication we actually
get about this the idea of Tony Stark's
biological father was neither hide nor
hear you didn't see anything about it
and even actually like the his
biological mom here you know Amanda we
didn't see anything about that until
like internationally so it was a few
years after the the introduction of the
idea that Tony was adopted before we
ever even saw any real expansion on that
now a lot of that was because Karen
Gillan took off he basically left and
went to go do his own thing but it is an
interesting scenario because what we end
up finding out here is that the father
of Tony Stark was a SHIELD agent who
turned Hydra and he actually started
selling out shield agents to Hydra and
it's interesting I'm not a hundred
percent sure how I feel about that but
again it's kind of a cool situation
because what it does is it creates a
potential enemy for Tony you know in the
sense that like what was his father
doing what were the kind of things that
he was getting into so on and so forth
and then the plot gets even crazier this
is the problem with Linda's writing is
occasionally he'll just go off the
reservation but this is actually pretty
cool in the middle of their attempt to
find Tony Stark riri Williams
Tony how all those guys are met with the
arrival of Leonardo da Vinci now on the
surface people are just kind of like
okay this is ridiculous
and maybe it is to a degree but recently
watch it going all the way back
Jonathan Hickman started I think was
Jonathan and Nick Trudeau doll remember
who it wasn't actually drew it they lost
a series called shield and it was a
miniseries that they went for issues and
there was unfinished for like seven
years or something crazy like that and
recently fought issues five and six were
finished but that was basically the
story of like the origin of shield and
Leonardo da Vinci was a member of a
group called the Brotherhood of the
shield which was the precursor to shield
itself and so there were a whole lot of
things that took place they were the
first ones to fight Galactus they were
the first ones to repel the Celestials
there were a lot of different things
that were going on there was a lot of
changing that was going on in the realm
of Marvel Comics uh and it's a really
really cool story we might cover at some
point it's actually pretty awesome
dealing with all that history and the
Marvel Universe but again what we also
end up finding out here is that we're
Amanda Armstrong it basically told Tony
looked like I killed your father
essentially is what happened your father
turned out to be a Hydra agent and I
killed him to protect you we end up
finding out that his father is actually
alive and it's cool here because again
what this means this could play a very
very very big role in the life of xx
start tracking down as Hydra agent
father now this also follows up with
Tony trying to make amends and trying to
fix things essentially by resurrecting
James Rhodes now with James Rhodes being
brought back with his mind simply being
downloaded into like a new consciousness
of sorts things just kind of pick up as
if they never stopped in the sense that
my James Rhodes essentially has all the
memories of everything that happened
even the fact that he was killed by
Thanos but we also kind of end up doing
is you know with James Rhodes being
resurrected it's a chance for him and
Tony Stark to meet but for Tony Stark to
also sort of get him back in gear get
him ready to be war machine and then we
switch back over to Leonardo da Vinci
now the fact that Leonardo da Vinci
helped to establish shield he kind of
gives us a sort of backstory and simply
saying that like he's been watching from
the shadows the entire time and we're
shield was basically corrupted where he
was essentially brought down by by Steve
Rogers and were shielded kind of grown
into this sort of unwieldly unruly
giant massive intelligence organization
that could have presumably brought
everything crashing down which
ultimately ended up happening in secret
empire that shield did not maintain its
original charter to be a protector of
all life on earth that's really the
original basis behind his formation by
Leonardo da Vinci and a handful of
others and so because of this da Vinci
has kind of gone back and sort of
reworked what shield is supposed to be
not in the sense that he's recreated it
but in the sense that he's kind of
making something akin to it but it is
kind of cool because like Miles Morales
for example is brought in it's really
kind of like a veritable who's who of
people who have
iron man or who were exceedingly smart
or capable in their own right there's a
variety of reasons of you know for why
people are being brought in here but the
fact remains that what we end up
basically doing is picking up with
Parker robbers when we end up learning
that with him going after Tony Stark in
order to beat Doctor Doom there and then
basically realizing that Tony Stark is
missing and that the the board of
directors essentially you know Eric
Lynch is trying to go through and seize
control of the company
Parker Robin sees it as a means to rule
directly what Parker Robbins does is he
basically approaches Eric Lynch and he's
like I get smelt like Howard from a mile
away and you are certainly a coward and
so the idea is I've got a gun to your
head you're gonna give me power of
attorney over like you're a whole
position and so you're gonna step down I
will step into your role and then I will
run Stark Industries it's it's actually
a genius idea now of course what do you
have James Rhodes and then you have Tony
Stark respond as well as Doctor Doom
Iron Man all showing up at the same time
it's like this massive conflict against
the forces of Parker Robbins alongside
like all these Iron Man guys now the
fight is not supremely drawn-out and so
one of the things that ends up happening
when Parker Robbins goes to attack
Doctor Doom what he does is kind of undo
what it was at Reed Richards did in
terms of fixing his face and go back to
scarring his face again now this really
looks to set the stage for like Doctor
Doom going back to his classic outfit
now how do you do that I don't really
know because doctor dooms face was fixed
by the power beyonders these nine
omnipotent you know multiversal beings
that destroyed the cosmic entities but
once the whole conflict is basically you
know once it ends once it all comes
crashing down then what you end up
having is Ruby Williams who's
essentially kind of taken under the wing
I guess again by Tony Stark
as well as James Rhodes who comes back
as war machine and then it's just kind
of like what comes next that's really
sort of the the question that's being
that's lingering here is what's gonna
happen after this now of course also dr.
Doom's face is all scarred to pieces so
again this whole idea that he's going to
go back and turn you know turn into you
know Victor Von Doom again especially
because of the fact that he's
essentially rebuilding Latveria
sending things back to rights returning
to the role that he's supposed to be
again it's very much been discounting at
these loose ends from the the story as
it's existed since the beginning of
all-new all-different marvel running up
to the modern day as well as bringing
Doctor Doom back to the original Doctor
Doom so again it's one of these things
where models setting things back to the
classic way you know to the way that
they used to be the way that they've
been doing it for sixty years going back
to the same old thing so you know it's
kind of got a mixed reaction for me
as somebody who's been reading comics
for so long it's the same old thing I've
been seen before which actually takes me
away from being interested in it but for
the new person it's all new to them it's
an you know it's all like I've never
seen anything like this before so it's
kind of a it's it's fresh stuff for all
of them for all you new guys so you know
I'm kind of curious
okay what's your also what's your all's
take on this like are you guys in favor
of like the new direction of things
telling new stories that we haven't seen
before or you guys in favor of the
classic things and just kind of
rehashing older stories in different
ways well that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here too comments explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]
[Music]
you